oh
is right up here because i'm not eating
at the right time
when he comes in
um
[Music]
i tell you
oh
avon
i'm going to have to ask for extra
comfort breaks today
it's all right
yeah because my blood sugar has gone is
up completely to pot
it's just i need to cover because i'm
having to drink so much
and of course you drink a lot you need
to survey a lot so i might say some i
need a five-minute comfort break
it won't be continued if if it's get
it's not a case if it's getting
awkward i want oh i'm not gonna sense
this i'll answer all the questions and
then once i've answered them
thank you
it's only because my levels are going
shooting up through the roof
sorry i'm done
is
uh
[Music]
oh yeah yeah so because there must be
because even because they must be
getting older what liquid must be just
evaporating
because andrew must have just decided to
give me the older ones you know do not
just like the nose ones
i've got the throat and
[Music]
oh thank you
yes
um
[Music]
[Music]
morning
thank you very much
lead
yes
yes
so well good morning ladies and
gentlemen it's nine o'clock the inquiry
is resumed
just the usual housekeeping points um
attendance list i hope is circulating so
please put your details on that before
you leave today
and
mobile phones if you've got one please
make sure it's switched off or on silent
whilst the inquiry is sitting
in terms of paperwork
i've been handed
some um redacted
photographs from the rule six party to
replace uh evidence
submitted earlier so thank you for that
and i understand there's another
batch to be submitted shortly that's
correct sir yep thank you
thank you for that
um the only other thing i wanted to say
is that
i
saw
an email from the inspectorates case
officer
um with
um
forwarding
an email from
the mp mr francoise which had got
attachments to it
of the
inspector's report and
um secretary of state decision that he
referred to
in his presentation
has that found its way to the parties
yeah um he called me this morning to let
me know it's on the way and just just to
reiterate it's what he said he would do
after he gave you his evidence yes yes
i'm quite happy with that the only
reason for me raising it is i'm going to
ask the council if it's possible for
them to print out a copy for me
i think we've got one for the inspector
so we i don't need it at the minute i
don't you know
but
i'm not sure we've received the email
but we had already printed a copy of the
appeal decision right okay well i'll
at the
morning adjournment mid-morning
adjournment i will check with the
inspector's case officer whether that's
been forwarded to the party not to us
sir not so far not so far okay well
thank you i i spotted that he'd come in
first thing this morning so i'll i'll
contact him and make sure it gets sent
on but i mean you're aware of what it is
that he's referring to they're the only
attachments to the best of my knowledge
that's not a problem okay
anything else from any of the parties
then before we
move on to today's business if i may sir
um
just briefly um i would imagine that
this afternoon i will start presenting
my evidence at some point hopefully yes
and
as i mentioned uh there is a planning
meeting this evening i've managed to
find a substitute for me in that meeting
and therefore i would suggest in order
to save time and get it over with
when i finished evidence and
cross-examination starts we continue
through to its end however late that
might be
well we'll i i appreciate what you're
saying i will certainly bear that in
mind but obviously i need to consider
the
well-being of all participants so we'll
we'll see how things go but it's good
that you're prepared to not be
constrained by that committee meeting so
thank you for that
there are there are no restrictions on
the time for this use of this room
either i checked that on the the first
day
yeah okay well let's bear that in mind
and see how things go
anything from yourself mr parkinson no
miss reed
no in that case would you like to begin
your
cross-examination of counsellor sure
then please i would do sir
oh sorry sorry before you start i was
just going to double check uh you you
gave me a time estimate of three to
three and a half hours i want to know if
that still stands okay so i'll be able
to check progress again hopefully yeah
okay
good morning council ashore good morning
now um
i just want to uh
start by looking at your proof of
evidence i'm hoping that we're going to
go to documents that we've tried to help
tab up for you
just to move things on so if you could
turn up your proof please
so you set out in your proof of evidence
uh that you are an affiliate member of
the rcpi
um is is that as a result of the time
you've spent as um chair of the um
committee in terms of the experience as
opposed to any professional
qualifications in planning it's since
i've been a on the committee um itself
not just being the chair yeah i haven't
i'm not i haven't got any formal
planning uh qualifications
now um what you do in your proof of
evidence that paragraph 3.7
3.7
is you set out the
key concerns
of the committee and those are points a
to f that we looked at we've looked at
before a little bit with councillor eves
you see that yes yeah
and so just to be clear and it was a
point i set out with council eves as
well
is that um particularly since you're an
affiliate member of the rtpi you would
have been aware of the importance of
setting out in detail
the basis of your case and your proof of
evidence wouldn't you yes good
and so we can understand that the points
that you wish to raise um against the
scheme are set out comprehensively in
your proof of evidence and also in the
evidence of council reeves that you take
into account in your evidence
good
and so in respect of um paragraphs a to
e
what you say at paragraph 3.8
is that in terms of those substantive
matters you were providing evidence
about
a b d and e and councillor eaves was um
giving the evidence in respect of points
c and f which were effectively the
congestion points he discussed yesterday
and also the highway safety point that
he had in respect of the rectory road
improvements yes
and
in respect
of those points in respect of those
points then
um
paragraphs
a
relates to the width of the pavement
outside the school
b pedestrian safety generally
and the package of measures proposed by
the appellant
at d
related to
parking space for the school
and e related to the loss of the
designated cycle lane and the proposal
of a shared use space with pedestrians
outside the school which was a initially
set out to be a highway safety concern
wasn't it yes
and um it's now the position
that you do not or well you the local
planning authority does not pursue ever
um a case in respect of any of those
points that's correct but i still
believe there is a um
problems and concerns regarding hop farm
school with the width of the pavement
being reduced yes i i understood your
evidence in that respect and we'll turn
on to that later and that's something
that feeds into the planning balance
isn't it because you're aware that
paragraph 111 of the mppf
sets out that um schemes should only be
refused
where there are unacceptable highway
safety issues so you're not suggesting
that these matters should lead now to a
refusal of permission your point is that
those disadvantages should be weighed in
the overall balance as i understand it
yeah okay good
now um next point and it's just a point
of clarification at the outset so that
we know exactly where we are with this
there is a
there are a number of statements of
common ground that have been signed
um on the part of the council
i'm going to focus because your evidence
is on the planning side of matters
on the planning statement of common
ground and there's also housing land
statements of common ground
i assume because you've not told us
otherwise in your proof of evidence or
an examination in chief that you accept
that the content of those statements of
common ground re reflect the position of
the local planning authority yes i do
thank you
good
um and um
thank you
now in respect um of the uh congestion
points raised by council eves i know you
raised some points at the outset in
respect of your experience just to be
clear i'm
i've raised my points in respect to
council reeves already so i'm not going
to ask you about those it's not that we
accept the position but there's no point
going over that ground because your
evidence focuses on these other matters
um now
what you say um at paragraph 2.1 of your
proof of evidence is that you present
the planning case for the local planning
authority don't you yes i do yeah
and um you say at paragraph 4.2
at paragraph 4.2 that you recognize that
the starting point for determination
is the development plan and that
application should be determined in
accordance with the development plan and
less material considerations
indicate otherwise yeah
good
and to be clear the count the core
strategy and the allocations plan
are the council's development plan
aren't they not the appellants the
council's development plan the local
plan
yeah it's the council's plan isn't it
please thank you
and you have a copy of the mppf please
in front of you
yes
good you're faster than me just a sec
paragraph uh 15 please
sorry
and what paragraph 15 of the framework
tells us
is that the planning system should be
genuinely plan led
succinct and up-to-date plans should
provide a positive vision for the future
of each area a framework for addressing
housing needs and other economic social
and environmental priorities and a
platform for local people to shape their
surroundings so that is essentially why
we have section 386 isn't it and it
reflects the purpose of the plan led
system yes
and it's no part of the council's case
either in your examination in chief or
in your
proof of evidence to say
um that um the plan
um fails to reflect national priorities
is it
no but it is out of date well it's out
of date because well when you say it's
out of date the policies within it that
are out of date are the housing policies
because the housing numbers in the plan
are lower than those now implied by the
standard methodology you understand that
oh yes so that's that's why it's out
today because um the methodology has
changed yeah and the figures have
changed yeah but that the figures the
figures have gone up it's changed yeah
no the figures have gone up haven't they
yeah yeah and that's recorded in the
statements of common ground but at no
point in your proof of evidence or your
examination in chief have you suggested
that less weight should be accorded to
the policies of the development plan no
not at all no so the inspector can
record then that full weight should be
accorded to the policies of the
council's development plan yes thank you
and it is no part of your case either an
examination in chief or through your
proof of evidence to indicate that there
have been any material change in cert
changes in circumstances
following the adoption of the plan
and it follows from what you've just
said full weight to the policies that
indicates that less weight should be
given to the policies of the plan that's
not part of your case i accept what i uh
counselling said regarding the severity
of the congestion well that that relates
to the individual impacts of the scheme
which we'll turn on to i'm dealing with
the broad point at the moment in respect
of weight that should be attributed to
the policies of the development plan
you don't identify in your proof of
evidence or examination in chief that
there have been any material changes in
circumstances since the plan was adopted
that would justify a decision that less
weight should be given to any of those
policies do you no
good
um
now
in respect of
yeah in just bear with me a second in
respect of the framework
um we can see
we can see
um
at 16
paragraph 16
plan should and it tells us what plan
should do
um and um
you you confirmed with me a moment ago
that it's no part of your case that the
plan is inconsistent with the framework
so you accept that the
development plan although adopted prior
to
this iteration of the framework
reflects the objectives of the framework
i think we agreed that a moment ago
in respect of paragraph 16
paragraph 16 we see the directive that
plans should
be shaped by early proportionate and
effective engagement
between plan makers and communities
local organizations businesses
infrastructure providers operators and
statutory council teams you see that so
can i stop you there plan 16 should
where what are you reading a b c d to f
what one part are you reading that uh c
plan show yeah thank you absolutely got
it thank you very much okay so just take
a moment if you want to i can read it
again so i can read it thank you if you
want to carry on i'll read it thank you
okay okay plan should so that the point
there be shaped by early proportionate
and effective engagement between plan
makers and communities local
organizations businesses infrastructure
providers and operators and statutory
council teas
so
the plan would have been the core
strategy would have been prepared
by the council council's plan
um and would have been shaped therefore
by
engagement um between the local planning
authorities communities
infrastructure providers and statutory
council teams in accordance with those
points that are set out there yes yes it
would thank you and we can see it so you
can pop aside the framework now
for the minute and we might turn back to
it in a moment but let's try and keep on
top of the
new documents in this case if you turn
up please the core documents and um
hopefully you've got a tab in the core
strategy
um
sorry we're in the i'm so sorry sir it's
called it's called document 6.1 6.1
sorry sir obviously i've not been
through your papers yeah you'll
you'll need to keep giving me a heads up
on which one i'm turning yeah i'm so
sorry
so do you have to have a copy of the
core strategy account sorry core
strategy counselor i have good thank you
very much
and if you turn up page 8 please we're
going to start at page
and of course just just as context the
core strategy is the strategy for
um the entirety of the district isn't it
not just one particular part of it
that's full of rock tradition yet
exactly so if we look at paragraph 1.11
we can see at paragraph 1.11 that it is
reflected there that community
involvement is an essential part of the
plan making process
there has been ongoing community
involvement in the preparation of
rochford's core strategy and in
particular at three key stages core
strategy issues and options core
strategy preferred options and core
strategy
revised preferred options
and then at 1.12
consultation on the course strategy has
been carried out in accordance with the
council's adopted statement of community
involvement
and then at 1.13
um
in addition to
community involvement on proposed
policies within the core strategy
consultation has also been undertaken in
relation to aspects of the evidence base
and particularly in respect of
deliverability and viability of
residential development locations so two
points arising from that firstly the
core strategy um reflects that there was
extensive community involvement as one
would expect and prior to the adoption
of the core strategy
i can't answer that because i wasn't on
the council at that time
i wasn't elected when this come through
okay but i understand that but but the
core strategy on its face those
paragraphs that i've just read out to
you reflects the fact reflects the fact
that there was community consultation
and involvement in the plan making
process
that was carried out in accordance with
the council's statement of community
involvement that's what it says in those
paragraphs my experience with the
council that that is what would have
happened you
and secondly what we can see from these
paragraphs here as well is that in terms
of in addition to the community
involvement consideration was given to
all aspects of the evidence base
particularly in respect to the
deliverability and viability of
residential development locations so
consideration was given to the
deliverability of the residential
development locations that were then
promoted through the core strategy
it was but it would have been
the residents would
would have objected to various sites
yeah and and that's the purpose of the
plan led process isn't it it's that
those concerns are listened to by the
local planning authority going through
what we see in 1.11 which is the issues
and options stage the core strategy
preferred options stage and then here
revised preferred options and all of
those matters are taken into account
along with other matters such as the
council's housing needs for example
and then a judgment is taken as to the
most appropriate
locations for development which are
those promoted by the council through
the plan process yes
um
good and again in in deciding and
determining the most appropriate
locations for growth the council would
have considered um the um consultation
responses
of all of its residents clearly not just
those in one particular area
each when they do the local plan and
they get the
allocated land come forward
where that is they will the council will
do a
plan
for that re area so if we've got
something in rochford
those consultations will not go out to
rayleigh it's just
subject to where where we are
but this has gone through
um and i believe uh councillor eaves has
said already said this
the roads have got busier
this was kate all the scr8 site was come
up put forward
and the traffic wasn't as bad as it is
today yeah and i think that is a
consideration okay well we'll look at
that in a moment but i did ask you at
the beginning and you confirm that
you're not relying on any material
considerations that have happened since
adoption
which indicate that less weight should
be given to the policies and i'm going
to look at the impacts of the scheme
with you in the planning balance but
that was the answer that you gave me
now in terms of the plan then
in terms of the plan
and the purpose of the plan and this is
sorry you're going to need the framework
again
the purpose of this is if we look at
paragraph 20 of the framework
um
it tells us that strategic policies
should set out an overall strategy for
the pattern scale and design quality of
places
and make sufficient provision for a
number of matters and one of which is
housing which is point a you see that
yes
so the purpose of the core strategy is
to set out the strategic policy
setting out the council's overall
strategy for the pattern scale design
quality of places and to make sufficient
provision for housing amongst other
matters yeah
and
obviously
because where you're providing
development it it and because there is a
requirement of national policy to
provide um for sufficient housing in
your area
it is the case that through the plan led
system the council will
need to undertake a balance
um and consider the balance um in
respect essentially of various interests
so on the one hand the need for housing
and on the other hand other
considerations yes
um and i just want to understand in that
context a little bit about the overall
strategy before drilling down into some
points so if you go back to the core
strategy and it's page 27 this time
please
[Applause]
and so this is just so that we
understand a little bit about the
context of the district
um
and we can see at page 27 of the core
strategies there is a heading issues and
options
and opportunities sorry
yes opportunities thank you sir
issues and opportunities um and we can
see at um paragraph two point in la 2.11
it says this
locations for development are limited by
physical constraints
including land at risk of flooding areas
protected for their landscape values
sites protected for ecological value etc
some such areas are of local regional
national and international importance
including those protected by the eu
habitats directive
and we can also see if we move on to
2.33
again issues and opportunities
on page 29 just over the page
we see this the the district is
predominantly green belt tightly drawn
around existing settlements the vast
majority of which is undeveloped there
is a limit to how much infilling and
intensification existing settlements can
sustain without their character being
adversely affected particularly given
the district contains 10 conservation
areas as such there are concerns as to
land uptake and loss of greenfield land
that the housing requirement will
engender
and then at 2.34 potential housing
development land is further limited by
the fact that much of the district is
subject to constraints which prohibit
the development of housing such as flood
zone 3 or areas of ecological importance
details of land subject constraints are
included in the sea baseline information
sorry baseline information profile
and then if we just put that in context
and turn up page 173 please
sorry page 173
and it's the key diagram it's right at
the back so just a few pages from the
back
yep thank you
and we can see here that this is the key
diagram
showing those constraints that we've
just
um spoken about and we can see
um that effectively most of the district
is washed over by the green belt those
are the areas of green on the on the
diagram yeah
and also we can see
to the east areas of coastal protection
belt as well
and so that the point really is that in
terms of the district as a whole
and the opportunities for development it
is a district that is heavily
constrained by
landscape greenbelt and ecological
designations that limit
the opportunities for new development to
come forward isn't it well we have
brownfield sites that could be taken up
one that hasn't happened in this
core strategy okay but as a whole if you
look at if you look at the district as a
whole in terms of additional
opportunities for growth
we can see the large areas of greenbelt
the coastal protection ecological
designations just went to the paragraphs
where the core strategy confirms
that there are limited opportunities for
growth
based on those green belt ecological
um and landscape designations as this
i've got a lot of background i'm sorry
as per this map shows yes yes thank you
good so limited opportunities for growth
based on those constraints and if we
turn back to page 32 please
[Music]
page 32 and 33 under the heading
transport
and um we can see at 2.6
the strength of these spheres of
influence of the large neighboring
centres of south end basildon and
chelmsford mean that traffic is drawn
through rochford district's own centers
to them
this not only has an impact on traffic
congestion in general but also engenders
concern with regard to air quality
within the district's town centre
this
situation has the potential to be
exacerbated if development is not
directed to the the appropriate
locations around the settlements
particular locations where there's a
concern include east of raleigh where
commuters to basildon and chelmsford are
drawn through the centre west of hockley
where those commuting by car to south
end or chelmsford basildon are drawn
through the center of hockley or
rayleigh respectively and east of
rochford
east of rochford where vehicular
movements would inevitably be directed
through rochford's historic center
given such concerns the location of
future development must be considered
alongside opportunities to locate
development in areas where alternatives
to car use are more viable alongside
other sustainability issues so just
taking a couple of points from that
first one is that traffic issues traffic
issues arise across the district as a
whole including in the other tier one
settlements
yeah
secondly areas of particular concern
that are flagged up in this paragraph in
respect of congestion
do not include ashington do they
yes it will do because it's going
through it's it has said here
that it will be directed through
um
yeah it's talking about east of rochford
there do you see and east of rochford
where vehicular movements will be
directed through the center yes but it
says given such concerns the location of
future development must be considered
alongside opportunities so if we got um
a new
development where this scr8 is it will
then be pushing all traffic
to yashinda road it will not be pushing
it out to um
the easter rockford or through hockley
rayleigh will it right so that's again
in terms of the implications of this
scheme which we're going to turn on to
in a moment but just looking sorry just
looking at this paragraph
traffic congestion is an issue across
the district
ashingdon is not specifically identified
as one of the points of concern in this
paragraph is it
no because is that because it's not scr
is not being mentioned in it no exactly
and then number three the point that you
raised a moment ago is the last sentence
of that tells us
that given concerns
such concerns the location of future
development must be considered alongside
opportunities to locate developments in
areas where alternatives to car use are
more viable alongside other
sustainability issues so what that's
telling us is that the core strategy
recognized that given the issues in
respect of
congestion and traffic across the
district
the strategy would be to direct
development to areas where alternatives
to car use are more viable alongside
other sustainability
issues that's what it tells us it does
but i would like to know where um how
we have a lot of residents at work at
south end hospital
so i'd like to know how
if we have this sera how they're going
they can't walk to the hospital they
can't cycle to the hospital and there's
not a bus where there's one bus that
goes whenever and there's not a train
station so they will need the cars okay
well we're going to look at the relative
sustainability of the the settlement in
terms of what the core strategy says
about it
now
if we turn up next please page 43
and sorry just just be clear clear sorry
just just taking a step back one of this
point about issues across the district
in terms of traffic
um
including in other tier one settlements
rayleigh and hockley we can see those
are the ones in the table on page 43.
those are issues i presume that you
accept still exist oh they do yes thank
you
um and um
also in terms of tier two
holbridge and great wakering i think
those are issues that still exist there
as well aren't they and i guess it was
yeah getting worse right
um
so um if we if we look at that page we
can see that there are essentially um
three tier one settlements that are
identified
rayleigh rochford ashington hockley
hawkwell
and so ashingdon together with rochwell
is classified as a settlement at the top
of the settlement hierarchy in tier one
isn't it you meant rockford didn't you
not rockwell
sorry just you said rochefort
so you meant rockford yes yes i did yes
sorry
um and um
yeah
and um in terms of uh yeah so top of the
settlement hierarchy and um if we look
at what that means in 4.1
sorry 4.9 um we can see
we can see
as described in the spatial
characteristics issues and opportunities
chapter of the document the district
contains a number of settlements
some of these settlements although they
have their own distinct identities are
not functionally separate from their
neighbours and for the purposes of the
core strategy have been grouped together
as one namely rochford ashington and
hockley hawkwell
these settlements groups of settlements
can be divided into four tiers with the
settlements in the higher tiers being
more developed subject to greater
housing demand and need and generally
more suitable to accommodate additional
housing for the reasons described above
and then the settlement hierarchy as
follows so the tier one settlements are
the settlements that the core strategy
identifies
as being the more suitable
um settlements to accommodate additional
housing that's what we're told in 4.9
that is what we're told yes
um and then if we go back to page 33
please
we can see
we can see at 2.60
the point that there is a high level of
car ownership um in the
district however the proportion of
people traveling to work by public
transport is greater than the national
and regional averages primarily due to
the accessibility of rail links from the
district's three main urban areas
away from the three main settlements car
dependency is high congestion and
environmental impacts will continue to
worsen with population growth if this
trend is not reversed so just pausing
there several points arising from that
firstly the plan is expressly
recognizing
expressly recognizing that car
dependency is particularly high away
from the three main settlements so it's
saying positions worse outside of those
three main settlements in the villages
you need a car to get to anywhere
because there isn't any public transport
of any salt yeah
exactly
um and so the second point is um that
is that in terms of issues in respect of
congestion and environmental impacts the
core strategy this is 2.61 recognizes
that that will continue to worsen with
population growth if this trend is not
reversed so it's really emphasizing
there the importance the importance of
encouraging
people to use sustainable transport
modes isn't it well i'd like to know how
that can be can uh be achieved when the
villages are five miles away from the
local train station yeah but it can't
walk and
that means more cars will be coming in
to the um from the ambulance junction
through to um
up through to the station
so you know we we have got a congestion
problem
with um
cars coming in from the villages
and these villages aren't like two or
three houses you're talking um you can
talk
their calls still call themselves
villages but there could be five six
hundred houses there yeah so so
that those are the issues in respect of
the the villagers but what we can see if
you look at 2.63
is
the lack of public transport provision
through most of the district is an
obstacle to reducing car dependency
there is however some opportunity to
utilize public transport particularly
within the three main settlements which
contain rail links between each other
south end and london
so just just pausing there what the core
strategy is doing because it's got these
top tier settlements the three top tier
settlements the most
sustainable locations for growth in the
district and then you've got your
villagers that sit below that as you've
explained there are limited
opportunities and there are issues in
terms of car ownership
what the core strategy is is doing is it
is focusing development to the top tier
settlements where there is more
opportunity
to use sustainable transport modes
that's what we're being told in 2.61 and
2.63
that's what we've been told but it's not
practical i i don't agree with these
statements
but this is your council's adopted
development plan maybe
maybe that but doesn't mean you have to
agree with everything that's written
down in paper
um
and um
in terms of um
yeah in terms of the statement of common
ground which you confirmed to me at the
outset that you confirmed to me at the
outset that you do not dispute could you
turn that up please
just bear with me a second
yeah give me a moment as well
sorry that was the planning statement
so yes please
[Music]
sorry just bear with me a minute sir
it's my planning one appears to have
fallen out here
so this is the local authorities agreed
position in respect of accessibility
and um there is agreement there is
agreement here that the appeal site
that the appeal site is located within
walking and cycling distance of a range
of local facilities and services
including and i'm not going to read them
all out but they're they're set out
there
and then at 5.9.2
it's agreed that these facilities are
located within the national travel
survey 2020 average walking distance of
1.36 kilometers
and all facilities are located within
the manual for streets suggested upper
limit
referenced in the form of ppg-13
guidance of two kilometers furthermore
all the facilities located within the
institute of highways and transports
preferred maximum walking distance of
1.2 kilometers so
quite a lot of technical speak there but
broadly the point is at 5.9.1
it is agreed that the appeals site is
located within walking and cycling
distance of a range of local facilities
as set out in the statements of common
ground isn't it yes if they're in good
health they can work we've got a very
older um population
sorry say that one again i didn't quite
catch it yeah
yes if you're able you're well enough to
walk we have a very elderly population
in rockford
who do depend on their carb for that
reason
um and um if we then turn back to the
core strategy
2.67 on page 35
and we then have this within the
district there are four tiers of
settlement we've just looked at those
already the first tier comprises
rayleigh rochford and hockley we know
that it's rochefort ashington and
hockley we've just looked at that but
then we see this
these are all settlements with a range
of services and facilities as well as
some access to public transport so it's
recognizing the point that we've just
looked at in the statement of common
ground there you see that yes yeah
and then at 2.68
um of the first tier settlements
rayleigh has the best access to services
within the district and then rochford
and hockley contain local town centres
catering for local need
and then later on in that paragraph it's
recognizing that rochford is a local
centre you see that i can but this when
this was done that was correct if you
look at rochefort town centre it's now
very lacking of shops and amenities okay
but
charity shops if you want anything okay
but it's still sorry it's still
in the statements of common ground
accepted still accepted
that uh
the site is within walking and cycling
distance of a range of local facilities
isn't it yeah you can walk there there's
no facilities well there's well there's
a cafe well yeah but
excuse me to interrupt you but if you're
um a young mom that needs food
um for their children
or other amenities for their children
there's hardly anything that they have
to go into south end
um for their school uniforms they can
only get get it in one place in south
end they can't even go to jump on a bus
or a train to
hockley or rayleigh to get these things
for their children that schools demand
but at 2.63 of the course strategy on
page 33 we see that in respect of the
tier 1 settlements there is some
opportunity to use public transport
particularly within the main settlements
which contain rail links between each
other south end and london that's right
isn't it the um bus services have been
completely been cut
since the covied
because um obviously people working from
home and they have not been increased
there's a meeting next week regarding
the bus with essex county council to
actually advise us how
it's increasing
okay just
in respect of that point you've seen
that the
uh
appeals scheme will contribute a
significant contribution towards
improving and enhancing the bus services
i assume that's something that you would
welcome
um
if it was actually going as councillor
eve said yesterday we've had money go
into
bus services but if the bus services and
we know this is gone down by 64 percent
if
they don't deem that a bus is necessary
it's not anybody
who has a business and a business brain
will not run a bus empty
or just for one or two passengers
people are still very very worried about
this kovid as we've seen today none of
us need to wear masks but a few of us
have walked in with masks and people are
concerned so they will not get on buses
they will actually still use their cars
so that means the buses bus companies
will not actually
put money into car buses when it's not
necessary and apart from that if you're
sitting having a bus idling a bus
station or a bus stop it's causing
air pollution right
councillor
you have not put any evidence at all
before the inquiry have you
in respect of the viability
the viability
of the bus service
provision that exists or is proposed no
i refused it on pedestrian safety
yeah then those concerns have now been
resolved um now in respect of um
in respect of just moving back to the
moving back to the core strategy
so um what we can see from all of that
and irrespective of what you think about
the current position
what the core strategy does having
recognized the constraints in greenbelt
landscape ecological terms and the
traffic issues across the district
it seeks to deal with that by as well as
it can
by directing growth
to the most the most sustainable
locations in the district those three
top-tier settlements doesn't it it's
considered to be yes
good
and if we look back at the framework if
we look back at the framework please
paragraph 105 this time
sorry what paragraph sorry one zero five
we have the planning system should
actively manage patterns of growth in
support of these objectives these
objectives being sustainability
objectives which are set out
in the paragraph 104c above
for example the planning system should
actively manage patterns of growth in
support of these objectives
significant development should be
focused on locations which are or can be
made sustainable through limiting the
need to travel and offering a genuine
choice of transport modes this can help
reduce congestion and emissions improve
air quality and public health and then
it talks about the difference between
urban and rural areas but
the point is here is that that strategy
of the council's plan
of directing growth to the tier one
settlements
is consistent with that paragraph of the
framework isn't it yes it is
and um
in terms of the impact that that
strategy of directing growth to those
top tier settlements including rochford
and ashington
might have if you look at 3.8 please 3.8
sorry 3.88 and the core strategy sir
paragraph page 37.
what we can see at 3.8 is
the council's balanced strategy to the
distribution of housing is beginning to
take shape housing development is
focused on the settlements with the
greatest range of services and
facilities but directing a proportion to
smaller settlements to ensure that rural
communities are nurtured and
sustained at the same time the
distribution of housing is balanced
ensuring that there is a fair and equal
division of new development across the
district providing new sustainable
residential developments to carefully
planned well related to infrastructure
community facilities and play spaces so
just pausing there the strategy within
the core strategy the distribution of
housing within it
is considered or sorry it was considered
by the council to be balanced and a fair
and equal division of new developments
across the district it's saying
directing a proportion of smaller
settlements but 662 houses isn't small
is it
that that part there counselor is is
talking about the smaller settlements or
the ones that are lower down the
settlement hierarchy
so what it's saying is that it's it's
looked at the issues that you've got in
the villages that you've described
and it's obviously looked at the
landscape greenbelt ecological
constraints the traffic issues across
the district
and it's come to a distribution that it
describes as balanced
ensuring that there is a fair and equal
division of new development across the
district you see that
yeah
good and um we then turn please to
uh
page 41 please of the core strategy
which is telling us about housing
and we can see that a number of um
objectives
a number of objectives are set out
at page 41 which we can look to
um
and
they
include in one ensuring a delivery of an
adequate supply
two delivering a balanced strategy for
the distribution of housing
uh directing housing growth to the most
sustainable locations so that's the tier
one settlements having regard to social
economic and environmental
considerations
the next one's about
rural services and settlements they're
not concerning us in here
and then prioritizing the redevelopment
of appropriate brownfield sites and
minimizing the release of greenbelt land
for development
and ensuring the delivery of housing
catering for all needs
for the needs of all communities in
terms of tenure type and location and
ensuring appropriate infrastructure
which we'll turn on to in a moment
and then over the page we see it 4.1 in
respect of housing
it is important that the pla that
planning ensures the provision of
sufficient good quality new homes in
appropriate and sustainable locations
so just pausing there it is a priority
of the council's core strategy as well
as national policy
to secure a sufficient supply of housing
to meet its needs isn't it
it is but as we've said um we need uh
the right homes in the right places with
the right infrastructure yeah well we'll
look at the scheme in a minute and we'll
look at what the council's policy does
about that but i've noted um
your answer
and um if we um turn then to i'm going
to turn and look at housing in a little
bit more detail later but if we look at
five
2.35
of course sorry in the core strategy
two point two point three five zero page
thirty
and we can see just in terms of what the
plan does and what the plan recognizes
there is a high level of home ownership
in the district however concealed
households personal persons living with
a household wanting to move their um to
their own accommodation and form a
separate household eg adult children
living with their parents
are largely unable to afford to enter
the local housing market due to the gap
between house prices and income there is
a limited supply of affordable housing
in the district and the development of
additional affordable units across the
region is not keeping pace with demand
um so just pausing there that's noting a
particular issue in respect of the
supply of affordable housing in the
district isn't it it is
um and um if we then look at 2.36
there's reference to the shmar there the
strategic housing market assessment
also examines the need for different
forms of affordable housing
and then we see a recognition
that there is an acute and that's the
word of the plan an acute need for
social rented
housing as well as significant potential
uh market for intermediate housing so an
acute need recognized in the plan for
additional affordable housing it's a
very broad definition of what affordable
is
what people on very high incomes can
afford a half a million pound house
people who are on very low incomes
and i hope i'm not insulting anyone
who's listening this on people with
carers who are carers on lower wages
cannot afford
any of these new houses in this in any
of these new developments that are
coming forward so we still will have the
need for reasonably priced
affordable housing which i don't think
we have in this plan right okay well
we'll look at what
the appeal proposals are providing a
little bit later but my question here
was that the development plan recognizes
that there is an acute it uses the word
acute need
for additional affordable housing
definitely there is definitely an acute
acute need that needs to be addressed
and in terms of
rochford specifically
we can see that at 2.37
that acute need that we've just looked
at it says this housing needs studies
and other data from sources such as the
housing waiting list
indicate
that demand for housing is focused
primarily on the district's largest
settlements of rayleigh hockley and
rochford and there is demand as well in
other settlements so it's identifying
a focus in respect of affordable housing
need in those top tier settlements isn't
it that's where the concentration of
people are yeah
so a focus for affordable housing need
in those top tier satellites
okay
and then we can see that reflected in
the table at 2.38
which is a snapshot i appreciate that
housing waiting lists are always a
snapshot but this is the snapshot that's
been included in the council's core
strategy as an indication
and we can see a snapshot of housing
need based on the council's housing
waiting list in 2009 indicated demand as
follows
and rochford was second
29
of the district's total so presume that
we can agree
well we agree acute affordable housing
need across the district focus of
affordable housing need in top tier
settlements and a particular
need for affordable housing in rochford
yes there is definitely a need
as you say
an acute need
um and um
in
2.39 we start to see how that
works its way through
the core strategy
which is
as well as directing housing growth to
areas of need and demand and away from
unsustainable locations subject to
constraints the council must consider
the relationship of housing growth to
areas of employment
and then we see this at 2.42
the construction of additional housing
will have the potential to deliver
affordable housing to meet the current
shortfall
in order to supply housing for local
community need
this will only happen however if
planning policies are in place to ensure
a proportion of the housing developed is
affordable so the point that's been
raised in 2.42
is that the way that the plan
anticipates that affordable housing is
going to come forward to meet those
acute housing needs is through the
delivery of market schemes with a
proportion of them required to be
affordable housing
as i said earlier it's the definition of
affordable
right well price range we're looking at
okay but the way that we'll yeah i
understand that yeah thank you
um
and then at 2.40 we see a recognition
having regards the constraints that
we've just
looked at that the development of
additional housing will impact on forms
of physical and social infrastructure
this impact will require contributions
to be made by developers by way of
planning obligations yep you see that
what sorry what number were we looking
at i'm so sorry it's
four
2.40
forty sorry at the top of the page yeah
okay
[Applause]
good um and um
then
[Applause]
if we turn up page forty five please
[Applause]
um
um
if we if we turn up page 45 please um
we see
at page 45 there is a heading extensions
to residential envelopes and phasing you
see that
and we see
in order to fulfill the requirements of
what was then the east of england plan
which was setting at that point the
housing requirements
and meet the housing needs of the
district the council is required to
allocate additional land for residential
development including land which is
currently allocated as greenbelt due to
the limited supply of alternative land
and that's the point that i was raising
a moment ago in respect of constraints
but what 4.17 tells us
is that in order to meet the housing
needs of the district the council would
allocate additional land for residential
development
yes it doesn't mention brownfield sites
does it
in this
right well it no but
if you just focus on if we may that
paragraph please the council's plan is
telling us
that
in order to meet the housing needs of
the district the council will need to
allocate additional land for residential
development it does indeed here yeah and
then if we look at um 4.18
whilst the council acknowledged the
housing requirements stipulated in the
east of england plan is a minimum we
know it's gone up now but at this point
it's talking about those figures
it must also be mindful of the need to
maintain greenbelt as far as possible
and then we see at 4.19 the locations
and quantums for housing development set
out in policy h2
are such that on a settlement by
settlement basis when combined with
development proposed through h1
which is um
points about efficient use of land uh
for housing and and sites that have been
identified through through that process
so the location's back to 4.19 the
locations and quantums for housing
development as set out in h2 are such
that on a settlement by settlement basis
when combined with development through
h1 a balanced strategy for housing
provision is delivered so that's saying
again the council's looked at its needs
it's considered its constraints that
we've discussed it's that fair and equal
distribution to meet housing needs is
delivered essentially through policy the
allocations within policy h1 and h2 you
see that i can see that i don't
necessarily agree with it but i can see
it okay
so that's what the council's plan says
and then we have 4.20
in addition in addition to identifying
settlements where housing development
will be directed to so that's your
tiered approach we've discussed
the core strategy also sets out areas
around such settlements where an
extension to the residential envelope is
appropriate
the council will direct development to
the most sustainable locations on the
edge of settlements
having regard to a number of factors
including the proximity and relationship
of existing centres facilities and
services
the availability of infrastructure
and or potential for additional
infrastructure to be provided for
development in such areas so that's been
expressly considered we can see there is
a bullet point yeah
the potential to reduce private car
dependency so that's also been expressly
considered there as a bullet point
hasn't it
and
the impact on the highway network
including availability and impact on
existing network as well as the
potential for improvements to be
delivered so that's been expressly
considered there as well hasn't it
yes it has nothing it's also been
covered by council larry's statements
yesterday right
and so um having looked at all of those
factors those bullet points and
considered them what we can see in 4.20
is that having identified the top tier
settlements there's also an
identification of the areas around such
settlement
settlements which are the most
sustainable locations to accommodate
growth that's what we see in 4.20 as i
just said it does say that but
counsellory has pointed out um various
points that it will
it's we consider it will not work right
well again for purpose i've done my
cross-examination of counselor eve i'm
doing the planning bit with you and
looking at the plan so this is what your
the council's plan says
so that's what can i just interrupt you
yes sorry um when you say that you've
done with councillors if i don't
actually agree with some of this on the
infrastructure can i actually point that
out because can i just point out that
counselors has made those points or
should i not i would like to take advice
on that
you answer your questions okay as you
wish to answer that all right and i'm
happy i'm happy for you to do that okay
given his evidence but if there's
something you wish to say in answer to
one of my questions i'm more than happy
for you to do that thank you for the
clarification um right then so having
having identified
the most sustainable locations on the
edge of settlements having regard to all
of those factors we can see where those
are in policy h2 and that's the green
box in policy h2
and this is um
just bear with me a second
and policy h3
and so what we see
in terms of policy h3 at 4.26
in considering general development
locations for post-2021
uh development so that's the period
we're in now isn't it councillor
the same issues as for policy h2 above
has have been considered so just pausing
there those bullet points we've just
looked at have been considered we're
told
yeah yes
battery is identified uh for post 2021
development may not be immediate
delivery deliverable or the situation
with infrastructure is such that deliver
earlier would not be appropriate so it's
essentially saying that that some sites
are earmarked in the same way for
development post 2021 isn't it yes
taking into account those considerations
and we're now post 2021
and then at paragraph 4.28
sorry not 4.28 policy four point
policy or paragraph sorry just bear with
me a second so let me just check the
reference
i'm sorry i've dealt with that point
already sorry then if we go to the
policy itself which is policy h3 in the
green box
we see this
so post 2021 so that's now
the residential envelope of existing
settlements will be extended in the
following areas as indicated on the key
diagram to deliver the following
approximate number of units post-2021
prior to that time
greenbelt land will be safeguarded so
the the temporal restriction of 2021 we
now pass that and you have no objection
to this scheme clearly on the basis
that it's coming forward at the wrong
time in terms of the plan it's a post
2021 position we're now in isn't it i've
no
problem with it coming forward just we
as a community we didn't actually agree
with it yeah that's a separate point in
terms of impact
yeah so no problem in terms of time
and then we have this
the detailed location and quantum of
development will be articulated within
the allocations development plan
document
so i'll turn to the allocations plan
document in a moment
but what we can see from the table
is that in the course strategy it's
saying approximate number of units for
south east ashington
500
yeah
and then it's saying deta it will look
to
precisely where that will be provided
for and the quantum so the number of
units in the allocations plan which came
afterwards yes
and then we see this
then we see this
um
just bear with me a sack yeah
so then we see this um development
within the above areas will be required
to be comprehensively planned
a range of other uses and infrastructure
including off-site infrastructure
having regards the requirements of the
core strategy
will be required to be developed and
implemented in a timely manner alongside
housing so it's talking about the
delivery of infrastructure to accompany
the development proposed there
and then it says appendix h1 outlines
the infrastructure that will be required
for each residential area and should be
read in conjunction
in conjunction with policy clt1
yeah you see that now we know from the
statements of common ground and we can
turn it up again if you
if you wish
but we know
that in the statements of common ground
on behalf of the council
and if you turn up
paragraph
4.2.2 please
and in paragraph 4.2.2 we can see the
lists of the list of policies that are
relevant yeah and one of those it's just
over the page second page is cl2
sorry clt it's a bit of a mouthful clt1
which is planning obligations and
standard charges that's recognized as
being a relevant policy in that list you
see that
and then um on to the next page and it's
it's paragraph
4.4.1 but it's right at the
bottom of that paragraph above 4.5
material considerations
and the sentence i'm taking you to
starts with following the case
management conference
yeah
says following the case management
conference in respect to the appeal the
local planning authority has confirmed
the only policies considered relevant to
the reason for refusal are scr 8 t1 and
dm 31 as listed above no breach of any
other policy is alleged so that's
effectively confirming that there is
compliance with policy clt-1
yes yes um and if we look at policy clt1
policy clt1
give me a page i will do sir sorry my
tab's falling out so just put him
92 thank you
on the course strategy it is yes
[Applause]
so this is just a point of clarification
in terms of what that policy actually
says to remind ourselves because we know
there's compliance with it there's no
dispute between us um it says the
council will require developers to enter
into legal agreements in order to secure
planning obligations to address specific
issues relating to development
including requisite on-site
infrastructure and the provision of
on-site affordable housing
so we know there's compliance with that
and if you just now
go back to page 48.
what that is telling us
is that the infrastructure that is
required for each residential area
is provided through the development
because it says should be read in
conjunction with clt1 we know there's no
conflict with that but also
if you look at the list of relevant
policies
with which there is no allegation of
conflict
we can see that that the council agrees
that there is compliance with policy h3
extensions to residential envelopes post
2021 do you see that in the statements
of common ground yes i do so what that
means is that that requirement because
the statement of common ground is
confirming that there is compliance with
policy h3
what that means
is that
in terms of this policy of the core
strategy
it is accepted
it is accepted
that the range of other uses and
infrastructure including off-site
infrastructure having regards the
requirements of the core strategy
are coming forward through the
development in accordance with that
policy
it's
i can read it
and i agree that what it says
but
on paper it looks very good but in
practical terms
i can't see how they can improve
off seo eight site the infrastructure
going on to washington road
well again that's the point about the
impacts of the development and we'll
come on to that but my point at the
moment is in terms of what the plan is
requiring in policy h3 specifically
there's no allegation of conflict with
policy h3
there's agreement that there's
compliance with policy h3 and clt1
so in terms of the wording of the policy
the range of other uses and
infrastructure
having regard to the requirements of the
core strategy
are going to be developed and
implemented
in a timely manner alongside affordable
housing
in accordance with that policy because
there's no conflict with it if you
didn't think that that was the case
having looking at the terms of the
policy you'd be alleging a conflict with
it so can we agree compliance with the
policy on that
thank you right
good so compliance with h3
so compliance with h3 if we want a bit
more detail about what that means we can
see that h1 appendix h1
so that's an appendix to this policy
outlines the infrastructure that will be
required for each residential area
and that
appendix
is at
page 54.
and our site is at
page 56 so this is the location for
growth identified in the core strategy
and so if we're looking at what
we have just agreed
provided in accordance with policy h3
it includes
local highway capacity and
infrastructure improvements including
contribution to traffic management of
ashington road public transport
infrastructure improvements and service
enhancements
link enhancements to local pedestrian
cycling and bridal way network
sustainable drainage systems public open
space place-based use youth facilities
and community facilities so we're in
agreement that those are provided in
accordance with policy h3
your point i think counsellors to be
fair to you is you're just not convinced
that's enough and it's going to work
exactly yeah okay
so provided in accordance with h3
not convinced will work
okay thank you
good
so
we then
just check how i'm doing on time
um
said you want me to carry on well i was
i was thinking we started at nine um
you've told me you've got three to three
and a half hours so i thought we'd try
and get through at least an hour and a
half before looking for a break so
around about half past 10 quarter to 11
um
because obviously i don't ideally want
to take two breaks in the morning uh
well if we if we need to but so if if
you carry on council sure you still okay
carry on could we stop at half past ten
please okay if that's okay that's
absolutely fine yeah we'll we'll find a
convenient point roundabout and just
just on the basis i mean councillor
shaw's we've had a discussion outside of
the inquiry about specific requirements
if counselor shaw needs an earlier break
i've asked her just to let us know if
that's the case of course i mean and if
we need a second break in the morning
then i'm quite happy with that it's just
so much obviously we've got things to
get through so i'm just trying to press
on as best we can but yeah okay
um okay so that takes us so we've got
compliance with policy h3 we've got
provision of the
infrastructure
requirements set out within that policy
and then we know because we've just
looked at it
that
what policy h3 said
was that the location and quantum
precise quantum of development was going
to be looked at through the allocations
plan
so
we'll turn to the allocations plan
oh sorry just just before i get to that
point there is another point actually
i'm sorry which i forgot about
um
so um
yes in terms of in terms of um what was
considered um at that point in time and
and the core strategy in the
infrastructure and so on that was was
being looked at and the locations for
development
the
the rule
yeah the rule six party and also um the
mp
have made reference in their
representations
to um a decision
if you just turn up the rule six parties
uh
six parties evidence
um have made reference to an appeal
decision it's the cogent land appeal
appeal decision sorry
case high court case don't worry i'm not
cross-examining you about law
good
um
so it's
yeah so it's the cogent it's the cajun
land uh
decision
is this one of these specific
um attachments it is it's attachment 12
sir yep i've got it yeah thank you
so it's a it's a high court
decision in front of
his honorable
uh mr justice singh
and let's say don't worry i'm not
cross-examining you about the law i'm
interested about
some of that that wouldn't be proper for
me to do that anyway but i'm i'm not
going to um you'll be pleased to know um
but this this was a challenge this was a
challenge to the adoption of the
council's core strategy
and um we can see and just it's just by
way of background
that um at paragraph five
and it's just by way of background in
terms of what all of this was about
that that the claimant in that case made
numerous criticisms
as to the production of the rcs that's
rochefort core strategy yeah
and um and then it sets out what its
grounds were but essentially
um one of the issues was the approach
that the
um
just trying to to sort of simplify this
the approach that had been taken to the
consideration of the council of
reasonable alternatives through its plan
process prior to adoption okay
and
the bit that i'm interested in looking
at with you is is if we look over the
page please
at paragraph
27
um
we sorry 26 and 27 we can see that the
court is looking there at the background
to the core strategy in respect of the
draft core strategy preferred options
paper that predated the core strategy
and we can see at paragraph 27
that the preferred options for general
development locations that were
consulted on through that are set out
and then
at 28 the alternative options for
general development locations the reason
i'm skipping over those is of course
because
we then went through to the core
strategy that was adopted and that's the
adopted development plan but i'm just
setting the scene in terms of what this
was looking at
and
um
in terms of the uh it's it's paragraph
31
so this is an extract from the preferred
options document that fed into and
informed the core strategy
we see this
rochford ashing and this is a point
that's been raised in the rule six
passes in the mps
statements but we see this
rochford ashington has in theory
reasonable reasonably good transport
links to south end in the a127
but in practice the area is heavily
congested with congestion on ashingdon
road being amongst the worst in the
district to the west hall road links
directly to cherry orchard way link road
but the railway bridge at the eastern
end of hall road is a severe constraint
on traffic movements
now
those reflect some of the concerns that
have been
considered through this inquiry but my
point is those were concerns that were
set out in the preferred options
document that informed the core strategy
and nevertheless in the core strategy
the council's decision
the council's decision
was that approximately 500 units should
nevertheless come forward in that
location
councillor wasn't it yes that's what he
said but it does when was this uh
judgment made
well the judgment yes what judgment was
made in answer to your question if you
look on the it was 2012
okay but my my point isn't really about
my point here
is about what informed the course
strategy
which is the council's adopted plan
and my point is that those issues that
have been raised here in terms of
congestion
and the railway bridge being a
constraint on traffic movement they were
known
when the council adopted its core
strategy because they've been set out
and considered in the preferred options
document
yes that's true thank you
good um right you can pop that one away
don't need this anymore at all
i told you i wasn't cross examining the
difference i can actually um clear my
desk a bit thank you
and just to be clear as as the rule six
parties and the mp has correctly noted
the
claimant's claim against the court
strategy was dismissed which is why we
now have the adopted document in front
of us um
good okay so those constraints were
known when that was adopted we've got
compliance with policy h3
and then
we have then
we then turn to the allocations
plan so this is poor document
6.2 please
[Music]
and again this is part of the council's
adopted development plan isn't it yes
councils not the appellants
and
and just as it was the case with the
core strategy um you do not advance the
case in your proof of evidence
examination in chief
to the effect that um reduced weight
should be given to the any of the
policies in this document now
okay
and um
if we just look at the um
first firstly paragraph 1.8 of the core
strategy
sorry allocations yeah okay sorry sir
um
on page seven
um we can we can see this the core
strategy
i was reading it before i was saying the
core strategy is the overarching
planning policy document of the local
development framework ldf which sets out
our main issues for the future and the
policies which will shape the future
development of the district the
allocations document will sit below the
core strategy in the ldf and must
conform to the approach set out in it in
order to be sound through independent
examination to deliver our vision
the allocations document must not repeat
the policies in the core strategy and
should be read in conjunction with them
therefore both these documents will be
used in the determination of planning
applications for the development and use
of land and buildings in the district so
that's just explaining there isn't it
the relationship between the core
strategy which sets out
strategic priorities the spatial um
objectives and and policies and the
allocations plan which effectively sits
underneath it
yes good
and um
just in terms of the
um just in terms of the um inspectors
decision that you were taken to
yesterday
by mr parkinson
which is a core
document uh
6.14.
bear with me a moment
okay
i think it's still open so
oh
um and the paragraphs you were taken to
you by mr parkinson are at page six
and um
obviously the inspector can
just not going to read every paragraph
out now but just invite the inspector as
part of his potential bedtime reading to
read paragraphs 22 through to 29 there
so that he gets the full context of the
those paragraphs
um but what what we can see in paragraph
22
is there is a reflection there of a
criticism that was made presumably by
objectors to the council's plan
that the overall impact on highway
capacity had not been addressed you see
that yes and then the points mr
parkinson took q2 or effectively the
inspector looks at that
and records
records the fact that there's stress on
the network at 24 and residents are
sensitive to congestion so these are
points that have also been raised here
that we've heard
um and um then we see at 25 and it's
just this paragraph i want to focus on
cause this is what the allocations in
spectrum just bearing in mind the role
of the allocations plan sitting below
the core strategy
says this
that said notwithstanding the general
misgivings there's no technical
information about the impact of
additional traffic so what he's saying
there effectively is that not finding
that those concerns have been
substantiated on the base of the
evidence before him
furthermore there is no other assessment
to contradict the highways authority's
position that the network as a whole
should be able to cope so
reflection there that the highways
authority position is that the network
as a whole should be able to cope and
just pausing we know that the highway
authority has no objection to this
specific scheme no you disagree with
that but that's the position they still
hold but then this and it's this
paragraph that i really want to focus on
with you
not paragraph sorry sentence it's coming
up to half past 10.
we see this
most significantly most significantly
the scale and location of development
has already been assessed and determined
through the core strategy
because of all this the allocations plan
is sound in this respect so the most
significant factor that the inspector
has identified in looking at those
issues is that those issues
have already been assessed and
determined through the core strategy you
see that
thank you
um
because you understand that the
allocations plan has to be in general
conformity with the core strategy
sitting underneath it yeah okay
good
we're very close to half past probably
just a good point to pause then sir i
think
yeah okay
let's take the
um mid-morning break then let's take 20
minutes because there's a fair number of
people i don't want to be longer than
that but let's let's try and see if we
can do it within 20 minutes so i'll
adjourn now if we can
resume at 10 50
um council sure as before you you'll
have to stay in communicado from your
colleagues but okay
so adjourn now and resume at 10 50.
thank you
okay
oh
the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen
uh miss reed just before i ask you to
continue at the start of the adjournment
ms wright indicated to me that she
wanted to ask a question said ms wright
before the end what what i indicated
when i opened is that i'll give the
opportunity for
interested persons who've already spoken
to put questions to relevant
appellants witnesses so that's the
what you'll be allowed to do you've
you've made your statement
i've got your
written representations so that's the
the sum total as it were of evidence to
come forward from yourself
in terms of any other participation in
the inquiry yes if you've got relevant
questions to put to appellants witnesses
that haven't been asked by
mr parkerson or or someone else
then yes you can put that but that's the
that's the
sum total as it were of your future
involvement having said that sorry you
will be able to summarize your case as i
said if you so wish
at the end of the day but it can't
introduce matters that you haven't
already raised
when you made your statement so they say
it's simply a summary of of the case of
the information you've already put
forward hopefully that's all clear
yeah okay thank you
mry
thank you very much start again we're
dealing with the allocations plan
and
you deal with this at paragraph 4.6 of
your proof of evidence where you say
um having looked at the core strategy an
h3 of the core strategy oh sorry i'll
just wait for you to get that's right
sorry i can stretch
okay thank you yeah you're dealing with
the development plan
and um at 4.5 you deal with the core
strategy and we've looked at that
already and then 4.6
um
sorry 4.5 the core strategy talk about
the extension of the
uh residential envelope and existing
settlement to provide land to deliver
housing to contribute towards meeting
the local authority's five-year housing
land supply
and then you go on to deal with the
allocation
plan
at 4.6
and you say accordingly the appeals site
is allocated for residential development
in the council's adopted allocations
plan
and the principle of the proposed
residential development
is therefore accepted
and then you say that is not to say any
form
or residential development without
within the allocation would be
acceptable
it's simply the principle of the
residential development
that is accepted now i just want to be
clear
in respect of what's meant
by those points in that paragraph so
just want to pick up a couple of
points of clarification with you
um the statements of common ground
confirms that there's no allegation that
the form of residential development in
terms of design density or layout or
those considerations is objectionable to
the council
that's what it says yeah so the form of
residential development is acceptable
in this case the form of it yeah yes
yeah okay good and in terms of policy
ser eight which is the allocation policy
if we just turn that one up
um
and give me a page reference yeah i can
say sorry just bear with me a sack um
it's page 71 oh watch oh sorry the
allocations plan
which is called document 6.2
also
what number sorry
what what page number sorry it's page 71
71 thank you sorry yeah
on page 72 and page 73 and it just goes
the
because it goes right through to page
70
6.
you want me to read all that now padding
are you gonna i'm not reading all of
them no i'm just i'm just locating the
relevant page references to the
inspector
okay so um just a couple of points in
respect to it i just want to look at
numbers first of all so if you look at
72 please
um
and
we can see
actually sorry 72 and 71 start at 71 i'm
so sorry paragraph 3.2
sorry 3.224
um
and
we can see that there's a recognition
that the site through the core strategy
the site in this general location should
have the capacity to accommodate a
minimum of 500 dwellings
during the planned period yep you see
that and the
um
and the end of the plan period is 2025
isn't it yes but that's not the
application we had in front of us the
application we had in front of us was
for six hundred and sixty i know not
five hundred i know i i do appreciate
that don't we just taking it in baby
steps all right okay so first point at
three point two two four is that the
site in this general location should
have the capacity to accommodate a
minimum a minimum
of 500 dwellings during the plan period
first point end of the plan period
is 20
25
yeah
yes yes okay so it's anticipating then
that a minimum of 500 dwellings
should come forward
before the end of 2025
during the planned period
i thought it would have been extended to
2029
that's what was discussed yesterday
no no no have i misheard what you said
sorry so the
2029 the 2029 date is the date that the
traffic
impacts were being assessed in respect
of the end of the plan period
is 2025. so if it goes ahead they're
going to do 500 units or minimum of 500
units by 2025. well your net burning no
the capacity to accommodate so it's
talking about the fact that the site is
should come forward so planning
permission it's anticipating should be
granted by
2025 to deliver a minimum of 500 units
okay
good
um so the words mint so that's that's
the plan period and when it's
anticipated that those dwellings will
come forward
and second point is that the word
minimum is used there so 500 is the
minimum number yes
it's not expressed as a maximum it's
expressed as a major understanding
minimum means good
and um if we turn
over
the page
we can see the circumstances that are
set out within the policy
in respect of when the numbers can be
uplifted
to more than 500 dwellings
and there are two bullet points
and they are as follows
firstly the additional number of
dwellings are required to maintain a
five-year land supply
now just pausing there it's a matter of
agreement it's a matter of agreement
between the parties that there's no
five-year housing land supply as i
understand it so there's a tick against
that first point isn't that
yeah
and the second one
is that
the additional number of dwellings to be
provided on the site is required to
compensate for a shortfall that has been
projected to be delivered within the
location
identified
in the core
strategy and
um
mr pycroft has indicated
that there has been a shortfall in the
units projected for
this
tier one settlement rockford ashington
by 2021
and you haven't produced any evidence to
dispute that have you no i haven't
so what we can see is then that those
two bullet points in 3.227
which allow
more than 500 units to come forward on
the appeal site
those have been met
here
yeah thank you so much conditions
and so when you are saying if we just
turn back your proof of evidence
[Applause]
when you are saying
at 4.6 of your proof
you say the appeal size allocated
residential development in the
allocations plan then you say this the
principle of the proposed residential
development so that's the 662
is therefore accepted
what you're saying is that
the 662
is in accordance
with that
allocation
that number of units is important i do
actually say that it's not to say that
any form of res or residential
development within the allocation would
be acceptable
i know you do and we've just looked at
the fact that you've agreed with me
i take it i understand you've got these
highways points against the scheme i'm
just looking at the numbers now and what
you mean by the principle of residential
development and so in terms of the
numbers
because those two conditions in the
policy are met
the principle of the proposed
residential development ie 662 units
as i understand it is accepted to be in
accordance
with the allocation policy committee
didn't reject um
this application on the number of houses
right
right so is that okay that's that's very
helpful so
what that means is
that the planning authority except
that 662 units
are
in accordance
with the allocation in principle your
point is but there's also traffic
considerations we need to take into
account yes that's definitely correct
okay that's that's helpful and that
helps me
just cut through things a little bit
because i understand
where we are in terms of that point
um
okay and just as a point in terms of the
conditions that are set out in paragraph
3.227
in terms of uplifting the number from
500
they did not con in terms of the policy
of the plan and again counselor i
understand that you have a different
view in respect of it in terms of the
policy of the plan
they did not have the policy of the plan
did not have a cap
introduced
or a requirement imposed
in respect to the number of units that
might come forward having regard to
traffic or highways consideration we
don't see that as a bullet point do we
we don't it's just as you say it's a
minimum of 500. yeah
okay
[Applause]
okay and then if we um
look at the
parts of the allocation
parts of the allocation
uh policy
and its requirements that are dealing
with highways matters
and they start at page 74.
and um
so hopefully again this is just points
of clarification i'm just ticking them
off to just check
if and where we disagree
um
at 3.243
on page 74
um we can see that there's a point there
um about vehicular accessors
and
just to be clear the local planning
authority hasn't taken any issue
in terms of the location or suitability
of the vehicular access
there was
it was
um discussed and debated at the
committee
okay but there's no reason for refusal
on that basis but it was
um that was one of the
reasons it was refused because of the
severity of the congestion on national
road we thought it would impact more on
the ashton road okay let's just split it
down and split it more split it down
into smaller points sorry probably it's
probably the way that i'm putting the
question in terms of that i i understand
that you've got a point in respect to
congestion
we know um but
um in terms of the site access and the
location of the site access and in
particular now those highway safety
concerns that we discussed are no longer
being pursued as reasons for refusal
which we discussed at the beginning
the council does not object
to this scheme on the basis of the
location of the site tax the actual
location they don't um disagree right
thank you so no conflict no material
conflict alleged with that particular
i'm just taking it into that particular
part 3.243 okay
so the reason i'm looking at all of them
is because they're all dealing with
highways points this is where we're
dealing with them and then at 3.244
um it's talking about the potential to
also have an access to the drive purity
or
percycottis road yeah and it's looking
at what needs to be considered in that
respect and again it's hopefully it's
the point of agreement because it's not
been a point raised by the local
planning authority no issue has been
raised in respect of the access on
percycottis road by the local planning
authority and its objection to the
scheme has it
no but can i clarify that again in the
committee
it was discussed how narrow that road is
and when there's no off street parking
for residents
and you wouldn't at times wouldn't even
get a bicycle
down the middle of that road let alone a
flow of traffic further traffic
okay so council understand your concerns
and i know residents have got concerns
and we'll have a think about those later
but in terms of the local planning
authority's decision and its reason for
refusal which we discussed at the
beginning in their terms those points a
to f
it's not a reason for refusal is it by
the planning authority we would not be
on congestion congestion on
uh the sites both sites from uh percy
cossey road percy cottie's road and the
ashland road that's what the congestion
and severity was but it's councillor
eves that's given the evidence
so okay so so in terms of um
yeah in terms of the position and
principle of that access and its safety
and suitability
no issue taken with that your one
relates to the congestion points
councilor eves has made yes okay no
issue safety and suitability
um
okay so in terms of
3.244 which is really dealing with
safety and suitability and again i'm
just trying to understand where there
might be a difference between us safety
and suitability so in terms of 3.244
no allegation in your proof of evidence
or examination in chief or what you've
just said to me that there's conflict
with that particular paragraph there no
because counsellories covered it well no
councillor eve doesn't allege conflict
with that particular paragraph what he
said to us is that there are these
congestion issues that need to be taken
into account so
no no
point has been taken anywhere in the
council's proofs of evidence or
examination in chief
in respect of the point raised in 3.244
so no evidence produced in terms of
conflict with that specific paragraph
council no that'll be my personal
opinion then okay right so no conflict
from the lpa
it's my personal opinion okay thank you
and that of my residence okay well i'll
i'll pick that up either with residents
or with mr blair given that you're here
we're discussing the view of the local
planning authority
okay
so local planning authority no conflict
with either of those two parts
and then
3.245 is relating to public transport
infrastructure improvements and service
enhancements now in respect of those
points there's no we've looked at policy
ccl t1 already there's compliance with
it
so i know your point is well
i'm not convinced all of that's going to
work in the end which is a separate
point because what 3.245
is saying
is that there will be
public sorry that it says public
transport infrastructure improvements
and service enhancements will be
required the potential for the existing
bus route along ashington road to be
diverted onto the site will be
considered
so not a requirement but to consider it
but in terms of clt1 and the obligations
in respect of public transport provision
it's not a reason for refusal on behalf
of the authority that those
contributions don't go far enough or
that there would be conflict with policy
clt-1 is it i just say it says the
potential for the existing bus route
along national road to be diverted it
doesn't actually say considered so it
says explored yeah he speaks sorry
explored that doesn't mean that it'll
definitely happen will it um
sorry
let's let's just again it's probably the
my questions are a little bit long let
me just try and focus it
the local authority hasn't refused this
application
on the basis of inadequate contributions
toward public towards public transport
sport infrastructure service
enhancements
or anything to do with public transport
has it no
okay has the local bus services been
actually consulted on this to say that
they would consider going on to the site
well that's something perhaps you could
ask mr parkinson to ask my witnesses
okay thank you well that's just a point
i'd like to make well that
sorry that's something you can ask your
advocate to ask my because i'm not
allowed to answer questions
i understand that but whoever's
listening perhaps they could actually
make a note of that and answer that for
me if mr parkinson asks them i'm sure
they'd be delighted too but if we could
just return to the
just return to the text here at 3.245
and it's just
all i'm trying to i understand what your
case is but what i'm trying to do is
just understand which parts of this
policy
we're elect the council is alleging
conflict with and there hasn't been an
allegation of conflict
with this part of the policy
and actually you've accepted compliance
with clt1 in terms of the contributions
that have been provided
so we can we we understand therefore
that there is
no conflict alleged with that
this particular thing thank you right
thank you
and then
3.246 is dealing with pedestrian cycle
routes should be provided throughout the
site
so
and also to the south of the site should
be provided etc
and again no conflict with this part of
the policy is alleged because um
pedestrian and cycle routes are being
provided
as the applicant's plans show yes yeah
so so no conflict with this part of the
policy
and i say i'm only dealing with these
because these are all the highways ones
so i just want to understand so no
conflict with this part of the policy
okay
and then we have this
um links and enhancements to local
pedestrian cycling and bridal way
network should be provided
and a recognition that a modal shift to
reduce use of private vehicles encourage
walking and cycling
is particularly important in this
location
contributions towards the development of
the proposed sustron cycle route may
also be required and we know that the
planning obligation is providing cycle
infrastructure
contributions and again there's no
conflict with this part of the policy
alleged is there
no but the bridal ways won't be going
down ashland road will they okay but
that's that's immaterial
i'm asking about the policy
so no conflict with this part of the
policy good
and then we have this 3.248
a transport assessment
a transport assessment
including an assessment of air quality
must accompany any planning application
to develop the site now before i move on
statements that appreciate residents
have got concerns but the statement of
common ground confirms doesn't it that
the local planning authority is not
taking an objection in respect of air
quality that's correct because we
haven't got any monitors up on the
ashland road
no objection air quality
and then so
i'll go back and now talk about the
other bits of the policy so transport
assessment must accompany any planning
application to develop the site this
must examine the additional transport
impacts that the site will generate
just pause
i will move on to the next bit but we do
have a transport assessment don't we
that has examined
the additional transport impacts that
the site will generate yeah yep
so that part of the policy there's a
tick against it i'll come on to the next
part of it again it might be but i don't
as you know they are aware i don't agree
with it that's fine yeah and then we see
this
actions and i think this is probably
where we just need to pause for a moment
actions to address impacts identified
through the transport assessment must
accompany the development of the site
or be provided prior to the commencement
of development so the policy is
requiring actions to address impacts
identified through the ta to be provided
and if we turn back
to 3.224
which is on page 71.
i saw i was reading about wildlife
we can see there
um
that having set out the minimum of 500
point which we've dealt with already the
overall site here is 23.5 hectares
to take account of site constraints and
accommodate the following infrastructure
service and facilities and it lists the
infrastructure that's going to be
expected to be provided
yeah you see that yes i do and so that's
linking back to 3.248 isn't it in terms
of the
actions that to address impacts that
need to be provided
yeah
and these these ones here this list
this list of infrastructure
provision that needs to be provided in
accordance with 3.224 and 3.248
are the same ones that we looked at in
terms of policy
h3 in the core strategy yes
and so they are the ones which we've
already agreed will come forward as part
of
the scheme yeah yes it is indeed and so
i appreciate your point as well none of
that's good enough get that but
that means that there is compliance with
the terms of policy three point two two
four and three point two four eight
doesn't it yeah
definitely if yes it is but if the
impact is severe it's not compliant is
it well no that's a separate point isn't
it because that's something that comes
from the mppf as a material
consideration so what i'm doing is that
section 386 test which you look at the
development plan first and then you look
at other material considerations i'm not
ignoring what you're saying i'm just
trying to understand where it comes into
the battle i appreciate that thank you
so what we can um
what we can agree then
having regard to all of that because
those are i think
all of the highways points that are
raised within the four corners of the
policy
is that taking those into account there
is compliance with policy ser eight your
point is there are other material
considerations to weigh against that is
that there is yeah i know that's it but
there is so there is compliance with
scra your point relates to material
considerations
good excuse the compliance ser eight
thank you
and then if we then think about how that
feeds into the other policies in the
development plan and again i understand
your point in terms of material
considerations
so policy t1 please next which is in the
core strategy
at paragraph 107
just being found
move on there you go
now
um
what you'll understand counselor because
you're the chair of the planning
committee
is you'll understand that when we look
at the policies of the development plan
and whether or not the pla the proposal
is in accordance with the plan we have
to look at the policies as a whole don't
we
so the test in section 386 is whether
the plan is in compliance with the
development plan as a whole yes
and so when we are looking at policies
in the development plan
one reads them naturally or one should
read them in a way that they are in so
far as possible in regards to their play
meaning consistent with each other yes
yeah also yes sir yeah so you don't want
to adopt
an interpretation of them which is
effectively you've got policies pulling
in different ways
because it will create because it would
create an internal inconsistency within
the plan yeah
so you agree with with that as a general
proposition yeah okay good very
generally yeah of course of course
um and um if we look at um page one zero
seven
and this is where we see policies t1 and
t2
and policy t1
um says this
so firstly
development will be required to be
located and designed in such a way as to
reduce reliance on the private car now
just pausing there we spent a lot of
time this morning going through the core
strategy
and that reflects doesn't it that
sentence this point about directing
growth to the top-tier settlements
essentially yeah
so because the development is in the
top-tier settlement
there's compliance with that part of the
policy yeah
and also
because
so that's the located point and because
it's providing obligations in accordance
with policy clt-1
which are going to provide obligations
towards public transport cycle
infrastructure and so on those are
measures i know you think they don't go
far enough that's a separate point again
but those are measures that are designed
to encourage
the use of modes other than the private
car so bus cycling etc excuse me i'll
just clarify that i don't say the money
wouldn't go far enough i just don't
think the proposals are workable
along
from the roots that the access will be
coming out okay it's not a case of
i'm disputing the money yeah it is i
don't i
the committee and i didn't think
that
it was sustainable what they were
proposing yeah so so your point again is
one about congestion and you don't think
it's going to resolve the issue
essentially in that okay and for public
transport and for cycle routes because
you can't put a safe cycle route on um
you might be able to do it on the estate
which would be good that you could go to
cair's including sorry king edmonds
um that would be a pro appropriate but
there's not enough room if you even if
you reduce the pavements
um
so if we've got suvs two suvs you will
not be able to get a cycle route through
there and if any big wagons come up from
the baltic wolf they actually
come over the white line so it isn't
safe for a cyclist and we've got these
new rules that are coming out
from on the highways that we've got to
give priority to pedestrians
and it's coming out this week
uh so um that's my concern is
it as we've said before it's very good
on paper and it does look very good
but
is it practical yeah got got your
qualification in terms of practical
issues and i'm not i'm going to look at
those okay but i'm again at the moment
i'm just looking at the policies because
i'm just trying to split it down into
parts to understand where we agree and
disagree
so those points in terms of
the pavement and so we clarified at the
beginning they're not reasons for
refusal but there's something you think
should be waivers in the planning
balance in the overall consideration of
the matter
i'm looking at policy t1
and councillor eves agreed with me and i
assume you do too just to cut in terms
of that first sentence given its tier
one location and given that there will
be obligations which comply with policy
ccl t1 as we've discussed there's
compliance with that first part there
developments will be required to be
located and designed in such a way as to
reduce reliance on the private car
so compliance with that i'll go with
what was closed
good right
then
this next part
so
we have
however
some impacts some impact on the highway
network is inevitable
and the council will work with
developers and the highways authority to
ensure that appropriate improvements
are carried out the council will seek
developer contributions where necessary
okay
now that's that's the bit i just want to
have a think about with you
now we know because it's what
appropriate improvements means
essentially
now we know because we've looked at it
that we have allocations policies here
so policy h3 and scr8 read together
and you have agreed with me that
the proposals are in compliance with
those policies
and they set out a number of measures
that the development will be expected to
bring forward in respect of
contributions and improvements okay
so
if one is
reading the plan
as a whole which we must do
where policy t1 is talking about
appropriate improvements
the policy requirement is effectively to
deliver
in terms of an allocation
to deliver the improvements that are
envisaged through the allocation yes
and if it does and it also delivers
against clt1 which is your policy about
obligations which it does
the proposal is in compliance with
policy t1 as well read in the context of
the plan as a whole writing the whole
context yes right so we can agree then
that the proposal is in accordance also
with policy t1 your point again relates
to material considerations yes
and then finally and i don't think we
need to spend much time on this because
i think it's the same point really but
policy dm one which is the third part of
your development plan it's the
development management plan
so again a page reference so sorry we're
in 60 we're getting to do page 81.
6.3 it says thank you sir patrick you
want
yeah i've got it thank you
no page 81. i'm waiting on sorry
i've got dm one on page 18.
yeah i'm 31.
um because and it's it's the same point
really but it's talking about major
developments including appropriate
traffic management measures etc and then
it goes on to talk about what those
might be
but again the word appropriate traffic
management measures within the meaning
of the plan is talking about those where
we're dealing with an allocated site
which we are here
those that are specified within the
policies that we've looked at already
and also the obligations in terms of
clt1
and so it's the same point as t1 really
i assume that reading the plan as a
whole
you accept compliance with that policy
your point is about material
consideration yes it is
okay so
what we have and again understand the
point about material considerations but
what we therefore have is we have a
proposal
that is in compliance with the
development plan
your point is that there are material
considerations that outweigh the
compliance with the development plan yes
thank you
as i've already outlined i think yeah no
i'm just yeah of course okay
that's very helpful so compliance with
the development plan but you say
material considerations outweigh okay
let me just check where i'm up to
because i've sort of gone off piste a
bit but i think i've covered a lot of
these points so just give me a second if
you would like sure
[Applause]
okay so um
yeah just just in terms
just bear with me a second of where
we're up to
uh
yeah okay i'm gonna deal with
with this point next i think um so um i
just want to have a think next in the
context of material considerations about
what the consequences might be in
respect of housing delivery if the
site's not brought forward for
development so that's the next topic
we're going to be dealing with
um and
can you please turn up the statement of
common ground on housing
[Applause]
[Applause]
you have that one counsellor or is it
just being found no i've got it here
you've got it sorry i just i wasn't i
wasn't sure just talk sorry i could just
see that i could just see somebody doing
some housekeeping under the table
right so consequences
consequences statements of common ground
on housing
um and so we've already um identified
that the delivery of a sufficient
quantum of housing is a key part
particularly affordable housing but
housing in general is a key priority for
the council and it has set out in its
development plan haven't we
and it's also as i'm sure you're aware a
key priority of national policy which
seeks to provide a significant boost to
the supply of housing yeah
and um statements of common ground on
housing supply and delivery again signed
by the council so you don't take any
issue with the points set out in here do
you as i understand it
if somebody's looking away and taking a
note we might miss the head shake so if
you're sorry okay thank you very much
now i'm just going to take you through
some of the technical points in here
because i just want to understand where
they take us and and if we look at page
five please
so
um page uh
sorry no page six
um
page six has got a table in it
and what that table is looking at
is it's looking at um
completions so the number of houses
completed
against the housing requirements of the
plan
which is 250 homes per annum
and it's looking at the years
when there's been an over over or under
provision against that 250 requirement
so for example
you can see
um in 2007 i'll just take one near the
top for example there were 169
completions
which was minus 81 which is the 250
minus the 169. you see councillor just
to talk through the way it's set out
yeah
so what this does is it sets out over
and under provision and then the last
column there is cumulative over and
under provision so
that column takes into account
everything that happened in the years
before
as against the council's housing target
you see yes yeah
and so what we can see at the end there
bottom right
is that two
to the period 2020 to 2021
there was a cumulative under provision
because it's a minus number
of
829 units against the plan requirement
you see that
yes
and so what that means
is that firstly the cap the council has
not or it has not been delivered as many
homes as firstly was anticipated as
being needed and secondly as required to
meet the plan requirements yes but these
aren't will not be for people on the
housing list this uh there's 829 homes
and whatever broad
i'm saying on the scr8
do 662 houses yep that will not
diminish our
people on the waiting list only by the
uh social housing is if people as we've
said earlier if people can afford the
affordable housing that's fine but we've
got
many people that are on low incomes
in this area that will never ever be
able to afford anything so we may be
have the numbers not actually made
what we should have but it doesn't
actually help our people
our residents on our waiting list it
will not diminish them
right can we just take it in
bite sizes yeah
okay so yes so just in bite sizes there
are two points in the statements of
common ground
one is dealing with housing need
generally so that's market housing
generally so not just affordable housing
but the number of homes that are
required across the district yeah the
second point is looking at affordable
housing specifically
now what i'm looking at at the moment
what i'm looking at at the moment is the
general point in terms of market housing
because your plan identifies that there
is a need to provide 250 homes generally
per year so that's market and affordable
combination
250 homes per year
and what i'm looking at at the moment is
how many homes have been delivered
against that requirement yes i'm going
to deal with affordable housing in a
moment don't worry but in terms of
in terms of housing generally there has
there have not been as many homes
delivered as have were anticipated
and there have not been as many homes
delivered as are required to meet your
plan requirement of 250 per annum have
that i quite agree with that with the
table
okay and the cumulative so the the
cumulative shortfall to 2020 to 2021 is
minus eight
to nine and then we see at paragraph 2.5
to meet the housing requirements set out
in the core strategy
1829 dwellings would need to be
delivered over the next four years so
when it says the next four years it
means the first of april 2021 to the
31st of march 2025 and that's reflecting
the monitoring periods that's just
focusing is 2.5 yep however the
council's housing trajectory only
identifies a supply
of
1498 dwellings
over the remainder of the plan period
excluding the appeal site
so therefore
and because we know that the planned
period is to 2025
yeah we discussed that earlier
both parties agree that there is a
shortfall against the minimum housing
requirement
in the adopted development plan of
331 dwellings and that's set out in
paragraph 2.6 you see that
so what that's saying
what that's saying
is that without the development site
without the development site
the number of homes that the plan
anticipated should be delivered to the
end of the plan period
will not be delivered based on the
council's supply position
that's what it says but unless we bring
in some brownfield sites forward
well that will help yeah but well well
counselor what we have to do you
understand when we're looking at housing
land supply is we have to look what the
position is now as we sit here in front
of the inspector and secondly we have to
look at what sites are deliverable
because we know we're in that five-year
period now to the end of the plan period
and that when we carry out that
assessment it's based on an assessment
of existing planning permissions
allocations and windfall developments
which are in the council's supply so all
of that's been taken into account by
your housing officers presumably that
helped and assisted in terms of this
statement
and what it demonstrates is that
both parties agree that there is a
shortfall against the minimum housing
requirement set out in the adopted
development plan
of 331 dwellings so what that is
demonstrating is that without the appeal
site because that's not included in that
calculation the council will not meet
its housing figure that it's required to
meet
by the end of the plan period
you see that based on the current supply
yeah as it is now but we don't know
what's coming forward
within that this period up to 2025 which
may
um
actually
bring more sites forward and help with
the um the housing supply okay but you
you but we don't know that because we
haven't got them in well i assume we
haven't they um our planning department
as you haven't got any new developments
coming as that when this was printed on
the seventh anyone you understand this
is based on your deliverables oh yeah
yeah okay good thank you and um we can
see that um
in terms of
the council's trajectory which is
anticipating
1498 dwellings
uh
a supply of
1498 dwellings over the remainder of the
plan period excluding the appeals sites
that's table four yeah
we can see that that is that is
essentially assuming that is essentially
assuming 380 units in 2021 22
362 the following year
447 the following year and then 309 the
following year giving us the total of
1498. see that that's the map whole
rocket district yes it is yes okay
and um just looking at looking at those
numbers there in that table
um we can see this the completions to
that extent is going to be challenging
because
there's only been if you look at this
it's reliant on for three of those
periods three of those periods
completions in excess of
360
dwellings per annum
and that is something that has only been
achieved once if you look at the table
above
since 2006 to 2007. you see that
yeah
so even
so say the point the i'm putting to you
here is
that even this
331 dwellings to the end of the
plan period shortfall
is conservative even completions at this
kind of level in table four are going to
be challenging for the council aren't
they
no other applications come forward yes
okay
thank you
and in terms of other allocation sorry
other allocations
and other sites that might come forward
if you look at page nine please that
sets out the latest position in
respective housing allocations
and this is the agreed position
okay
and um
you can see at 2.12 it says it's agreed
the following table sets out the latest
position on residential allocations
in the allocations document
and the appeal site is the last of nine
settlement extension residential land
allocations to start delivering
dwellings
um and we can see there that effectively
um there's no other than the appeal site
there's no
capacity left
within the other allocations to deliver
the 331 dwellings required
to the end of the plan period
we've got 500 on seo i'm sorry ser six
which is going to be completed in 20
yeah that's the count of four in the
numbers though isn't it that has been
counted and so has the great wakering
side yeah so these are they're still
they're actually actually in this site
yeah and i okay yeah so those so so
sorry the point is is that when you're
looking at your forward supply
you're looking at ones that have that
that might have planning permission or
be an allocation that can come forward
in additional into additional additional
ones okay so those sites have already
been countered
yep yes because that make it clear in
this story yeah clearly so those have
been countered so my point is in terms
of additional sites in terms of
additional sites
that there isn't additional spare
capacity of any other allocations etc
that can meet that 331
figure to the end of the plan period not
as not as come forward at today's date
no but not at all because this what what
this table does is it looks at what
those allocations are and what their
existing position is in respect of them
so they're either complete not
deliverable or under construction
so my point is this is the only
allocation that can come forward within
your plan
to meet that 331 unit shortfall but as i
stated before this yes this is the uh as
at today yeah but if um for argument's
sake if next week we get an appeal
decision that's gone against council and
we get an allocation for 300 homes and
this is hypothetical
then that could be added into this plan
sorry i think added into these
allocations i think we're talking across
purposes so i'm talking about i'm not
talking about windfall planning
permissions which are ones that come
forward not on allocated sites i'm
talking about allocated sites
so page nine sets out what the position
is in respect of your out the sites that
the council has chosen to allocate in
its development plan so that have some
planning status now yeah
and
what that table demonstrates is that
there is no additional capacity
on any other allocated site
to increase the number who increased the
numbers sufficiently to deliver those
331 dwellings by the end of the plan
period
except that yeah thank you
um and so
what that means
what that means
is that
as we sit here now based on what we know
because the deliverable supplies looked
at existing planning permissions and
also sites that are deliverable that
perhaps don't have planning permission
and it's also
um we've also just discussed what there
is in respect of allocations which is
not sufficient capacity within them
to meet that particular
housing need 331 to the end of the plan
period
what that means is that the appeal site
which is an allocation within the plan
is critical
to achieve the numbers that the plan
envisaged would be delivered or come
forward by the end of the plan period
isn't it but yes but that's not why we
refuse this application i know and i
know you've got your other material
consideration if i say we did not um
refuse it on 500
or six well we didn't refuse it on 500
because the application was 662.
so we
that wasn't um a reason why it was
refused and i fully agree
this is on the appeal site and it would
help
for the housing allocation that we is
needed within this area
but i just want to be clear because i
appreciate your point in terms it wasn't
refused on that basis but you'll
understand as the witness that's doing
the planning balance
that as well as the other impacts that
you've taken into account you also have
to take into account the benefits
and so yeah and so so my point really to
you
is that the allocation this allocation
and not only this allocation but the 662
units that are being brought forward in
accordance with that allocation
are critical
to meet the requirements of the plan to
the end of the plan period yes uh yeah
for the 800 and whatever yeah yeah okay
that's very helpful and we also know
though that um the 250 figure which was
in the plan and you've alluded to this
several times um does not
now reflect the requirements in the
framework because now the framework says
that the council's housing need is
actually 362
rather than 250. doesn't it yeah so what
what that's telling us is in fact that
it's even more important it's even more
important
critical more important
that those allocated sites
come forward
because the housing requirement has
increased now yeah yeah as long as the
housing well we we can't stop anyone
from outside the district
we may have 662 houses and then we've
got i'm not we're not going to talk
about social housing if you reduce that
um if we've got 400 units for
um
it will take our need out but it will
not necessarily help our residents
because people outside can actually buy
the houses so even though we may produce
what they say it doesn't actually affect
or help our people on in this district
okay but you understand that as as chair
of the planning committee and an
affiliate member of the rtpi
you understand that national policy and
the ppg it sets out a formula for
assessing what the housing need is in
this district and that housing need is
362
dwellings per annum
and there is a requirement for the
council to identify sufficient sites to
accommodate that need
and
because that need is now figure a figure
higher than your development plan figure
it's even more critical even more
important that the sites that the
council has allocated in its plan come
forward to assist you in terms of
addressing those needs
yes but again we have issues with the
infrastructure yep got that i mean i
know i know it's going to be we
highlight that all the time but i do
think it's a very
yeah um good point okay well don't worry
we're going to come to the overall
balance in a minute but i'm looking at
the components on yeah so even more
important that allocated sites
come forward
to meet those housing needs
okay
and um
we also know if we look at 2.34 of the
statement of common ground please
oh no there's not 2.34 just bear with me
second
uh
2.24
sorry
2.2.2 2.24 on page 11.
and 2.23 just above it
and you can locate that by reference to
a table do you have that yeah yeah so
this is telling us here because you're
also aware as chair of the planning
committee that there is a requirement
and it's a requirement of national
policy to demonstrate a minimum of a
five-year housing land supply
against that housing need figure that
we've just discussed yep
and we can see in paragraph 2.23 of the
statement of common ground
that the council's forward supply is
4.04 years you see that
and so the authority is not meeting its
minimum requirement
in respect of its forward supply as set
out in national policy is it which is a
minimum of a five-year housing land
supply
um and um we can see it's also agreed at
2.24
that both parties agree that should the
appeal be allowed then the shortfall in
the five-year housing land supply would
be addressed by the deliverable
dwellings on the appeal site and
therefore the council would be able to
demonstrate a deliverable five-year
supply at the 31st of march 2021
so just pausing there
what that's demonstrating again to us
is that the delivery of the appeal site
which is an allocated site
is critical
because it's going to allow the council
to effectively recover its five-year
housing land supply position yes it's an
allocated site so it's critical isn't it
it will be
good now we're going to turn to
affordable housing next so we've already
looked at the fact that the affordable
housing needs are acute in the core
strategy that was a core strategy that
was adopted in 2011 so we're now 10
years on from that
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
look at what the need is with you and
then i'm going to look at how it we say
it will be met
through
the appeals scheme so two stages two
bite-sized chunks to what we're looking
at so if you look at the statement of
common ground please and it's paragraph
two
2.
2.
7
is where we start dealing with
affordable housing delivery and supply
on page seven yes
and
we can see
at 2.7
that there's a reference there to the
core strategy
which was talking about that at the time
the course strategy was adopted there
was a need for 130 it identified a need
for 131 net edition or affordable homes
to be developed in the district per year
so that was a
net requirement for 131 units you see
that yeah
and we can see in the table
sorry not we can see sorry in the
following paragraph
that it is agreed
that
only
362 net affordable homes have been
delivered
in rochford 2006 to 21
which is an average of 26 affordable
homes per annum you see that
so
that is very significantly
below
the 131 net additional homes per annum
that the core strategy identified was
required isn't it
and we can see actually if you look at
the table because that's the average
figure
in terms of um we've got again we've got
affordable housing needs that's the 131
figure
completions shortfall against need and
then cumulative shortfall
and we can see
that since 2006 which is the start of
the plan period even though it was
adopted in 2011
that there has not been a single year
where that affordable housing
requirement has been met
yeah you see that shortfall against need
they're all minus figures
so because we've got a 35 only got a 35
on each
development so we
um unless you allow thousands of houses
coming to an area then it won't be this
will not be completed i'm thinking about
what the need is
we definitely need a social housing as i
think i've said and others are getting
their statements yeah so
just looking at the table what we can
see is there has not been a single year
that we've achieved that we've achieved
it
and we can see at the bottom of the page
uh on in the right hand column
we then have a cumulative shortfall
which is standing at 1 603 dwellings as
against that core strategy
figure yes
and then what we know it's getting
better as we can see in the last three
years three years it's still not good no
exactly
and then if we look at 2.9
uh we see that there's a more recent
schma that's been produced by the
council which contains the latest
calculation of affordable housing need
in rochford
and demonstrates a significant need for
more affordable housing across all
tenures which is the point that you've
raised counsellor
and it says that it identifies now a
need for
296 affordable homes every year
falling to 238 after five years over the
period 2014 to 2037 so it's a different
period but it's effectively rebasing the
need isn't it and looking at that and it
says against this so it's coming out
with the same shortfall almost bar three
dwellings but there is a shortfall of
1606 affordable homes between 2014 and
2020 and that's set out in the following
table so however one gets to it
however one gets to it the position is
that there are over 16
hundred homes
that were needed
and that have not been provided
to date
yes okay
and um what we can also see
is because you recall when we spoke
about the core strategy one of the
things that we looked at was how those
are delivered and it says that well the
only way really that we can do that is
through market led schemes where a
proportion of the housing is required to
come forward as affordable housing
now i look at what the appeal scheme
does in a moment in terms of that
but we can see
at 2.10 in terms of other things that
are happening
that the council's supply
over the
next uh
five years
is 471 homes you see that
now obviously over the next five years
you've got an
additional requirement that arises year
on year as well as the existing
shortfall
of sixteen hundred
odd
affordable homes that are required yeah
and so that the councils existing supply
the 471 figure
is not going to scratch the surface is
it
of meeting affordable housing needs in
the district not according to these
figures no these agreed figures he's
agreed figures
okay
and then um
what the appeal proposals just bear with
me one second because i just want to
check something
reference just a sec
just want to make sure we're not talking
about
purposes
okay
so
okay so um at
2.11 of the statement of common ground
what that records
is that given the position on affordable
housing delivery and supply in rochford
it is agreed that the delivery of
232 affordable homes at the appeal site
carries very significant weight in the
planning balance
now that's that's the agreement now i
just want to be clear that you
understand
what we're actually delivering because
i'm not sure from some of your answers
that aren't that we do i have read it
and i do know how many there was no it's
not it's not sorry it's not just the
number so in in the framework in the
mppf there is a definition of affordable
housing at the back of the framework if
you want to have a look at it
and it's housing for sale or rent for
those whose needs are not met by the
market
including housing that provides a
subsidised route to home ownership and
or is essential for local workers and
which complies with one or more of the
following definitions i'm not reading
them all out because they're all quite
lengthy but they're set out there and so
there's a specific definition
of um affordable housing within the mppf
and what the appellant is providing
is 80
affordable rent and 20 shared ownership
and shared ownership available to
households with less than
um with with a certain level of income
yeah
and 20 also 20 wheelchair
adaptable affordable units
72 accessible and adaptable units and
the obligations in respect of what we're
providing in terms of the types of
housing and the fact that they need to
be affordable housing
that falls within the definition
of national policy so not just low-cost
market housing but affordable housing is
secured through the section 106
obligation and i think i do agree with i
completely understand that but on
the whole road estate the affordable
housing the minimum rent 600 pounds
as i will go back to if you've got
carers on minimum wage
600 odd pound is not affordable and this
is what this is what i was trying to say
earlier i appreciate we've got the this
new development will give us 232
35
completely agree with that i completely
agree with the figures because i've done
finance all my life so i do know figures
but
my still point is
the definition of affordable is
that's what we've got to look at for the
residents of rochford right the rochford
district so i want to be clear because
the local planning authority's position
here at 2.11 is that taking into account
the definitions of affordable housing in
the framework and the specific
obligations that my client is delivering
through this scheme not talking about
other ones but this scheme and the
obligations offered here because that's
what we're dealing with
the agreed position of the authority is
that very significant way it should be
attributed to that in the planning
balance as set out at 2.11 of the
statement of common ground like you
agree with that counsellor thank you
um
okay
and in terms of um
just in terms of
yeah and just in terms of the provision
of housing generally at 2.25
so just sorry i should have raised this
point i was talking about the general
position earlier it's also the agreed
position in terms of the general
position
with those housing numbers that new
housing at the appeals site will carry
significant weight in the balance yeah
yep good
okay and then um what i want to do as
well is also think about the degree to
which the council's emerging plan is
going to effectively come to the rescue
in terms of the
housing needs that we have
considered
and um we know you can pop that one
aside now the statement of common ground
[Applause]
um
and um
excuse me
yeah it's just behind the um it's just
behind the oops
uh the al at the um
oh it's oh sorry you've got different
folders to me apparently in terms of the
way they're organized
it's the one that looks like i did tab
it up the other day
you got that one
so sorry cd 6.4 6.4
okay and this this is the new local plan
spatial options consultation paper 2021
yeah
and it it's at regulation 18 stage so
it's being consulted on and it's
consulting on
um spatial options for an emerging local
plan isn't it
and um
it
with me a second
and i think on page five it said the
consultation will close on wednesday the
22nd of september 2021. so consultations
closed on it
and
what what it does it pay if you turn up
page seven please
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's page seven is um
setting out that this is
a consultation paper that forms the
latest stage in the production of the
council's new local plan
and it sets out this paragraph two a
range of challenges and opportunities
relating to the district and it's
looking at how the district can change
and grow
over the next 20 years
and it says just bottom
sentence there this consultation is an
important step in exploring the
advantages and disadvantages of
different strategy options
alongside the contribution these can
make to fulfilling the objectives of the
district in its diverse settlements so
i'm not going to read inspector can read
all of that later but that's basically
i'm going to read the whole lot i'm not
going to help read the whole lot so
that's basically what it's it's aiming
at and um it's it's right because it's
been out consultation already and it's
it's it's a
regulation 18 consultation so as i
understand it the process in this
council is that prior to this document
going out to consultation
it would have been approved firstly by
the policy committee and then secondly
by full council yes
and that was in july 2021 i think um
there's my instructions
if you can't remember the exactly i
can't remember but yes
i could always go back onto the next no
no no no don't don't worry i don't need
the jewel they could always do go
through the last year
yeah it would be the last year
yeah
and my understanding and from those did
did you i think you voted to approve
this document when it comes out to
consultation i've got my book over there
with all my minutes on so i can actually
tell you okay so you you voted to
approve this document to go out to
consultation
and um just if we look at it on on page
eight in terms of looking at what the
potential options for the district might
be
um we can see
we can see there that there's a
reflection
it's under how have we got here
and it's it's talking about that there's
a reflection that prior to formulating
the options there was a period of um
community and public engagement that the
council would have taken into account
yeah
um and um if we then turn to page 49
please
and we see again
at the top of page 49 why why is it
important to plan for the right amount
of growth
and it's talking there about the
up-to-date position rochford district an
area with known housing challenges many
of which have been exacerbated by covid
our housing register has grown by 20 in
the last year to around 1 000 households
so just pausing there
that's the more up-to-date position in
respect of the council's housing waiting
list
and what we can see is that there's been
a
decrease
sorry there's been an inc a decreasing
affordable the provision the the supply
of affordable home an increase in the
housing waiting list since the core
strategy was um
adopted um and the ratio between house
prices and local earnings is amongst the
least affordable in the country so it's
it's again recognizing that there really
are the the most significant affordable
housing needs in this district aren't
there yes there is um and when new homes
are built around a third of these are
built is affordable typical typically
discounted by at least 20 percent
by taking a positive approach to growth
locally we can help create a more
inclusive housing market
avoiding the emergence of housing
related issues including homelessness
and concealed households such as whereas
younger people are forced to remain and
return to their family etc so those are
the points we've just discussed in terms
of those needs but
the point here is recognizing those
needs and that the council needs to plan
to accommodate housing needs going
forward as our population grows we need
more houses yeah that's the fact of life
it is
and if we look at um page 73 and 76.
uh we can also uh see there
and i don't think i need to to to read
these out but it's effectively the same
point and if you just cast dry over the
first two paragraphs at
73
[Applause]
again i would say we do need the right
houses uh
for our local people and this is what
we're they'll be looking at this new
local plan
okay so it's recognizing the importance
of continuing to plan for and provide an
adequate quantum of affordable housing
essentially very poor council if you
didn't do that thank you
um and um if we then look at page 53
so page 53 is looking at what options
are available to the council
the option
yeah so so this is looking at and i know
obviously the council needs to determine
which of these options is going to um
because we can see it pages 53 to
through to
uh well it's about page 61. but
essentially um there are a number of
options said set out here in terms of
how the council will accommodate
its growth yeah
and um strategy one
urban intensification
and it says
option one is the minimum expectation of
national policy
and is likely to be required within
every strategic
option
this option would be to make best use of
our existing planned development and
also brownfield sites and so on which
you've already mentioned
um a strategy based on urban
intensification could also include
taking a more permissive approach to
higher densities in suitable locations
such as town centres and near stations
we expect that at least 4 200 homes will
be built over the next 10 years under
this option
and our urban capacity study suggests a
further 1500 homes could be built
through a mixture of maximizing capacity
of planned housing developments and
taking a more permissive approach to
higher densities in urban areas so i'm
just going to pause here and break it
down into bite-size bits
so the first point in respect of this
and the options that the council has
approved through this sorry
the potential options that the council
has approved at regulation 18 stage
every single one of those options
includes that first option which is 4
200 homes through urban intensification
yeah
so that is go because and that is
because
that is because option one is the
minimum expectation of national policy
we see that in the first sentence yeah
yeah i know it and obviously we're going
to be bringing the brownfield sites
forward before greenbelt right okay well
we'll look at that how are you going to
do it in a minute but just bite-sized
for the moment so option one is is
reflecting the minimum expectation of
national policy and you're right is
likely to be required within every
strategy every strategy option
and the reason that it is and i think
this is the point you're raising
counsellor
necessary to include it in any option
that the council might consider going
forward
is because if we look at we've looked at
the greenbelt constraints across the
district already
and that's because paragraph
uh 141
of the framework requires authorities
before they look to greenbelt release
and exceptional circumstances for
greenbelt release
it requires the strategic policymaking
authority to demonstrate that it has
examined fully all of the reasonable
options for meeting its identified needs
for development so it's saying you
maximise other opportunities before you
move to release more land from the green
belt essentially that's what it says so
that's what we should any council and we
should be doing that as well exactly so
um so option one
option one
is something that's going to have to
happen
the other options within the preferred
option document talk about
whether and to what extent you also then
release green belt on top of that option
essentially that's right isn't it yeah
obviously it's looking that way it says
we expect at least 4 200 homes
and well how i've read this is we do the
brownfield sites first we don't know how
many that will bring in
after that then
there may have to be an option to go
into
the green belt but first before going
into any green belt we do the brown
field sites yeah so so so what
i think where we are with that
is that the 4 000 although this is at a
relatively early stage because it's
regulation 18 stage and in terms of
these other options so options two to
what is it two to
uh is it five
four
four
two to four options two to four will
look at if and what extent you're going
to then go into the green belt and where
etc we're not really concerned with that
here because we've got an allocated site
um but in terms of
in terms of the baseline position
in terms of the baseline position the
council accepts
that it is going to need to
bring forward
the sites
under option one for those 4 200 homes
at that stage but if we're not actually
going through all this why are we
discussing it if we're only going to a
cro if we're only consuming appeal is
scr8 i'm a bit confused okay well just
bear with me so the council accepts it's
going to need to bring forward those
sites to deliver those 4
homes in accordance with the minimum
expectations of national policy yeah
great yeah
good and if we uh look at um
if we look at what those 4 200 homes are
comprised of we know we've talked about
the brownfield allocations but if you
look at page 47 please
and 40 oh just bear with me a second is
that the right um
yeah page 47
this is looking at the
um
and it's it's planning for housing
growth and it's the bottom paragraph in
that little section
our housing and economic land
availability assessment do you have the
reference there yeah
so what what that says is our housing
healer
housing economic land availability
assessment i'm just going to abbreviate
that to healer from now on um 2020
identifies a supply of 4 300 homes that
are already planned for yeah
so that's reflecting that figure we've
just looked at in option one yeah
this includes existing allocations
sites with planning permissions and an
allowance for windfall developments of
around 45 homes a year when full
development is development which happens
on sites which can afford unexpectedly
and are not provided for in the local
plan so what that's telling us is option
one
option one which is required to meet the
minimum requirements of national policy
and which is
part of every single option that the
council might pursue has set out in here
includes bringing forward existing
allocations
yes
so existing allocations include the scr8
allocation
yes sorry yes yeah
so by resolving by resolving to put this
preferred options paper out to
consultation
which was approved at full council and
included you voting for it
what what that demonstrates is that the
local planning authority also recognises
that
in its new plan
in order to meet housing needs going
forward
that is going to also need to include
the existing allocation
scr scr8 isn't it yes
good and um
okay
i've done that
okay so now i'm just going to look at a
few other matters that sort of you can
pop that away now go on the floor don't
need to put it on the floor it's fine
i'm not into weightlifting today
now um
i just want to consider with you now is
a few other inputs in terms of the
planning balance in respect of benefits
and then we're going to look at the
planning balance as a whole okay so
that's the sort of topic approach we're
going to be
thinking about
and we know that the
local planning authority now
has
no objection to the scheme that it says
is sufficient
a sufficient basis to refuse planning
permission based on those highway safety
concerns that you outlined in your proof
of evidence yeah no counselor eve has
got his point about the mitigation but
i'm talking about the ones that you
would you dealt with in your proof um in
the vicinity of the appeal site yeah
and so
we know no highway safety
issue um sufficient to um
found a reason for refusal there
um
we also know that it was initially the
case that the local planning authority
took issue
took issue and if we just turn back to
your proof of evidence this was
initially
your point b which was the pedestrian
safety generally in a view the package
of measures proposed by the appellant
was simply renewing what is taking place
you recall that one which has also been
um
the council also is no longer pursuing
yeah
but i just want to have a look at those
with you
so um for this you're going to need the
highway statement of common ground with
the highways authority please
it's the
um okay and um
[Applause]
attached to that
uh document
there is a drawing
i'm just going to hold it up so you can
see what it looks like you're looking
for one that looks like that it's it's
in the infinity
[Applause]
the highway authority one
the one from the highways authority
between the appellant and the highway
have you got it that one yeah or one's
in colour
can you hold it pull it towards you
sorry so it's drawing um 185 180 004 and
it's showing the site access and works
there
yeah got it thank you and so um
all right so what what we've got here
and it's just telling telling us about
some of the and we know the council
doesn't object on base of b anymore but
i just want to be clear what we're
talking about in terms of
um what we say are upgrades in the
vicinity of the school in highway safety
terms okay
and um we can see we can see
just bear with me a second
um at the top of the page and at the
bottom of the page
um that there is going to be um existing
signs are going to be replaced with
flashing school ahead signs yeah so
that's going to warn
motorists
with flashing led signs
that the school
they're on the approach to the school
you see that yeah so that's a benefit
isn't it
because it's tell it's telling well it
is isn't it well yeah if if you'll say
so but i do know that a lot we've got
them the vast signs in other areas that
are completely ignored so um
and it obvious they stay well
they'll be queuing there but yeah for
safety reasons yes i will say yes but
that would
with my experience i must probably be
ignored
in other parts of our district well
let's let's let's hope that people do
what they're leaving obliged
and we then have pedestrian guard rails
we then have pedestrian guard rails
and the the point about pedestrian guard
rails is that they segregate pedestrians
from traffic don't they that's their
purpose you ever have them there already
yeah but you you understand that they're
actually going to be increased in
respect of their length i think by 20
meters 20 meters
yes yeah
um and
they're also the visibility of them is
also going to be improved brought up to
standard so again that's the benefit
isn't it
in terms of highway safety
and in terms of the toucan crossing
um
we can see there it says two can
existing two can crossing to be retained
and extended for widened carriageway
refuge island added
signal operation to be modified if
necessary to ensure efficient and safe
timings
and
we also refuge island there we also know
from mr blair there's going to be
renewal of the anti-skid surfacing there
which is worn at the moment so again
that's the benefit in terms of highway
safety isn't it
it can i just point out i'm not being
awkward it is a benefit but when you've
got the young the age of the children
um
they don't always adhere to the highway
code um and if they if you're they're in
the middle of an island and they see
their friend
across the road
they have a tendency they don't think
they're too young they they run and all
we've already had three accidents in the
last six months for children along that
because they're just
if you've got young children they just
look they don't look outwards um so it
could be um
a dress but i don't think it'll it is
but but you know i suppose higher ways
perspectives will say is yeah
improvement well but i mean just just
thinking about that point in terms of
children in particular say primary
school children you know anti-skid
surfacing is a benefit for kids isn't it
because it's going to stop them skidding
is sort of onto the road
a refuge a refuge island a refuge island
is also a benefit isn't it because it's
providing refuge in safety terms so my
point is here that you might
say well okay
there are still outstanding issues
they're not sufficient to
lead to a reason for refusal but there
are benefits here as well aren't there
the minimum benefits benefits okay um
and and we also know that um there are
going to be provided alternative routes
through the appeal site
um which is in particular there are
going to be routes from those to the
south and north
um to access waterman primary school in
king edmonds school by avoiding
ashington road because they'll be able
to walk through the appeal site won't
they that's after um while the
construction it won't help well it will
be after the construction is finished
yeah
um
and
most of the children
for going up to king edmonds
will go straight up passion to road into
the co-op or cafe 206 to get their lunch
right and that is what they do now
and i cannot see that being altered
they will not work go through the new
site to school
most a lot of our children will go and
get their breakfast
before going into school unfortunately
because they do not have breakfast at
home
okay but there will be and you know you
might say well not all of them will use
it but there will be alternative routes
provided through the site which allow
the option for
pedestrians to avoid ashington road on
that basis won't that most of the
parents that use waterman's do not use
the ashland road they come from malting
villas the drive
some marks field and sinclair's
so they actually they're the school and
catchment area so they would not
actually use um the national road to go
to waterman's the
parents that use waterman's would be
centuries it'll be rocha primary
centuries holt farm junior hulk farm
infants
you've got a nursery
and trees and then you've got king
edmunds
okay let me just take it
really simplistically
do you accept that providing alternative
routes through the appeal site will
provide some benefit
only to the people going to case not
going to waltons
thank you
and um
so what we have there is we don't okay
next point is in respect of highway
width in respect of highway width
so
we know
we know that that's no longer a point
being raised in terms of highway safety
as a reason for refusal
and what you do do though um council i'm
just going to pick this point up with
you in terms of your residual concerns
about it
but you you do
include in your
proof of evidence a letter from ecc can
we just i just want to turn it up
because there was there's a chronology
here in terms of the letters from ecc
and if you've included one
at appendix 2 which is from october 2020
um and that that's the one that as you
say sets out um
some that the point about it being a
downgrade essentially that that's what
you summarize in your proof of evidence
albeit acceptable in highway safety
terms
but then if you look at appendix 4
there's the letter dated the 12th of
february 2021.
yep sorry just checking you've got that
and so this this is um we can see here
that this was following um a letter
uh from the council seeking further
views and clarification in respect of
education public health and highways
matters do you see that yeah
and so there's a question there about
the minimum technical width point
and um
over the page under three some more
points about that but um making it clear
that we do not consider the proposal to
reduce the foot and cycle way to be
unacceptable providing it meets the
minimum technical standards for shared
or segregated areas as per point one
above which sets out what those
standards are
so that's that's the point the highways
authority doesn't object in respect of
um highway safety considerations either
yeah
yeah but i haven't brought the highways
um essex highways people down to
actually look at this
right okay well we we're dealing with
the evidence that's been i do appreciate
that okay
bite size points next point however as
outlined in our initial corporate
response it will be a significant
downgrade from what's already in place
and therefore undesirable from an
education and public health perspective
and that's the point that you rely on in
terms of it still being a benefit is
sorry a dis benefit but you say
ways in the planning balance but i just
want to read on to the next paragraph
with you
because it it then looked at how
or potential ways that that could be
dealt with
in this letter
and it says this
we welcome sight of the developers
landscaping proposals within the school
boundary highlighted in your email of
the 4th of february 2021
which includes measures such as
improving internal paths ventures and
additional planting
this developer funded mitigation may be
appropriate but would require support
from the school and ecc property service
we we would therefore recommend further
discussions to explore the acceptability
of the specific mitigation i'm sorry i
i'd prefer not to have the interruptions
yeah we don't we don't need this i've
said it yesterday please
and we would therefore recommend further
discussions to explore the acceptability
of specific mitigation measures but then
it says this
indeed a preferred approach may be
agreeing a financial contribution to
provide the school with some flexibility
in terms of specific mitigation measures
so what it's saying there is thank you
for the proposals
um they may be appropriate they're
probably going to need further
discussion so actually the better way to
deal with it in in the planning sense
might be to agree a financial
contribution to provide the school with
the flexibility in terms of what it
wants to do you see that i can see that
but as
colleagues just said and i do know this
that school
are
they've got over 500 children coming
through there
and they come from north
and south
and to
put a small
pavement through the school
will not help
the safety issues of the children going
in and i don't know how
um
if this development goes ahead
that they actually can actually offer
a sum of money to the school to improve
it because we don't know
we haven't got that in outline anywhere
how much an improvement would cost right
well let's just take it in bite-size
points first point can you turn up
please
um mr blair's volume 4 of his rebuttal
evidence
i've got volume five but not volume four
to hand so just bear with me
oh there we go yep
[Music]
so i don't think we have apart from my
marked up copy a clean copy of that on
this side of the room i was wondering if
someone on the parent's team could help
of course it looks as though yes
and just you're also going to need as
well whilst you're getting it um well
actually i might have to read this edit
so we asked for copies of this but i
know there are copying issues at the
venue so the still compliance schedule
but what i'll do is i'll read it to you
if you don't have a copy and then it can
be checked later if that's acceptable
yeah because we've asked for copies but
there's been issues at the venue
you've got oh brilliant okay
right so i'm going to go to this
i'll just wait for the yeah just just
wait a minute hang on a minute because i
think the the copy of the other
documents coming so let's just get
everything
uh stacked up and then we'll go to the
five minute comfort break well they're
looking is that all right sir well let's
i was just going to check how progress
was going uh how are you you
probably got about
what
what's my time at the moment
we will have a short break now so i've
probably got about half an hour or so
left i would think uh if if we if we
break it's 12 i make it 12 32 if we have
a short break to 12 40
then if you've got half an hour that'll
go just after one o'clock which could
still be acceptable so let's let's try
and aim for that okay
let's have a an adjustment now then
we'll resume at 12 40.
yes
yes
thank you very much
i'm sorry it's because
is
thank you very much the the inquiry is
resumed ladies and gentlemen apologies
that was fairly a short and rushed break
but i'm trying to keep things
moving as best we can so
miss reed
thank you so you recall councillor that
just before the break we were looking at
ecc's response which had said that in
terms of that issue that they had
raised about there being a downgrade
and points about education and public
health
their follow their comment that followed
which was talking about a financial
contribution to provide the school with
flexibility to mitigate that
and um what mr blair has included in his
volume for
is is i think this is the
plan
this is the plan
and we can see this from his
proof of um
evidence
at 3.2.5
that um this this was the plan that was
before ecc and the council i stopped you
sorry where are we looking i'm so sorry
mr blair's mr blair's rebuttal
volume fat four
yeah yeah all right so
right so if if you look at first let's
look at 2.3.5
yep
para 2.3.5 on page 3.
have you got the right it's it's volume
four
i've just got it from your base volume
four yeah i haven't got any maps like
you're showing now i'm
3.2.5
although perhaps unrelated
is that so yeah that's right right
okay it's talking about the section 106
agreement contains an agreed
contribution towards a landscaping
scheme to deliver immunity enhancement
enhancements
in the school frontage area a drawing of
these works is attached to volume four
rebuttal proof appendix a
it's this is an agreed item as described
in 2.35 of the committee report
yeah
okay so this was a matter that was
before the council
um and um
which was and then if you turn up
appendix a which is right at the back
[Music]
these are the landscaping proposals that
ecc is referring to in that letter we
looked at a moment ago where it says we
welcome sight of yeah
and we can see it's not it's not just a
path that's being proposed it's you can
see um
that um
it's a landscape proposal which includes
new areas of for example planting and
also
circular and waves these are examples of
what could be achieved
uh seating to create focal points and
gathering opportunities for pupils and
parents for school drop-off time
yeah you see that so these are the
proposals that were being considered the
ecc said they welcomed sight of
yeah
and then in terms of um
what the local authority planning
authority has said about those
it's in the civil compliance schedule
and it's under the heading school
landscaping scheme
whereabouts is that in the schedules
near the end or because it's not
packaging
which is the issue with it um
when i say page four they're
double-sided but it's the actual
physical page four
it's i see it start starting education
yeah and then after that next one after
our school landscape yeah got it thank
you
and the local planning authority's
comments are in the second column
sorry do you have that counsellor
page four you said
it's probably your page eight yours
isn't double-sided
looking at that
count again i
widen the footpath or i've gone too far
now
no it's after the education it's school
landscaping scheme
yep
right at the bottom lovely sorry
unfortunately it's not paginated which
is not consisting is it
um right so this is this is still
compliance schedules this is the
council's position in respect of why
these contributions are necessary
directly related to the development and
uh fair and reasonable
um
and it says necessary the widening of
ashington road to create a ghost right
term for the development would result in
the footwear being narrowed so that's
your point and then it says this
landscaping scheme would ensure the
footway is a suitable size
so the reason it's saying that is
because although the footwear will be
narrowed there's a sum of money which we
can see is
um either
the obligation is in the first paragraph
there
either an obligation sorry either a
schema to landscape the frontage will be
submitted to the county council at the
same time as application for reserve
matters or a 50 000 pounds contribution
to the council to be used to carry out
works
yep
you see that yeah
and the reason that that's necessary
this is the council's world words
is because the footway will be narrowed
and this landscaping scheme would ensure
the footwear is a suitable size
so what it's saying is although the
footwear will be narrowed because the
obligation provides money to secure an
improved environment within the school
frontage that's going to compensate and
provide
a safe and convenient
drop-off and pick up area for parents
and children within the school and the
council's words are this landscaping
scheme would ensure
that the footwear is a suitable size so
that is the council's position isn't it
now
yes i know it is but i don't agree
because this looks very very pretty and
it's very nice for holt farm uh children
infants and junior schools
but you will still have
as i said there's
i think there's 500
something children go to those two
schools
and coming from retreat road that's
junction one
going towards junction three dailies
road we have got centuries on the same
side so we still have accumulation of
children and parents on that footway
where they've got to go past the school
to go to the other school
if they go to the rochester primary
it'll be the other side that's not an
issue
just just bite-sized chunks again there
are two points that were raised in
respect of this the first was highway
safety and the narrowing point which has
been resolved and which just just
bite-sized chunks
so that's the highway safety point and
that's people going up and down the road
and that it's going to be safe for those
people steve to be safe
and the council has withdrawn its
objection in respect to the safety issue
the second point that you raised was in
respect to this public sort of general
amenity point for those people who are
effectively waiting on the pavement
before and after school drop off
yeah
and that set and that's the point that's
being dealt with by ecc there in that
letter
and that point is resolved
through the provision of this obligation
isn't it
right so what that means is taken in the
round
taken in the round
and now that you've had an opportunity
to have a look at this and to consider
the obligation properly in the sill
compliance statement
those matters do not
the narrowing of the footway taking into
account that mitigation the contribution
does not relate does not is not a
disbenefit to weigh in the equation
because those matters have been dealt
with that's what hap that's what i said
yesterday that um yes we know it's being
reduced
and yes it is compliant
but no i still don't agree with it which
is a completely different matter right
but sorry just just bite-sized chunks no
way highway safety concern
sufficient to refuse the application or
otherwise is being raised by the council
now the secondary point
was in respect of this public health
issue that was rate and you relied on
ecc's letters in that respect yeah
i'm sorry i'm just struggling to
hear
um the second was the point about ecc
and the amenity and put the immunity
point yeah
that point
that point has also now been resolved
even as a disbenefit by virtue of this
obligation within the section 106
obligation
so what that means
is that there is no negative taking
everything into account to weigh in the
back planning balance in respect to this
issue is that no i still don't agree
with it
so no negative but don't agree with it
sorry was that a no but you don't agree
with it exactly so yeah okay
because what the council doesn't do
either what the council doesn't do
either
and just be absolutely clear on this
point is you haven't produced any
evidence taking into account these two
points to demonstrate that active travel
would be
hindered as a result of these measures
either so also not a negative to weigh
in the balance taking everything into
account agreed agreed thank you
and so um where that
and then final point is in respect of
parking
um and again although the council
initially raised an issue in respect of
parking that's now being withdrawn yeah
agreed
and um just just want to be clear about
this um
in terms of what is proposed in terms of
what is proposed
um
it's
just both me a second
two points
is that
as follows the first is that there is
going to be dedicated parking that's
going to be secured as a result of the
planning obligation isn't that within
the site yes
and what that is going to
result in
is firstly that there will be
dedicated spaces for school drop-offs
and pickups yeah
there's going to be ten isn't there yeah
dedicated education right so
what
there are two points in respect of that
the first is that there is going to be a
net increase in the number of spaces
available as compared to those that are
lost
yes no
well there are counts there aren't there
because there isn't can i say they're
using a slip road at the moment which is
essex highways
land and they can put up to 20
people parking there
but the safety partnership essex
partnership are going to be putting
yellow lines on so you completely lost
those right so so just to be clear the
scheme the appeal scheme is going to
lead to the loss of four of those spaces
in that lay by it's going to lose them
all as i've just said because there's
going to be
double yellow lines all the way through
there the plan is going ahead now with
this
safety
that's the south essex parking
tro
yes yeah the set
okay i have got um
lost it they have been given permission
and the funds although we'll be putting
in
uh essex will be putting in double
yellow lines which will stop
the parents
or relatives picking up the children so
we've actually lost those but yes we
have gained the ones on the sites
but who is going to police those because
if you've got 20 parents there's going
to be a rage what was going on who's
going to pick the kids up because they
get there
um
i don't know if it was mr blair that
actually went and did the assessment but
the school comes out of three
that they can be there from half past
one guaranteeing getting the parking
space which is absolutely ridiculous
let's let's just and i'll do but
let's just do the right size i
appreciate it you know i understand your
concerns let's do the bite size points
the first point is the traffic
regulation order that you've just
discussed
so that's that's now at a stage where
it's going to be implemented
right that's nothing to do with this
development is it that's going to happen
anyway yeah regardless if we had to
develop there or not that will happen so
in the world that the development
doesn't exist
all of those car parking spaces go yes
and nothing additional is provided for
school drop-off and pick-up
yeah
in the world where the development goes
ahead
there are going to be 10 dedicated
spaces
that are provided
in respect
of school drop-off and pick up provision
yeah
now those 10 spaces that is going to be
an improvement
over and above
what is going to exist without the
development because you go from none in
the world without the development to 10.
so that is a benefit isn't it this will
be a benefit thank you
and um given the
given the issues attack you've just
identified i i assume you accept that
significant weight should be given to it
as a
benefit there should be benefits but i
think if you're going to do a
development for a size of 662 um
houses
that um parents will
they'll be parking
on the road with their own developments
and
there will be potential people parking
on the road from the schools
right to pick up so yeah we have got
right sorry we do have no we can't do it
we can't we can no i know you can't do
that i'm sorry no if you've got the
community center yeah or whatever it's
going to be yeah
those 10 allocated spaces will be within
that center as i thought i read on the
plans
now if you've got a health center
our health centers open at seven o'clock
in the morning
in this district
so
the parking spaces may be allocated to
the health center
and then you're going to say to patients
sorry you can't use them
i'm just going to have i missed the
point
i'm going to interject because i'm
waiting for the answer to the question
which was put to you about significant
weight should be given to this benefit
yes it should be given and
i was waiting to write what you thought
about that and then suddenly we went
somewhere else
so that's why i've interjected so okay
so thank you significant weight to that
as a benefit but then in terms of your
point about how are you going to secure
that
the
sill compliance schedule
gives a bit as a bit of information
about that so i'm just going to read it
to you because no problems finding it
developer proposes to provide a number
of parking spaces to the far west of the
site for use by the public when drop off
from children from halt farm infant and
junior school
the specification of these visitor
spaces will be controlled by condition
the section 106 secures the delivery and
management of those spaces prior to
first occupation
the developer is proposing that these
spaces only be used in connection with
the primary school during certain times
of the day and aside from these times
the spaces could be used by those
visiting development
and then in terms of the lpa
the lpa's comments necessary the lpa did
not originally request these spaces be
provided i think that's officers didn't
originally request it however it has
since been established these will
benefit the local community so that's
why it's said to be necessary there and
then fair and reasonable it is fair and
reasonable for a development of this
size to provide visitor parking and due
to the developments location allowing
these pickups and drop-offs for the
children is welcomed as it will ease
congestion on ashingdon road
um and uh
so then it says it sets out in the
appellants box
points about sill compliance and then
this planning obligation is particularly
welcomed by members and when you look at
the section 106 obligation there's an
obligation there to secure that that
happens and the management of that and
how that's going to be secured so taking
all of that into account it has been
secured through the 106 obligation
and significant weight should be given
to it as a benefit shouldn't it
counsellor yes it should thank you
and in terms of those highway safety
points then that we've just looked at
we've got the position where
we're looking at where the balance is in
terms of highway safety no issues now
taken by the council in respect of high
pedestrian safety in the vicinity of the
site access and we've been through what
the proposals are in terms of improving
highway safety
and also we've got the landscaping
scheme in terms of public community
so on on balance on balance in terms of
highway safety in the vicinity of the
school site there's going to be a net
benefit isn't that on balance on balance
on the paper
well
you appreciate that we have to deal with
the evidence that we've got here now so
on balance on the evidence there's going
to be a net benefit in terms of highway
safety i actually agreed that i said yes
thank you
and in terms of highway safety that's
obviously a key priority of the council
and so that net benefit in terms of
highway safety should be accorded
significant weight shouldn't it yes
um and then in terms of um in terms i'm
not going to go through every single
point in mr gascoigne's proof with you
in terms of benefits i'll pick them up
with
mr pie croft because i'm aware of time
constraints i've got some other points i
want to take with you in terms of the
balance but i do just want to have a
think about the community centre
because in terms of the self-compliance
the community center it luckily happily
this one is the first one on the
is the first
the first one
so hopefully we can all have a look at
that
um and what we can see there is um
in in part one
um it says healthcare land and it's it
says the landowner is offering
an area marked as community land on the
healthcare plan
to the nhs for the sum of one pound
the offer period will run from two years
from the commencement of development
and then it says necessary and then
again this is the council
the development site will mean that
there will be more people requiring
local health care services if used by
the nhs the health care land will
facilitate a new general practitioner
medical surgery and surgeries and
associated facilities for the residents
of the development and other residents
who live in the vicinity of the appeal
site this will generate gp surgery
capacity and mitigate against the
impacts of the development
so a facility that's going to be offered
to the nhs for a pound
and can assist in in meeting some of the
issues we've heard about from residents
yeah
and if
um given that that's the position and
again the council has said this will
generate surgery capacity mitigate
against the impacts of development and
will also provide facilities for the
residents of the development and other
residents
that is the benefit of the scheme isn't
it it is a very generous offer
from
the developer
and it's lovely to have a brand new
health care uh facility
but we don't want it to be a white
elephant when we can't have the health
care workers in there when we can't
the doctors are not coming through the
system as we
sit today okay well it will be a
generous offer yeah well just just want
to be clear because you know it's it's
something that's in the obligation and
that the council is saying is necessary
directly related and fair and reasonable
so the council's the council's position
is that it's a justified contribution on
that basis isn't it what i've just said
it's a generous offer but the section
106 money for the nhs
will go to the nhs the uh the council
actually hold it give it to the nhs and
then it's down to the nhs on how they
spend it well hang on we're talking
about the land at the moment yeah but
i'll say it's you're saying it's an nhs
uh healthcare which will it won't be uh
it will be under the nhs won't it won't
be under the councils
no the land the landowners offering
an area of land to the nhs for one pound
then if you turn over there's also a
contribution
of 262 300 pounds which again the
council has agreed is necessary directly
related and fair and reasonable so the
council's accepted those contributions
and is putting them in front of the
inspector on the basis that they meet
the tests
they will go to the nhs
um after
this has gone through and then it will
be down to the nhs where they spend the
money okay
right so
so the opportunity to provide
that land
and to provide that facility for the
benefits of the community
firstly is a benefit isn't it as i said
it's a very generous offer yeah it's a
benefit isn't it clearly and sorry it
is a benefit right i just want to be
clear thank you and um it is a benefit
that should be accorded significant
weight isn't it
if it is used yes
so is that well there's no evidence it
won't no it can't be it's got to be yes
right so it's yes thank you significant
weight
um so now we turn to the planning
balance the planning balance oh sorry
just final point in terms of benefit the
other one and there was a bit of i think
confusion in your examination in chief
on this but we're now
we're now at the point aren't we where
it's agreed that bringing forward the
appeal development will be in accordance
with the development plan we've dealt
with that your points about material
considerations which we'll come on to in
a minute
so um
in in examination in what mr gascoigne
and mr pycroft say as well there is a
benefit looking at your housing needs
etc of bringing forward development in
accordance with the plan led system and
the allocation and that should be
accorded significant weight
given that you now agree that there is
compliance with the development plan i
assume you agree with that position as
well your issue is one of balance yes
thank you
okay so then in terms of what that
balance is
if we return to your proof of evidence
[Applause]
so um
we know
and you're going to need the mppf as
well actually just for this section
um
so if you turn up paragraph 11 of the
framework please
and just put your finger in that or a
tab on it and the other one you're going
to need is paragraph 111
that's what i thought you were going to
refer to
there you go you're at the point now
where you're preempting my questions so
there we go
so um
two two points then um
in terms of in terms of the point that
you
raise
um having regards paragraph
111 of the framework
um first
um
right so um
development should only be prevented or
refused on highway grounds if there
would be an unacceptable impact on
highway safety or the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
would be severe so what that's telling
us is if there is an impact that is
below
that given level so below an
unacceptable impact on highway safety or
below a severe impact i.e an impact
that's not severe
then in those circumstances that should
not stop planning permission being
granted
yeah
and just to be clear in terms of your
point on highway safety and this is a
balance point really
um
yesterday we heard
councillor eve's
concerns
about his perception
of the mitigation measures at rectory
road you you recall that
but but you counselor shaw as chair of
the planning committee and also an
affiliate member of the rtpi
you understand that significant weight
needs to be given to the view of the
statutory council t the highways
authority and you can only depart from
that if there are clear and compelling
reasons to do that you understand that
don't you
so we understand that and
the reason i'm asking you this is
because it's you giving the planning
balance evidence and you're obviously an
affiliate member of the rtpi
and whilst we understand council eve's
concerns and his perceptions that he's
set out in his evidence
i presume you accept
that there is no evidence that the
scheme should take and take into account
the other points we've dealt with in
terms of highway safety
there is no evidence to suggest that the
scheme should be prevented or refused on
highway safety grounds
no only refused on the severe congestion
that is that's my point and i'll go with
counsellors but on
on balance what we've said no right so
on balance taking everything into
account including his expressed concerns
at rectory road
and taking into account those points
about highways authority clearing
compelling evidence the local planning
authority's remaining point relates to
congestion doesn't it
good
okay
thank you um and so um
in respect of that point
um what it says then is
should only be prevented or refused on
highway safety ground if the residual
cumulative impact on the road network
would be severe now bite-sized chunks
what that means is if the inspector
finds
that there
would be an impact but that it's not
severe
then that shouldn't be sufficient to
refuse the application should it
if the inspector finds that the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
are severe and just pausing there the
test isn't whether there is
a severe impact
the decision maker as you understand i'm
sure needs to look at
the cumulative impacts on the road
network as a whole yeah you understand
that
um if there is a finding that the
residual well if there is a finding that
there is a severe impact
there then needs to be consideration as
to whether the residual cumulative
impacts on the road network as a whole
or severe yeah
and it's only and if they're not
then planning permission should not be
refused
yeah
right
if the position
is that the residual cumulative impacts
on the road network would be severe
yeah
paragraph 111 does not say permission
must be refused
what then one has to do
is carry out the planning balance that's
set out in paragraph 11 of the framework
yeah yeah
good
um and so what paragraph 11 and this is
why you needed your finger in it and
you're probably going to get to it
quicker than me because i'm on the
laptop
what that tells us to do
what that tells us to do
in the tilted balance work
in the tilt of balance world that we
find ourselves in yeah
uh which is to grant planning permission
excuse me sir may i interject for a
moment i think uh
councillor shaw is struggling a bit
physically and she may require another
short break i would think
well council shaw hasn't said anything
my eyes have been used to swim i've been
reading all this because i will need
food soon being a diabetic yeah
but i don't want if it's only going to
be about five to ten minutes
um more questioning i'm preparing well
it's acceptable to go on for there but
um if we're to go on for another half an
hour so i would probably have something
i i hope we're not going to go influence
i'll i'll check with with miss reed if
if we are then i will certainly break
but i mean thank you mr foster but i
mean council shaw could quite easily
have told me can we have another comfort
break so now i would actually would like
if we have a break i'd like to have a
food break yes of course
speaking sort of on behalf of council
sure i'm just a bit concerned
if she's saying her eyes beginning to
swim and stuff whether
it might not be because obviously we're
coming up to the overall planning
balance i don't want to okay well we we
misread are you content if you might
have to
go go back and and
repeat some of these if if we break i
just finished this little tiny section
which will be literally a minute or so
and then we'll we can break and i'll
finish it off after the break so are you
content with that that's fine
so that we get to yeah yeah of course
which is why i said you might have to
wind back because you might have to end
up repeating some things if you feel
that okay you're in any way you've been
disrupted here
please everyone really finish this
question and then let's let's do the one
question or the one point and then we'll
have a
so so if we're in in the realms of
residual cumulative impact is severe
that then has to be fed in into the
planning balance in accordance with
paragraph 11 of the framework and that's
where the tilted balance comes in
and it tells us that we grant planning
permission unless
and the first one is that the
applications of policies in the
framework that protect areas or assets
of particular importance provides a
clear reason for refusing the
development proposed and there's a
number of points set out in the footnote
seven
and none of them apply here
but what footnote seven doesn't say is
for example
where the residual cumulative impacts on
the highway network are severe so
the tilt of balance applies in this case
counsellor doesn't it right and so what
we then have to do is consider those
impacts whatever they are in the context
of the tilted balance and consider
whether the adverse impacts of granting
permission would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits when
assessed against the policies in the
framework as a whole and that's the test
that we need to apply isn't it yes yes
right and that i'll wait there and then
i'll have a couple more points when we
come back so yeah okay
so i'll keep these open keep that one
though right that's fine you you you
you've taken councillor shaw to the
point that you want to yeah
explore perhaps with a couple more
questions so but yes
let's let's break there so could i just
raise one thing before you you say
something sir and i'm not i appreciate
members of the public aren't aware of
protocol um when i was in the ladies
before and i'm not take counselor dealt
with it admirably because she just
didn't say anything really in response
so in no way
complaining about anything particularly
and i do appreciate members of the
public don't know the protocols but one
of somebody approached council ashore
and spoke to her in the ladies now
just it's just perhaps maybe a reminder
of what the protocols are so that that
doesn't happen again and i've got no
problems with what's happened but um
it's just a reminder for people if i may
obviously i
excuse me sir can i rebut that please um
the residents are just concerned over
our council who suffers from health
conditions so we were just being it
wasn't me but we were just being careful
yes i understand both points of view i
mean the
the point is in terms of protocol as
i've said a couple of times when a
witness is under cross-examination
it's nice to get it all completed in one
section so so they don't have to have a
break and have lunch on their own and be
in isolation but when that does happen
it's important that that
witness doesn't have contact with other
people particularly their team um but
but any individuals because what happens
when the witness is on the witness stand
is i'm hearing their evidence i'm not
hearing things whispered into their ears
by other people
so
i i don't need to label the point i
think everyone's heard what i've said
now but please if if a member of the
public feels that you want to say
something to one of the the counselors
then that's fine as long as they're not
in the middle of cross-examination okay
so let's um
thank you because he i don't have to
talk to him for this length of the time
so there is some benefits well for my
husband there is yes
well uh we we're getting close to 20
past um
well just past quarter past i don't want
to cut it down too much but equally i
don't have too long a break can we go to
can we go to 10 past two then that's
about 50 minutes for everyone
we've got two rifle bids they've got ten
person two mr parkinson
um
i i i really don't mind i'll go with
whatever we just go let's let's go for
10 pass i don't want to
cut it down too much so i'll adjourn now
we'll resume at ten past two thank you
thank you
okay
yeah
right
the council's barrister wants to get out
sick
well the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen
miss reed just before i ask you to do
your final points
as i left the inquiry room
ms crosby who was one of the
interested persons down to speak on the
first day
asked me a question
she said she didn't want to speak on the
first day and she still doesn't want to
speak but she'd like to submit her
statement as a written representation
which i said was fine but i would like
to have it before the appellant gives
evidence so that if it raises any points
that you need to cover with your
witnesses then you've got it in good
time so thank you sir mr crosby if
you're still around
if you can get that statement to us as
soon as possible that'll be great
thank you so much reed
good afternoon councillor in the
afternoon now but we're nearly there
but we're nearly there at least it's not
good evening no
we're nearly there
so
um where we were just before lunch is we
were looking at i'm just going to take a
tiny step back just to remind ourselves
where we were we were in we were in the
tilted balance and we were looking at
paragraph 11 of the framework
and we had agreed that um
even if um we were in the realms of
residual
cumulative impact being as the council
suggests and severe that needs to be fed
into the tilted balance
and what that means
is that the harm identified
significantly and demonstrably outweighs
the benefits of the scheme when taken as
a whole
yep
now um just want to recap on where we
are following councillor eve's evidence
in respect of the harm that the council
says should be weighed in the planning
balance
so
we have
mitigation that works at all junctions
apart from junction 4
which is
and the council's concern primarily rate
relates to the ashingdon road
arm of that junction although councillor
eaves has some points about cute you
know the overall delays in respect of it
but primarily relating to one arm in
respect to that junction one junction
and the concerns that he expressed in
evidence related to the am peak only so
the amp counter only
and one time segment within the amp so a
15 minute period
so those impacts that he was identifying
that he relied upon to demonstrate what
he said was a severe impact
related to
one junction for a 15-minute period okay
that's where we got to
now in respect of junction 4
we also agreed
that the reason uh sorry that the reason
that those impact and that's that's
before those impacts are before
any
any measures in terms of sustainable
transport trip diversion etc taken into
account which he accepted will have some
impact
on bringing the level of impact down
albeit that hasn't been quantified yes
so that's where we are one junction 15
minute period that's the worst case
it'll come down a bit further you didn't
know how much
now
what we also know
though
is that
the reason that junction improvements
physical junction improvements can't
happen at that junction is because of
the geometry effectively there isn't
it's the railway bridge and the river
so
it is not
possible to mitigate those junction at
sorry that junction by junction
improvements
in the highway
at that location yes
okay
now what we've also agreed in terms of
your evidence is that the appeal site
is that the appeal site needs to come
forward
to meet the critical housing needs of
the district
yeah
we've also agreed that the appeal site
needs to come forward
in order to address affordable housing
needs which you accept a very
significant weight should be given to
we've agreed that the proposal is in
accordance with the development plan
and that significant weight should be
given to the policies of the plan full
weight actually is what you said
and we've also agreed that without the
site coming forward the housing needs
that have been identified both in this
plan
and also in your emerging plan cannot be
met
now i appreciate that when matas came
before the planning committee
the planning committee felt that the
evidential basis was different because
at that point the local authority had
concerns about highway safety
which have now been resolved and you've
had independent consultants come in and
look at that issue for you yeah
it was also the case that the planning
committee had concerns about parking
those have now been resolved and we've
got an obligation that's delivering what
you accept to be a significant benefit
yes
there are also concerns about numerous
other junctions in the vicinity and
again you've had an independent
consultant come in to look at matters on
behalf of the local planning authority
and members and to give you comfort that
mitigation can be provided at those
junctions to mitigate those impacts yes
mrs flexman did that yeah mr flexman did
that that's right so what is left in
terms of the impact that the planning
committee well what what is left in
terms of the impact is a single impact
on a junction
where
for a 15 minute period of the day
in circumstances
where
it is not possible
to carry out improvements to mitigate
those impacts i'm so sorry to interrupt
but this is quite important and there's
two points to pick up first of all
um i don't recall i need to go back for
my notes to double check
i don't recall
things
only a 15 minute period
he didn't say that he did i asked him
certainly he didn't
he didn't say that the 45 minutes
preceding that was acceptable
the table shows a 15-minute period and
it shows the worst 15-minute period and
he was asked questions he he was he was
certainly taken to and asked questions
about the
eight to eight fifteen or whatever
different from what
saying i'm okay with the position 7 15.
the question sir i have the note of it
and i've checked it i said you are only
raising concern in your evidence aren't
you with that 15-minute time segment and
he said yes well i'd have to go back to
my notes and find out exactly what was
said though i i've i've noted your point
there uh mr parkinson that's all i can
say at the minute
the the second point is of course um
council eve's also raised he said it was
his most important point the point about
cues from junction four
blocking back into junction three
so i think that just has to be recalled
as well yep
i certainly recall
councillor is referring to that i
haven't finished my question so if i
could continue with my cross-examination
i'd be most appreciated
um so so sorry counselor sure right so
i'm gonna have to take a step back so at
the time
that the committee
looked at this
matter
there were concerns about highway safety
you've had mr flexman come in
and he's looked at those
and they have been resolved but you now
accept significant benefit in respect to
highway safety
we had
concerns committee had concerns about
parking
there's now an obligation which is
resolved sorry which has resolved those
issues significant benefit parking
committee had concerns about junctions
other junctions other than junction 4 mr
flexman's come in we've looked at that
there's a mitigation scheme an
alternative one proposed
and those issues have now been resolved
in respect of all junctions apart from
junction 4
and what what is left in respect to
junction 4
is an impact that can't be mitigated
with works to the highway you understand
that
so if if we are in a position though
where you accept that the site needs to
come forward to meet the critical
market and affordable housing needs of
the district it needs to come forward
that it needs to come forward in
accordance with the policies of the plan
to which you accord full weight
that harm
in the am peak
to that junction in respect to that
junction
it cannot significantly and demonstrably
outweigh the benefits of the scheme
when considered against the provisions
of the framework taken as a whole
can it and before you answer that i
appreciate different position from the
one that you think the committee
considered different position now i'm
asking you as an affiliate member
of the rtpi
to take into account all the evidence
that you've heard now
all those changes that we've taken into
account
the inevitable impacts at that junction
that have to happen
if this site is going to come forward
which you accept it must to meet your
housing needs going forward though that
impact cannot significantly and
demonstrably outweigh all of those
benefits that we've discussed can it
can i make one point earlier on this
morning i mentioned percy cotty's road
and you said you would address that
hasn't been addressed as yet i
appreciate that that has also got to be
a consideration
that if um the site is going to have an
entrance and exit there
that road cannot cope
there's no way
traffic can go actually come through
there as i said earlier a bicycle can't
even get through there if the
president's parked but
councillor eves
did um under full examination expand on
what his concerns were
i did my concerns between eight and nine
i'm left fortunate enough i don't have
to go out through the weight of her road
in the evening
but other residents i have had evidence
from other residents they do i can't
bring that to the table sir
but um
if there's
if junction 4 can't be improved
and it does back up to junction 3 and
eventually it could go up further
you know if you're going through from uh
through there is a still significant
concern
i'm hearing what you're saying and i've
noted certain points of it but it isn't
actually addressing
the question that was put to you so
i understand
you have remaining concerns that's
that's quite clear and you're explaining
some of them but i i do need you to
just focus on the the questions put to
you and and give a response to that
please let me just i'll go back
counselor i understand that when the
matter came before the committee the
committee had a number of concerns
those have been addressed in respect to
percy cottage road there's no evidence
in your prison evidence counselor eve's
evidence the evidence in chief that has
provided i appreciate you've got a
concern but has detailed the issues in
respect of that but i appreciate the
concern that you've expressed in terms
of it and i'll deal with that with mr
blair
when the mata came before committee
highway safety concerns those have been
resolved you've had someone independent
look at it and now you accept
significant highway safety benefits
concerns about parking
obligation
now resolved you accept significant
benefit different again from the matters
that the committee were thinking were
existing at that particular point
had concerns about various junctions not
just junction 4
had a professional consultant in to
robustly look at this for the local
planning authority to give members the
reassurance that they needed in terms of
those points and those issues other than
junction 4 have now been resolved the
satisfaction of the local planning
authority
what we are left with is it
is an impact at junction 4
an impact at junction 4 that cannot be
mitigated within the confines of the
highway
that was known about prior to the
allocation of the site through the core
strategy
and that you have accepted
in respect of the site that the site
needs to come forward to meet what you
accept our critical housing needs for
your district and the people in it
not least the 232 affordable houses that
will be secured through very robust
obligations in the section 106
obligation
now if the site is going to come forward
those
impacts at junction 4 are going to occur
therefore it cannot be the case that
those impacts that you have identified
now taking into account everything you
know now and the evidence as it exists
now before this inquiry
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of the scheme taken as a
whole
right thank you that's correct so on
that basis what paragraph 11 of the
framework tells us is that this is a
proposal that is in accordance with the
development plan
and applying the tilt of balance
planning permission should be granted
that's right isn't it
so on that basis the evidence of the
local planning authority as we sit here
to now today now
having rigorously assessed all of the
information before it
having rigorously assessed all of the
information before it the evidence is
that planning permission should be
granted isn't it
on that basis
i still have reservations i know and i'm
gonna say with what you've said is yes
but
when we did the application we did not
have any of this information so we had
to go
with the information we were given at
the time
and i believe we made the right decision
as a committee
and i counsellor sure i i have been very
careful and fair
to to put those points and i understand
that that you had concerns and that
those those have now been resolved but
those concerns that you accept have now
been resolved mean that in accordance
with the development plan and the
framework the evidence before the
inquiry now now
is that planning permission should be
granted isn't it
oh no well she's you've just agreed with
me haven't you i didn't say a word now
and then everyone else did i'm
thank you very much i'm very grateful
sir i have no further questions okay
thank you thank you counselor sure just
stay there a moment please
right thank you
well
i had got a number of points that i'd
flagged
on your proof of evidence but you've
obviously
been taken comprehensively through
through this i don't think that there
remains many of the points that i'd flag
that i do need to
ask you
about bear with me while i
i go through them
i think that the main thrust of the
remaining points that i may have had
went to the planning
balance because i wasn't sure
going through your
proof that i'd seen
a full assessment of that and i wasn't
sure
whether a similar full assessment had
taken place at the
committee that considered this proposal
but i i i i in light of the
cross-examination i don't think i need
to
ask you questions it would simply be
repeating matters that have already been
put to you and which you've you've
clearly answered so
i don't have any questions for you
council shaw um mr parkinson do you have
any points in re-examination
um so no i'm i don't have any questions
that fall within the category of
clarification so okay
anything else okay okay that's good
thank you
in that case thank you very much
councillor shaw you may retake your seat
and uh i believe that concludes the
evidence for the local planning
authority thank you for giving me the
time to speak okay thank you so can we
just have
five minutes just to rearrange papers
while the rule six party's set up yeah i
was going to say we'll we'll we'll need
perhaps about a 15-minute break really
display boards etc
um
it's 14.28 let's uh resume at 14.45
so i'll adjourn now we'll resume 14.45
thank you
um
right
the
inquiries resumed then ladies and
gentlemen
excuse me
[Music]
so mr foster um
i received the statement that you'd
submitted
back in december but then at the start
of the inquiry you presented me with uh
a slightly revised version i've said you
you've added a few things and taken a
few things out correct
i haven't had time
to go through it in detail to see where
the changes are so i've still got your
original one with various flags on which
it may be that if you if you've left
something out i may not need to ask you
about it but just so you know that
that's how i'll be working so i'm happy
for you to go okay with the new one okay
it would be helpful um if it's
a key point that's new that you
highlight the fact that it is new and
then we can all follow that quite
clearly okay
um the major change between the two was
i misread one of the diagrams and i
put the lane in the wrong place in my
description
okay
primarily you're going to be working
from the one that you submitted on the
opening day yes right okay thank you and
also you recall my original one was back
in november
and then there was a supplementary one
that was submitted on the
23rd of december i think
um
i'm not saying it wasn't i do remember
that you put things in late i can't
remember a statement coming in
later i remember
some um
last minute photos and things came
through but i can't remember a version
of the statement
one was headed housing shortfall and
some evidence attached uh an appeal in
uh
i i i may not have a copy of that in
front of me then uh mr foster i don't if
you've got a spare
definitely went to mr wordsworth on i
think the 23rd certainly before the
closing date yeah i i i'm certainly not
questioning that it's simply whether or
not i printed it out and now have it in
front of me and i say it's not it's not
something that i can recall when i went
through the bundle
would it be misread of you i asked for
it to be sent i could probably get
somebody to email it if necessary
yes i mean ideally if it could be
printed out
sometime
while you're still giving your excuse me
can i trick miss reed did you receive
this yes you've got it yeah
uh mr parkinson have you
you've got it so i'm the odd one out
here i think
no it's got my writing all over it
if if someone's got one that could be
copied then that would be
very helpful thank you
[Applause]
uh
no that's my original one
this one's headed up um housing short
form
when did you send it through
23rd of december i believe
it was certainly before the cut-off date
for evidence
yeah
you've got it yeah
the appellant's got it so
is it possible that your copy can be
photocopied
it all depends
yeah
and it's the back end of my presentation
so yeah it's towards the end
let's try it that way and see if that
works
then when you're
probably there mr foster i presume i
don't need to reintroduce myself having
done it in the week happy for you to
to crack on as it were okay um just to
make clear i'm obviously representing
the residents
i'm not going to be talking much about
theoretical data i'm going to be talking
about pictorial evidence and and my own
experiences
um
a couple of points before we start i
just um
to remind that we agreed i could show a
video later on about halfway through i
believe yep
um
and the other thing just sorry just
pause there because miss reed's just
razor thank you
i'm so sorry to interrupt and when when
the video's shown just before it is
would it be possible if we just because
i i'm not going to be able to see it
from the circle so when it's going to be
shown
if it's possible just for our team to
just move our chairs over so yeah
certainly
i'll i'll watch it obliquely i think i i
have seen it on the on my
pc beforehand but yes would
give us an enough warning for people to
move move scenes and probably take a
couple of minutes to get going so that'd
be fine
um
the other thing just to mention for the
record the
pictures on the easels and the maps are
all
in your evidence packs are provided in
large versions earlier in the week so
you can see them clearly yep
and just a further a couple of minor
points
on the map
um the junction map
though that was put together before
other evidence came so the numbers on
there are different from the numbers
have been quoted for example
what's described as junction four i
think
is junction one on there okay okay yeah
um and finally finally um a couple of
points from this morning
and the leader of the council advised me
that for the last three years rockford
is over delivered on the housing
allocation
and secondly because there was a big
point made say that again just make sure
the leader of the council advised you
that rochford district council has over
delivered on its housing plan in the
last three years over delivered on
housing in the last three years okay the
other point i'd like to make is that
there was uh miss reed made some
significant comments about holt farm
schools
and the s106
application or not application
agreement in related in relation to
those schools
i've got here
dated the 27th of january
and i thought it was too late to submit
it which it was in technical terms but
it's from the head teachers of the two
primary school the primary and the sorry
the infant and junior schools at holt
farm
both objecting to the
development the proposed development in
scr8 i've got copies of that letter here
i think they were not up to date with
some of the
some of the goings on
they hadn't been consulted apparently by
essex and uh
were furious when they found out what
was proposed i've got copies of those
letters here if you wish
let me just hand them over now
yeah i suppose so let's let's do that
and then at least it's before the
inquiry
so
miss reed will have the opportunity to
put questions if she needs to
you can you content with that misread uh
i prefer to see them sir if that's
possible before they're handed in but in
principle won't be objecting to
third-party correspondence coming in but
um is can i just check whether there's
going to be anything else though because
is that the sum total of additional
documents that you're expecting to yes
sir yeah okay thank you
right so i'll begin if i may
okay
right first i'm going to go through some
background you've seen all this but i
must go through it and be able to
emphasize some points of course
others you know either watching on the
live stream uh or attending today won't
know what you're saying so okay
right so first of all some background
the proposed development
is on land allocated in the local
development framework core strategy
adopted version december 2011 and the
allocations plan
adopted 25th of february 2014
under the policy known as ser 8.
for str8 under the heading of new
infrastructure and services to accompany
residential development it states the
requirement
for local highway capacity and
infrastructure improvements including
contribution to traffic management of
ashland road
[Music]
essex county council
highways as a statutory council team
recommended approval of the application
but will argue that the recommendation
is flawed
and does not fully consider the evidence
including its own earlier highway
assessment
made
not only prior to ser 8 but also the
rochford district council policy scr2
scr2 known locally as a whole road
development relates to some 600 homes
some of which are still under
construction
and close to ser 8.
in the allocations planned for ser 2
mentioned in the first paragraph it also
includes the requirement for local
hiring capacity and infrastructure
improvements and the reason i talk about
that is in the mppf
it talks about cumulative impact of
nearby developments and these are in
fact scr-2 scra are cumulative in a
relatively short
close area
so i'm going to
refer now to the ringway j jacobs essex
county council traffic highways baseline
technical note
dated the 25th of october 2017 which was
attachment one in my evidence
and it's based on data from 2014-2015
and it describes itself in the in the
document has been
prepared to inform the local plan
the reason for reflecting on scr 2 is
that the ringway jacobs assessment does
not look beyond sar 2 and have not been
able to access any similar ringway
jacobs assessment for looking towards se
r8 so it makes sense therefore to assume
that the impact of ser 2 becomes a
baseline for scr8
as i said apart from being common sense
it's also consistent with the mppf
guidance which states that traffic
assessment should consider the
cumulative impact of multiple
developments
within a particular area
sdr2 is still in construction four years
after the ringway
jacobs assessment
so the assessment of the was of the
highways before
uh just during the commencement of
building phase one of ser t2
and before the application of 662 homes
under scr8
attachment two in the evidence
submission depicts a local network
referred to in the next section and for
clarity then large version is here i'm
gonna ask mrs austin to just point to
the johnsons that i'll highlight
all right the ringway jacobs report
states high levels of congestion are
observed on all three approaches to the
action and road hall road west street
roundabout which is junction one on the
map
it also describes medium to high levels
of congestion along the majority of
ashington road which is number two on
the map
and also described there being very
little free flow of traffic along the
ashland road
and in attachments 3a and 3b which
you've had for some time
are um
examples of typical days on the ashland
road
these evidences were gathered randomly
there were no
schedules or any particular
events or anything like that people just
out driving and they are not
all one event that is various people at
various times
putting forward that evidence
the retro road junction junction 3
is highly congested
where it appears to stem from the
railway bridge where the road merges
into one lane for both directions
attachment four
and i emphasize that
appears to stem from the railway bridge
it says around hockley town center
junction 4
all the principal local routes are shown
to be congested in all directions
the b1013 spa road south end road mini
roundabout is particularly congested
the report also includes
local development plan engagement with
which also identified nursery corner
hawkwell
junction 5 has been perceived as a
congestion problem
the ringway jacobs
report page 6566 which is what i'm
verbally adding which wasn't in the text
describes canon road to hall road
because just just point to that on the
map please christine
canoeing road is at the top end of
ashington road
so what that's saying is that the whole
length of ashingra road
is a key congestion corridor
and at the top end of ashland road you
can see
there are junctions coming in from the
left and the right which from hull
bridge and canoe
and our sources of
inflow of traffic into
that network
so
the reason i've pointed those things out
at the moment is it become clear as we
go on to talk about ser eight in a
moment okay
okay
um the ringway jacobs and essex county
council assessments were based upon the
table which was submitted with my
original evidence which was table 4.1
congestion description which was page 46
of the ringway jacobs report
and the beginning of this week i also
gave you
copies of that
i should just emphasize
um that the whole road b1013 that i
mentioned the b1013 b1013 hall road is
the main spine between rayleigh
and the settlements of hockley
hawkwell
rochford
and the end of that
is
the hall road roundabout as we describe
it
we will argue that the ringway jacobs
report describing the projected impact
and mitigation of residential
development makes unconvincing comments
on the roads and junctions
in the opening statement in the report
about str2
sorry chris could you just point where
scr2 is on the map it's in the whole
road sections and
the orange section at the bottom
it so says about the whole road the
development poses a significant increase
in peak flows along an already congested
part of the network
it does state that numerous improvements
have been made to mitigate congestion
which have now been implemented
but without further explanation
it adds that despite these improvements
the development is projected to generate
482 two-way trips in the morning peak
and 357 in the afternoon peak
this adds up to a total of 1
678 daily trips
now
i just emphasize it mentions
numerous improvements now what's
actually been improved is
as part of the development there are two
accesses onto the whole road
they've created two new roundabouts
there which allow
an inflow and outflow from the whole
road development they don't contribute
to
the junction end of the whole road
and
as you'll see later they will show that
the
mitigation of the whole road is
actually irrelevant
so i move on so in considering junctions
and for the purpose of this report and
i'm
at this point i focus on the mini
roundabout at the junction of hall road
west street ashton road which has
described his giant from one
it's described as having high levels of
congestion on all approaches
ringway jacobs describes a projected
effect on weak peak delays will be very
high
with up to 125 percent increase
then it's that widening has been
undertaken at this in section at this
intersection
and i just argue that the widening has
an insignificant impact i just like
christine would you point to that
the um hall road junction ones the
pictures of the cars
that's the whole road junction yeah
yes at that point
um
you can see that the whole road narrows
under the railway bridge
to the extent the footpaths are not
viable for pedestrian use which is what
the ringway jacobs report says then it
widened slightly
to the junction
and that widening that slight widening
was the proposed mitigation
for the extra traffic on there now it's
not particularly easy to see but what
that widening was providing a small
left turn lane about one car length long
now as you can see and that is not
contrived evidence that was going there
on a
off chance that one i'd just say if it's
any help i have visited all of the
junctions so
although you know i'm more than happy to
look at your photographs i am familiar
now with the layout of the junctions
okay the point i would make is that um
that one car length of extra width
rarely gets used because you can see
from the the traffic pictures there
cars approaching that junction tend to
straddle both lanes
occasionally there is a second there is
a second vehicle but it's very rare
and that's just
pictorial evidence
and um
you know daily
daily observations
and that was taken at i think
it was three what's the time i said on
it
yeah it's about
oh sorry 3 p.m on the 11th of november
so it's a minor tweak i would describe
it as to mitigate the 125 increase in
peak delays at the junction
um
as i say they were taken at 3pm on the
11th of november we checked the road the
three
arms there were no obstructions this was
just the weight of traffic and the
effect of that junction
and the point is
i haven't seen i've been unable to find
i've requested but i've been unable to
find any evidence that ecc highways has
tested the actual traffic flow
against its definitions in the table
above which i i handed out separately
since the construction of ser 2 started
so i now move on to scr8
[Music]
the ball planning at bloor
planning application for 662 dwellings
shows two access points to the site
the primary access phase one and three
onto the ashland road the secondary
access for phase two is via percy
cottage road
entering or leaving by this secondary
access has two alternative routes one
via ashland road
the second by the rochard town centre
conservation area
so i'll make more of this later but
first i'll focus on the primary exit
so leaving by the primary exit onto the
ashland road southbound
leads to the yashnin road west street
hall road mini junction
roundabout as discussed in the case of
this heavily contested junction it's
obvious that no junction improvements
are possible and that is not contested
anywhere
it's stated
it is the case that at the ashton road
west street hall road junction no
junction improvements could be carried
out and the proposed development would
add to cueing and congestion here
and they're the attachments five
in fact the ardent report is quite
interesting
it shows drawings of all the key
junctions with the current state
and then the proposed state as a result
of mitigations
except for this particular junction
where it just serves the current state
which is actually misleading anyway
it shows two lanes from hall road into
the roundabout as if they were
continuous
in fact the two lanes merge into one one
car length it fails to show the road
narrowing under the railway it doesn't
even show the narrow lane into hall road
and it adds that the highway authority
has considered
not tested not measured has considered
the impact carefully and do not consider
that this
residual impact would be severe
now i'll point out here
if i may say
then on tuesday morning our local mp the
right honorable mark francois
uh reminded us about a meeting he had
with essex county council by
audio link some months ago back end of
2020 i think he said
and um
they actually admitted that they don't
have a definition of severe
and that their
their normal reaction
uh the default reaction is to prove
things they very rarely reject anything
so i'll just and it's sort of laboring a
point i suppose but just further in an
assessment of the
scr-2
it described the junction via
operating theoretical capacity
which would be exacerbated by the
development
sorry i'm just going to pause you there
so just
write in my note tell me again mark
francois mp video meeting with ecc
don't have a definition of severe
default reaction tell me that bit again
sorry you said what their default action
or react their default action yeah is to
approve applications they very rarely
reject any planning applications
even as far back as 2020 an ardent
report um in relation to sal 2 as it
happens
was
damning even then it described it as
operating over development over
theoretical capacity which be has
exacerbated by the impact
the report page 53 6.2 6.62 sorry says
the junction is located in an area with
severe restrictions for improvements to
the layout
the railway over bridge on hall road has
restrictions in both its width and
height
ashington road and west street are
historic roads which also have
restricted widths due to the properties
or the stream on either side
in order to accommodate any significant
further improvements to the junction
it will be necessary to acquire
third-party land and demolish houses on
the ashland road approach
and or widen the existing bridge under
the railway line on the hall road
approach
this would incur an excessive cost which
cannot be borne by this development loan
which should not be expected to overcome
an existing capacity restraint of this
nature
and provide a benefit to the wide area
on its own to be clear this was before
ser 2 and sera and numerous other
developments such as brazilian which
have happened in the period since then
so
we have a junction described as highly
congested
by essex prior to str2
to which congestion is increased by the
development
now ser 8 will add to the queueing on
congestion and this is recognized in the
ardent report
but at no point does it seem to evidence
that essex highways has tested these
increases against its own definition of
severe as illustrated in its own table
the words consider
and considered
do not suggest or imply
that the impact has been assessed
against any definition of severe
nor indeed their own definition that was
in that table
seems to me given that they announced
that they didn't unders didn't have a
definition for severe they seem to have
forgotten the evidence that was in their
report
so leaving the primary access and
heading in the other direction along the
ashland road northbound leads to the
junction with rectory road
number three on the map as we saw
as above rectory road
is described by ringway jacobs as highly
congested
primarily due to the railway bridge
narrowing the road down to a single lane
blind corner controlled by traffic
lights and there are some pictures that
an attachment for
a couple of pictures showing the the
junction the blind turn and so on
it's a bit and it says to be clear
doesn't say to be clear sorry sir it is
clear that there is no mitigation
possible here like the whole hall road
bridge it would quite a massive
investment to rebuild a railway bridge
and widen the road
so that
narrowing to a single lane is described
as the source of congestion
for the
rectory road
ashland road roundabout
at the time of the
ringway jacobs pcc assessment the mini
roundabout at the junction had two exit
lanes in chattanooga road
one left turn and one right turn
and that's been mentioned before i think
by councillor eaves
due to the proximity of the nearby
pelican crossing in rectory road which
is heavily used by pedestrians and
cyclists the two lanes are very short
the distance between the pelican and the
junction is probably two carlings
and like cashing the road actually uh
sorry like hall road where the two lanes
were quite narrow they were often
straddled by cars so they created one
lane but
ultimately
essex
subsequent to the ringway jacobs report
modified the junction to reduce the two
lanes down to a single lane for what are
understood to be safety reasons now i
know that was challenged
uh when
council eve said it yesterday
i live
probably about 300 yards away from there
just around the corner when that change
was made they were boards up explaining
why it was happening
for safety and and then unfortunately i
didn't realize at that point that i
would be here today some years on
otherwise i would have taken some
photographs to provide the proof i
haven't been able to find any proof
subsequently sir but i do assure you
that that did happen
so it's reduced from two lanes down to a
single line laying for what
understood to be safety reasons
excuse me so
the application simply reverts that part
of the junction to the way it was that
it was at the time
sorry assessment so
question really has safety become
irrelevant
so the application also proposed adding
a left turn lane at this junction
northbound
it would appear this would cause
narrowing of the paths
um but i'll say based on something i'm
going to talk about now i would suggest
that changes are irrelevant
the drawing from this extra lane shown
in the original attachment 7a from the
ardent traffic and that's the
left-hand picture at the top
now the other one chris please
for the minute
okay that hardened the left-hand one
that's it that was the ardent picture of
that uh junction
uh what it failed to do
uh will show the shops that the turn
into manstead gardens which is immediate
to the north of the proposed extra lane
you can point that out on
on yeah on on the collarbone manchester
gardens there
come in sorry go up a bit
right go across to ashland road that
that road across that's manchester
gardens
okay
um
so this right or left turn into manstead
gardens is a regular point of congestion
in both directions due to the shops car
park car wash and photographs are
attached there which show people waiting
to get in get out block the road ashland
road and that's at the
the manstead gardens turning and that's
a frequent occurrence any time of day
in the original submission oh sorry in
the evening rush northbound traffic
turning into rectory road is delayed by
pedestrian and cycle use of the pelican
crossing in rectory road close to the
junction
these delays spill into ashland road
causing delays there northbound now
adding a short narrow left turn lane in
ashland road is a minor adjustment and
has insufficient length to
resolve that problem
there is also a well used pelican
crossing just to the south of the
rectory road action road junction
which always delays traffic or sorry
also delays traffic in both directions
in short
the revisions to the mini roundabout
at this junction actually had nothing to
highway capacity not improving traffic
flow because that junction isn't the
problem
the problem is
the pelican manstead gardens and not
forgetting
the earlier discussion from ringway
jacobs about the source of the delay
being the single lane at the railway
bridge
so i just emphasized that these um
these minor tweaks actually
um
do nothing we've seen that these short
lanes
do nothing these short left turn lanes
do do nothing and um
um i should also mention at this point
when this is in addition to the um
to the
original evidence
i've not mentioned before the sutton
road and berlin roundabout
again it adds a turn lane so it's a
similar discussion
um but
the assessments don't look beyond the
junction if you look at the left turn
lane from the ambulan roundabout it
leads at sutton road
sutton road is a relatively narrow
country lane which leads down from the
ambulan roundabout
around in towards the
eastern side of south end it feeds two
industrial estates
and also leads into as i said the east
of south end
and also
the um
the rochefort district
has a lot of outlying villages and
there's a river that separates them from
rockford itself
so that sutton road exit
uh also is the access route for some of
the villages in the east of the district
so if you see if you go along that that
road in the early morning in the morning
peak it tends to be heavily backed up
worst case all the way from south then
back to the sutton road junction and in
the evening it's quite the reverse
it's just a heavily used road and it's a
very small country lane
as i say the the
traffic assessment as far as i can make
out
makes no um
no
reference or
assessment of the traffic beyond the
actual junctions
the other thing i just mentioned
uh briefly and it was
our mp was
wanted to touch upon it on tuesday but
sort of didn't have the time is if you
look at our
roads and those of you that got here
from out of town
mostly driven i assume not on public
transport
would have spotted that roads are a mess
around this area
um
so roadworks
necessary roadworks are a frequent
problem
um we are a resident and i haven't got
the actual factual evidence here right
this minute but kind of quiet if
necessary
um
made a freedom of information request
uh to cover the period july 19th through
to october 2020
and he came up with a 130 road works
in the
the
ashton road hall road
southland road sutton road bradley way
so roughly
uh an average of two road works per week
throughout that period and that's
continued since
anybody who travels these roads every
day
knows that they're a mess
and we moan because the road works come
along and slow us down even more but
they're necessary to try and begin to
sort out the mess
i um
so i talked about the primary access
uh
i've not yet talked about the
the other junction national road which
is a roach avenue daley's road
which
incidentally along with many other
basic errors in the arden report they
kept calling it uh bailey's road and
i've if if it would help i could
probably list
the nine or ten errors i identified just
factual errors in the arden report but
i won't dwell on that at the moment
so this junction
is a few hundred yards north of the
troublesome action and road west street
hall road junction
now
the suggestion is adding extra lanes to
each leg of the daily drive junction by
adjusting road markings or road widening
but that
doesn't have any impact on the
hashington road west street or road
junction
there are pictures in the in the
evidence pack of traffic backed up from
horror road past the daley's road
junction back up to the ashland road
so
the argument is that um
that actually
does
nothing to address the through-going
problem
um
i would say that the left turn does
provide an escape route from the ashland
road of course
um a left turn but what that does is
lead you into the rockford town center
conservation area which would be a
negative consequence
and i'll come back to that in a moment
in relation to the um
uh the high court judgment which uh miss
reed mentioned this morning
i'd like to pause now if i may sir to
have the um
the video kit clip okay so do you want
to
just
tread water as it were for a few moments
while
the
appellant's team
moves
so i think
i think my oblique view will still be
okay here
i did you're right
remind me how long it is five six
minutes five minutes yeah
all right
and
we'll stop it at five minutes if
necessary yeah
just point out just before we press the
start button
um
at the time we
commissioned this time lapse video
um it was a rebuttal to
what we thought was a time lapse perhaps
video submitted by the appellant
it turned out that the appellant had
actually submitted still photographs
from a video so we provided stills as
well which i think we've
presented you in the meantime yeah
stills
from the time
yvonne if you'd start it and stop it
after five minutes
okay
what what is this duration it'll tell
you at the bottom won't is it right this
is um
in the morning
no sorry i meant the oh it's just with
mr foster saying stop it at five minutes
if if it's only a bit yeah let the whole
lot of that yeah okay
yes
so these are um
time-lapse shots from along the ashton
road at various points through the day
and um i'll explain the reason why we're
showing it despite the appellant only
having stills
okay
you
you
you
nice
okay
up to here was ashington road now this
is the um
rectory road ashland road roundabout in
the shops i refer to in the map
foreign
this
thank you so that's it
a couple of minutes to get back into
position yeah thank you
that was
a couple weeks ago i swear
okay right thank you sir
um so
apart from
what one might describe as an obvious
purpose in showing that
first of all for the sake of honesty and
clarity i should say that at about three
quarters of a mile a half mile three
quarter miles down the road
with some road works that started about
11 p.m that morning
11 00 sorry 11 am
okay so the queuing that you saw at the
start of that was way before the start
of any road works
now
apart from the obvious reason i wanted
to i've shared some stills with you
which you had earlier in the week
um i stand corrected on the road work so
a pavement works actually pavement david
yes yeah
but knocking on to road uh
effect now the reason i've given the
stills from that uh time lapse is
we've been a bit puzzled by some of the
evidence we've seen submitted in things
like the ardent report
and what we tried to demonstrate was
though that was a busy road as shown by
the time lapse
it's not that difficult to take a
photograph of points where there are
gaps in the traffic and apparently
there's a little going on
and the original traffic submission from
arden it looks like a little country
lane where there's never any cars going
down and it couldn't be further from the
truth
apart from the fact that wrongly named
it they also took a couple of pictures
of the wrong place
right so i'll go back now to what i was
saying before
right the um
i was talking about the extra lanes uh
providing an escape from the congestion
by the rochard town centre
so going on looking at the access for
the homes proposed in phase two of the
development is via percy cottage road
now actually there are two essentially
two alternative routes on leaving via
percy cottis
you go to ashington road by greenway and
somerset avenue or or to dalys road via
greenway somerset avenue and the drive
there is also a road called rochford
garden way which forms a loop around
percy cottage providing alternatives for
part of both routes but they all lead to
outlets either towards the conservation
area or to washington road
percy cottage road and all of these
roads are narrow and they're
characterized by high levels of
on-street parking with little off street
opportunity
sharp blind bends
blind bends and corners and in
attachment 9
there are some pictures that show the
that the environs the environs of
percicotis
and one of them it's the one that's got
an arrow pointing down on it
is actually the proposed secondary
access you can see there at the moment
there's a white van parked in there and
a couple of others
yeah
and those the people who park there they
don't have any off street parking
capability and they're rather angry
about what might happen if that becomes
the access to
a new development
so
again
one of the exit exits leads to the um
the conservation area and again i'll
come back to that later in the high
court judgment
um one of the things that's
really not mentioned in the ardent
assessment and perhaps most importantly
from height from
the perspective of that area is the fact
that the entrance to waterman's primary
school is nearby
so extra traffic combined with the
existing levels of on-street parking
could well present a safety hazard for
children walking to school
so
finally on the percy cottage road issue
um the ardent assessment page 38
and i think that's in the pack as well
stated that in addition to the primary
site access design
all other accesses have been subject to
an independent stage one road safety
assessment
it goes on to say again
no significant issues have been raised
as a part of this audit
it then refers
to the stage one
road safety audit in appendix g
where it says
and it's attachment 10 in the pack
it says the raid the road safety audit
stage one
actually identifies three risks
associated with the persicotis access
to crash risks
and one pedestrian risk
that is not
no safety issues being raised or no
significant issues being raised now it's
fair to say
there is a proposal for some mitigation
there which is basically widening the
footpath
on that
current dead end of purchase costa's
road and
increasing display for visibility but
the issue isn't with just that it's that
whole area and the increase in traffic
the other thing that was identified was
hedgerow's overgrowth and the answer
would be to cut that back but if it
grows it grows again and grows again
a further issue barely mentioned in any
analysis is the incremental impact of
construction traffic
um
whilst the entrance to
i missed a point out by the way that
that stage one's a road safety audit it
was a
office based audit during june 2019
based on a site visit
of just over one hour duration
so a further issue barely mentioned in
any analysis is the incremental impact
of construction traffic
whilst against the entrance to the uh
construction site is shown as via braze
lane
the only access to braze lane is via
ashton road
apologist
because of railway bridges in hambro
hill rayleigh greensword lane hockley
hall road rochford and rectory road
rochford the routes to ashington road
are either from the a127 through to
warner's bridge south end road and to
the hall road west street ashton road
junction
all described as heavily congested
i should have added that um i i the
information i've had on at least two of
those bridges the hall road and rectory
road is even though it's an underbridge
road
there's a 7.5 ton weight limit on those
and a 4.1 meter height limit
so go back
so access from the 127 through to
warner's bridge
a127 is pretty much rammed during much
of the day
warner's bridge south in road and to
hall road west street ashland road
the other alternative avoiding bridges
is from the
a1235 which is to the west of the rocha
district
via a road called roarth lane through
the village of holbridge
down a narrow country lane called lower
road where it's difficult for even two
cars to pass in opposite directions
just as a as a a by note on this really
there's an attachment
in the context of
law it would seem they've got a very
poor reputation in relation to
construction traffic there was a big
newspaper article
hugely critical
of law about construction traffic
traffic servicing a large development in
stratford-upon-avon
i missed the points there i feel made
just going back to the
road safety audit
it says in the audit the report has been
compiled only with regards to the safety
safety implications of road users of the
layout presented in supply drawings
it's not been examined or verified for
compliance with any other standards or
criteria
right i'd now like to move on to refer
to the rocha town center conservation
area
in the above comments i made about
routes out of percy cottage road and
daley's road junctions i explained that
both of these could draw traffic through
the rochard town centre
this would be unacceptable
there is evidence to support this
attachment 12
i've
supplied extracts from the
2012 high court judgment
case number c o
605 2012
which was heard on the 30th of may
1st of june
in
2012. the claimant in this case was
cogent land and the defendant was
rockford district council
the claimant's application was for an
incl for the inclusion of an area known
as coombs farm
to be included in the local allocations
plan for housing development
this
coombs farm is on a road called
stanbridge road which feeds into the
rochardtown centre conservation area
rodsford district council successfully
defended the appeal the claimant's
application was refused
one of the reasons
was a potential traffic impact on the
conservation area
though coombs farm is slightly further
east than the proposed law development
in the judgment handed down on the 21st
of september 2012
there are two points which i believe to
be significant in the context of the law
application
the transcript states
rochford ashington slash hashington in
theory
has reasonable good transport links to
south end of the a127 but in practice
the area is heavily congested with
congestion on ashington road being
amongst the worst in the district
it also states
when referring to the reasons offered
for not including kum's farm on the plan
it would generate traffic on local web
networks for non-local reasons i.e
traffic to south end would likely be
directed through the center of rockford
including through the conservation area
the judge accepted that argument
against that land being put in the local
plan and as i said the
secondary axis from the proposed law
development would
lead through the conservation area or
onto the ice action road directly
even if it
took traffic through the already crowded
con
conservation area the exit from that
goes down to bradley way where it picks
up the traffic that's passed from the
hall road junction through to the
amberlynn junction
headline night night to move on to
alternative routes to avoid congestion
whilst ardent floor and essex highways
argue the impact of the development on
road traffic is not severe
the ardent report suggests that
increased levels of congestion on the
network due to increased traffic demand
will likely lead to some existing and
new drivers re-timing their journeys to
avoid peak times of congestion
also adding that some
drivers are likely to take alternative
routes if available to avoid congestion
as we saw earlier on
through the map
all of those alternative routes for
anybody moving down the ashland road go
to one of those junctions that are
variously described as congested or
heavily congested
in all directions
so it would appear
that drivers
or there's an opinion shall we say that
drivers will be taking actions to avoid
allegedly non-severe congestion
by taking highly or very congested
alternatives
longer routes
burning more fuel creating more
pollution
to avoid congestion
to move into congestion
so it seems to me
thinking also about people changing
their
travel times and so on people are
from local knowledge people do that when
they can
people are driven by the need to be at
work by a certain time to drop the kids
off a certain time
and um
you know that's that's the lives they
live and effectively i think what this
is asking is
is asking people to change their lives
to fund bloor's profit
why should they
um in fact
i wonder whether mr flexman would be
able to give evidence and we could
cross-examine him because it appears
that he seems to have prepared evidence
for the uh the appellant rather than the
rather than the defendant in this but um
so
elsewhere in the ardent report page 70
paragraph 6.35 it describes the rkd or
arcadia now it's pronounced software
being used to assess capacity for
standard and mini roundabout junctions
in the network
it makes the following statements which
were in the attachment 10.
and i'm going to go through them page 71
6.42 says
the tables reflect maximum ratio of flow
capacity for junctions then goes on to
say
the software is not well suited to model
the impact of additional traffic on
approaches already operating close to or
above the theoretical capacity
tending to exaggerate results in
increasing cue length they wouldn't want
to hear that would they
i.e the model becomes unstable
on pages 77-78 discussing the results
in point 6.66
it states the junction is predicted to
operate over theoretical capacity with
2029 base flows and so the model is
unstable with queuing and delays rising
exponentially i.e q lengths are
exaggerated wouldn't like that either
would they
in 6.67 it states
the addition of development traffic will
add delay and curing at the junction
however not to the extent predicted by
the model since this is unstable
as such the results should be treated
with caution
these comments are related to the ashton
road hall road west street junction
which i mentioned earlier in this paper
read the report to the development
committee on the 24th of june 2021
on page 79 of the rkd results 0.6.73 in
relation to the south end sutton road
junction it states that
the south end road north approach is
predicted to operate over theoretical
capacity in the morning peak hour with
2029 base flow
so again the model is unstable with
queuing and delay rising exponentially
in 6.74 it states also the addition of
development traffic adds to delay and
queuing however
not to the extent predicted by the model
since this is unstable and as such above
results should be treated with caution
so
i'm not an expert but i think i'm quite
logical
i would say in raising this point is it
not reasonable to offer the view that it
would appear that the appellant
concludes
if you use algorithms and software tools
for modeling and they give answers i
don't see your argument ignore them
i would now like to move on to the essex
county council corporate response
which was attachment 13.
essex county council made what's called
a corporate response it described as a
corporate response representing the view
of all areas of essex county council
responsibility
not just those of the statutory council
t essex highways
of 20 pages just seven were related to
highways and transportation
extracts from the report not technical
highways assessment are as follows
referring to highway changes in ashland
road
to accommodate the primary access to the
development it states
excuse me
the additional lane on the highway
the right turn lane outside the schools
would necessitate a diminution
diminution of the segregated footpath
and cycle lane outside the halt farm
infant school
and this is a cause for concern from
both an education and a public health
perspective
it goes on to say the applicant proposes
that at this point outside the school
the segregated cycle lane also becomes a
shared space before continuing again to
the north and south of the school either
segregated or shared
in actual fact the segregated cycle lane
is a misnomer anyway
it is what was formerly just a footpath
now with the white line painted up the
middle and dangerous in that with
hundreds of school children and parents
walking the
path
pedestrians have been have clipped
excuse me been clipped by cyclists
the shared space resulting from the
widening of the carriageway is in fact
the footpath side of the aforementioned
so-called segregated space
and according to officers
cyclists will be expected to dismount
and walk the length of the shared space
in fact i would argue that the whole
length of the so-called segregated cycle
lane is not segregated at all
the essex report goes on to say quoting
the department for transport gear change
policy
it goes on to reinforce that cyclists
must be treated as vehicles and not as
pedestrians
and the imperative is to avoid conflicts
between users
brackets this is reiterated in the nppf
it therefore recommends that users are
physically separated on urban streets
and shared spaces should be avoided
it then goes on to add
it's very important that the route is
safe and inclusive for all
now some of the pictures that
we updated with the redactions this
morning
um showed
a couple of pictures
[Applause]
and there are others in the evidence
showing the narrowness of the road but
it's quite interesting to see
the pictures i showed you
were of
two cyclists and three ladies now
i heard
a comment from somebody
um apparently on the appellant side but
i can't confirm that
that all it demonstrated was that it's
not very busy
well actually this was during the uh
school christmas break
uh when the um
the rush of children and adults up the
road was obviously not president
but what we saw at first was um
the van lorry
parked on the footpath
which is in your evidence pack
and the reason we parked on the footpath
was i actually and i challenged the
driver
why um why you parked on the footpath
and he said it's because we cause him
mayhem in the ashland road
then unfortunately i wasn't able to get
the camera out quickly enough um the
ladies in the with the push chair
the three ladies with a push chair
pushing a child
um had to obviously go around that van
to stay on the on the footpath but then
you can see in the pictures that the
three of them
between them are straddling the cycling
lane
and then you can see the picture of two
cyclists
uh one on each side of the white line
which allegedly segregates the cycle
lane from the
footpath
you can also see on that picture of the
two cyclists as i say though it was
during the afternoon
and it was during the school holidays in
the background you can see washington
road is quite rammed and heavy with
traffic
that was not in a peak period
that's right
so the um
the essex report goes on to say it's as
i mentioned it's very important that the
route is safe and inclusive for all
so we have a situation that the existing
cyclone pedestrian route is not
compliant with mppf recommendation that
users should be physically separated on
urban streets but also due to the
increased traffic and road widening
including in the
proposal sorry
even the path
cycleway separated by only a white line
is removed and becomes a footpath that
requires cyclists to walk
further the ecc report goes on to say
the applicant appears to prioritize
securing a means of vehicular access
into the site
over the potential impact on hot farm
junior and infant schools
through a reduction in the segregated
footpath and cycle lane which we do not
support
and i refer back to the letters from the
school
that i handed out earlier
this point i'm adding three
unsolicited comments picked up from
residents in the course of this week
that's this week been the time i wrote
the evidence
they reflect commonly held concerns
about the danger of narrow footpaths in
so-called cycle lanes in sections of
ashland road
particularly in the vicinity of the halt
farm schools
one said i've just driven along there
and a little girl just ran into the road
to get past people on the path
luckily i was going slowly but it scared
me
i put i must add i've personally
witnessed that kind of situation outside
the whole farm school
second one the cyclist said i try to
avoid cycling the ashland road because
the cycle lanes are dangerous for
pedestrians
this person reported along the
pedestrians sorry the third this person
reported walk along the pedestrian side
of the white line in the path being
narrowly missed by cyclists the point to
be made is that the footpaths are
already narrow and dangerous for the
literally hundreds of children and
parents that walk these paths shared
spaces to and from school each day
the ecc report
goes on
to discuss
noise and air quality
suggesting that the rdc should need to
be confident that proposals would not
have a detrimental impact on the
vicinity of the halt farm schools
i would add to this that the other
schools including saint teresa's rocha
primary and the rocha day nursery
on the day of this
writing of this report
11th of november 2021 i went out around
the district between 2 30 and 3 30
taking photographs
some of which
are attached with the note
by the day nursery situated at the
junction of ashland road hall road west
street the traffic was chaotic and
that's one of the pictures or two of the
pictures up there
the air was fume filled from vehicle
exhaust my personal experience
the children's play area for the
nursery
uh
has a metal fence railing construct
which is approximately 12 feet from the
edge of the road and you can see on one
of the pictures in the attachment
there's a lorry just uh quite close to
it
and i say this is a stark reminder i'm
not you know that a lot of people have
brought this point to me
it's a reminder of the case in south
london last year when the death of a
young girl
was attributed
by the coroner to exhaust viewing
pollution
and as i said photographs
in attention 5
on the
show the proximity
in response to the statement of common
ground
which
never came to fruition but we offered
a statement as follows
an air quality assessment has not been
carried out in the area of hall road
ashland road west street junction and
particularly at the preschool at this
junction i suggested that as an
agreement as a statement of common
ground and it was ignored
well the response it wasn't quite
ignored they said the response was that
the appeal site does not lie within
or close to a designated air quality
management area aqma
the nearest being rayleigh some 10
kilometers away
this doesn't mean there's not an air
quality problem it means it's not being
tested
you may have seen yellow ribbons
attached to the safety barrier outside
the hot farm school this bag is a small
handful of
sorry
we have a bag here sorry we couldn't
submit it because it's a bag
a small handful
of those ribbons which were removed from
the barrier last week
as an experiment
we soak them in boiling water and um
this is the result
we can leave this behind if you wish
what you can see is the bottom is is tar
that's formed and if you shake it up
that's extracted from the ribbons by the
ashland road
that's what our kids are breathing
apparently there's a discussion going on
in parliament today about a child who
died as a result of road fumes
i'd just like to add
a comment from the
october 2020 air quality assessment
which was i think
ardent
yes it was arden
it says
schools and children's playgrounds are
considered to be sensitive locations for
comparison with annual mean objectives
due to the increased sensitivity of
young people to the effects of pollution
regardless of whether or not their
exposure to pollution could be over an
annual period
and i just point out that those
rails at the top of those
barriers
are about head-eye for
primary school kids walking along
on the subject of public health and
well-being the ecc report highlights a
number of issues and concludes until
these issues are assessed and mitigation
measured agreed to address any negative
impacts they identified the application
cannot be supported by ecc in respects
of local authority for education and
public health
on education contributions the ecc
reports that if rdc were minded to turn
down the application we'd be grateful if
the lack of education provision in the
area can be noted as an additional
reason for refusal now i'm sure that
the applicant will
claim ss106 would address that but i
remind
remind sir that
the schools have actually opposed this
so
none of the above
sorry i think i missed a bit
sorry right none of the above issues and
objections from the non-statutory
consulting areas of
essex county council were included in
the report to the development committee
meeting the 26th of november november
2020.
the one item the footpath became a
shared space for it becoming a shared
space for a distance was noticed by a
councillor and explained away by the
officer with the answer that cyclists
would have to get off their bikes and
walk
and unfortunately none of these
non-statutory ecc issues were included
in their motion to defer
and consequently not included in the
discussion to consider and then reject
the application
so we have a situation
where the report provided to the
development committee on the 26th of
november did not include non-statutory
consulting objections
of the essex county council report
but did accept the statutory consulting
element essex highways
as i said the rdc report to the
development committee showed no evidence
that it tested essex highway's not
severe conclusion
because it's ultimately the local
planning authority is responsible to
satisfy itself of severity
in this matter i referred to the answer
which was attachment 14
by brandon lewis mp on behalf of the
department for communities
and local government on the 17th of
november 2014
in response to a question in the house
of commons it states
it's for the local planning authority in
considering planning applications
or the planning inspector in considering
planning appeals
to consider whether improvements can be
undertaken within the transport network
that cost effectively limit the
significant impact of the development on
traffic levels
and determine whether the residual
cumulative impacts of the development
are severe
and as i said i see no evidence
i've seen no evidence i've searched for
evidence i've asked questions i've seen
no evidence
that either the highways authority
or
the planning authority
tested
the
traffic impact
against the
a definition of severity and the only
definition of severity that i've been
able to find
is the one that i shared with you which
was in the ringway jacobs assessment
and the next level above the
congested that they describe in many all
the junctions next level above is
severe
i don't believe seville was ever tested
so now i'm just before moving on to
conclusions i want to mention some
additional evidence that i submitted on
the 23rd of december
[Applause]
so is this your housing bit which i'm
haven't yet had passed to me yes it is
right would you like the copies yeah
please yeah
i think everyone else
seemed to say they'd got it but yeah
thank you
just to double check i'm at oh thank you
i was just checking that i've actually
got the same thank you
over there
thank you
yes
it's um
relatively relatively short
yeah no i i i can confirm i have seen it
but i hadn't got a printed copy of it
okay with me but yeah but by all means
carry on right so
excuse me
um i'd like to talk first about housing
shortfall
um in rochefort district
there's been long-running opposition to
the housing numbers imposed upon us by
the east of england and central
government dictat
pursuing this argument in a letter to
the right honourable michael gove mp
dated the 1st of november november 2021
from rogers district council
signed by the leader of the council
the portfolio holder for strategic
planning and the chairman of the
planning policy committee they
challenged the way algorithms are used
to decide how many new dwellings we
should build
they particularly
argued that the algorithms do not work
for rocha district council being a
largely agricultural peninsula bounded
predominantly by water
the response from the ministers state
sorry the letter and the response are
both attached
uh the response from the minister of
state for housing is interesting saying
clearly
that whilst the nppf introduced a method
for identifying housing need it does not
set a target for the number of homes to
be built
in fact the secretary of state we know
as a result of this challenge that was
put
as actually looking at the process of
identifying housing need i don't know
what the timetable is for that but we
know also there is a
review of planning law going on which
seems to be uh
not going very far at the moment
in talking about housing need and i'm
sure i'll be challenged on this and i
can't evidence it but i will say it
nonetheless
one of the
one of the developments quite close to
ashland road is called braze lane which
is where the construction access is
a resident there did a survey and i'd be
happy to try and dig that out if i can
but did a survey that identified that
approximately 75 of the houses in that
development
were bought by local people
that the 25 percent were bought by
people from outside the district
it also identified
that
of the people
that were from the district and bought
houses in brazilian when they moved they
were normally bought by people from
outside the district
and the point is and it's many people
have speculated on it and it's very hard
to prove but it is provable
um
that this housing need
or e housing uh requirement that was
imposed upon us is actually
a mechanism for sucking people into the
area
it's not
totally
uh satisfying the needs of rocha
district people
i'm just going to go on a bit more to
talk about housing numbers included in
the local plan
as i said they're not based not
calculated by local plan but on numbers
imposed but despite that in the state of
common ground
signed by the appellant
and rochford district council
in paragraph 2.6
as a mystery says it identifies a
shortfall of 331
in the housing trajectory for dwellings
based on the imposed numbers up to the
period march 2025
excluding
the applicant's proposed development
however i would argue there are
mitigations on the horizon
they're not yet scheduled for build and
still to go through detailed planning
in table 7 of the statement of common
ground
it identifies
sorry i lost my track there
[Music]
it identifies that shortfall with 331
and um
there are however as i said mitigation
on the horizon they're not scheduled for
bill
and still go through detail planning i
believe offset this
in table seven of the statement of
common ground
uh it notes that an additional 222
houses were granted
outline planning permission to be built
in the development under construction by
countryside homes now in the table
it says here
550 under construction the site has
planning permission for 547
and an application for a further 222
dwellings approved subject to
section 106. that extra 222 were
approved at july
2021
development committee meeting
and
the
section 6
agreement was actually signed last week
and the decision noticed issued
so that's
potential replacement for 221 sorry 222
of the 333
on the second one
coincidentally for 222 homes which
includes i have to admit some
um
care home type accommodation but the
majority not so
um so there's an application for a
retirement village off cherry orchard
way in rochford previously rejected
it was granted on appeal on the 5th of
november 2021
in this case the developer is optimistic
that the reserve matters application
will be determined by the end of june
22.
and aims for completion in that
development in the years 23-24
so
whilst timing is to be determined for
the countryside homes plan
it can reasonably be assumed in my
opinion
to cover the
in total the shortfall described above
this 331
so and honestly i would say it's a
puzzle
um i hate to be um
critical of my
uh ross for district council colleagues
but i do say it's a puzzle that that was
signed off
i would also add in relation to the
statement of common ground that the
windfall numbers are not considered in
those in that um
that projection
trajectory
and the
over the last several years the average
windfall numbers within rochford have
been around about
50 per annum
also as an example on the rochford
development committee
on 9th of december 2021
an application for 29 flats was approved
none of these winfor numbers are
included in the statement of common
ground in the section relating to
housing trajectory
but i'm reasonably confident that those
29 will be delivered in that period
through to 2025.
i would also like to discuss precedent
um it's reported on building site
website
sorry the building trade website and i
have actually
seen a fuller report
from
the department for communities and so on
um it was probably reported in november
2021 the headline says gove turns down
kent housing scheme despite council's
housing land shortfall
and he says despite the local authority
having no five-year supply of land
a key reason in the refusal was that the
plans would severely impact on the local
road network mr gove agreed with the
inspector that the impacts of granting
planning permission
would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
which is a test set out in the nppf
we argue that this test applied to the
law application would equally give
ground for refusal of the appeal
i also attached
in the evidence
that
that late december evidence
several reports of appeals reject on
grounds of severity
of traffic impact
and in some cases
despite shortfall in housing supply
again before moving on to the
conclusions which i'm
almost there i think
i would like to just share a concern
about the local drainage system actually
um in this section
um
talk about on 24th of um
24th february 2021
i wrote to the essex suds team
asking questions about their assessment
of the rainfall on the drainage system
we observe
roads quite regularly flooded we observe
the field where this is proposed to be
built to be heavily flooded
despite the natural drainage there
so i asked some simple questions
um i said
this area of essex is known to be one of
the areas with the lowest rainfall in
this country
having done research
i discovered that at the time over the
previous
at that time over the previous two years
average rainfall had consistently been
significantly higher than the previous
eight years
so i asked two questions of suds
one hence the suds assessment of the
proposed law development included the
recorded levels of rainfall
experienced over the last two years
and the second question was what was the
worst case included in the assessment
in response to question one
after a very long-winded technical
explanation
which i'm reasonably intelligent but
struggled to understand
he said we ask developers to use longer
data sets which is something we can't
ask developers to collect for specific
areas
the response to question two was
on your second point we experts expect
suds
to be designed for up to and including
a one in one 100 year storm event
plus a 40 allowance for climate change
it goes on to say the 40 climate change
allowance is the upper limit set by the
environment agency
so we're therefore taking a conservative
approach
we also ask for half drain times for
storage features with looks at ensuring
there is enough storage capacity for
consecutive storm events
so
as i say i'm reasonably intelligent i
don't think i'm an idiot but i didn't
quite understand the two simple answers
to the two very simple questions
um
in light of the above i'd like to share
a personal experience
many effects photographs shown in the
evidence that's been previously provided
as shown in the past months the impact
of heavy rainfall on roads
and some residence gardens and
importantly on the farmland proposed for
the floor development
it's not unusual for roadways under the
local railway bridges to be impassable
we've submitted pictures there's one
relatively recently
the cars trying to get through under the
rectory road railway bridge
um
can you just confirm that you did get
those pictures
the pictures of the rectory road and so
on yeah thank you
um so i'll share a personal experience
many of the photographs submitted in the
evidence have shown the the impact in
past months and heavy rainfalls on roads
um and so on
said it's not unusual for the roadways
under the bridges to be impossible on
the 20th of october 2021 11 p.m
we received a call from my 94 year old
future mother-in-law lives in hockley
not very far away a couple of miles
her roof was leaking in the torrential
rain
now to get to her involves going by
one of the routes on the maps that we
showed you at the beginning
we set out to get her heading north
along ashland road towards greenswood
lane but could not get through the
flooding at the bottom of washington
hill
turning back we were able to just get
through the flooded road under the
railway bridging rectory road
making our way along retro road to join
main road hawkwell we once
got mods we got to level grounds the
roads were underwater from side to side
we arrived at the railway bridge in
greensword lane to find it impassable
with three vehicles stuck in the deep
flood water
now with no further alternative route
available we turned back to return home
we found rectory road flooded and
impassable at the railway bridge or by
now flooded
we went to hall road to find the
railroad bridge at that junction with
ashland road and west street flooded and
impassable
next a long diversion of several miles
to get to the wallers bridge southend
road roundabout flooded but passable
by going on to the path and grass verge
next chamberlain roundabout flooded but
passable eventually home via ashton road
all roads were flooded current to curb
and many manhole covers lifted and water
flowing out the drains
so
i started this section by asking two
simple questions
about
levels of rainfall that been included
and got these long technical answers
and i wonder if the amount of rainfall
that night would have been classed as a
100 year in event
and particularly whether the mitigation
for the loss of natural drainage
resulting from the pros development
proposed development
could further overload the local
drainage system
anybody that lives around here knows
that that was a bad night but we
experienced bad nights and bad days
quite frequently
so so i will now move on to the
conclusions
the ringway jacobs essex county highways
baseline technical note dated the 24th
of the 10th 2017 stated
the sole purpose of this report is to
provide a baseline assessment of traffic
and transport to inform the development
of the rockford district council local
plan
it describes all of the junctions and a
number of roads in the area affected by
two large housing developments known
under the planning policies scr 2 and
sera
against its definition of traffic flows
it describes the junctions and roads
variously as high levels of congestion
very little free flow of traffic highly
congested congested in all directions a
congestion problem
of all the difficult junctions one in
particular the ashland road hall road
west street junction is described in the
baseline assessment as having high
levels of conjunct congestion
on all three approaches
it also states that widening has been
undertaken at this section
this very minor adjustment is laughable
mitigation for the scr 2 development of
600 dwellings
in the case of scra with the further 662
dwellings off the ashton road the rdc
planning officer reported that the
development committee
made it clear that in relation to the
above mentioned junction no improvements
could be carried out at that junction
and that the proposed development would
add to queuing and congestion
so between
scr-2 and scr-8 adding 1200 plus
dwellings
both feeding this junction
the only mitigation is not for putting
it for fit for purpose
since the 2017 rj ecc assessment there
appears no evidence available to
indicate that the congestion at the
junction and its feeder arms or any
other road or junction has been assessed
by essex highways or rockford district
council
the planning authority
as to whether the cumulative impact
would be to move from the earlier
assessments of high congestion to severe
who knows not assess
as such
one must conclude that the development
fails to deliver local highway capacity
and that infrastructure improvements are
required by policy ser eight
in the course of the interrogation of
councillor shaw
miss reed
made much of the
history of ser 8 being approved
and approved in the knowledge
that there could be no improvements to
the hall road
ashton road west street junction
and um
i think
council shaw was
persuaded to agree that that was the
case
the point i would make is
those responsible for planning when that
plan was put forward
or not now running the council
made a mistake
in approving ser 8
in the knowledge that that junction
could not be improved and it was at the
end of the major spine through the
district of rochford
and fed by three
arms all heavily congested
so i believe
on that alone that the development
committee decision to reject the blood
application to be correct
and that the appeal sir should be
rejected thank you
okay thank you
[Applause]
sorry i'm just double checking because
because i've got a next page there are
you you're content that you're not
giving me those bullet points there um
it was um you just said it was written
i've introduced a historical footnote
earlier on
um
it wasn't the historical footnote it was
the you say be remiss to not reiterate
other issues identified no i've already
covered those you've covered those in
early on yes okay thank you i've got all
that
right thank you mr foster just bear with
me a moment
miss reed have you
got questions that you want to put to mr
foster i forgot one point sir should i
pass these to you to see uh i i'm
content that i can see
from from here thank you
um
so i don't have any questions i'll pick
the points up with my witnesses okay
yeah
did i hear that correctly sir no no no
no questions to you from the uh
appellant repellent advocate miss reed
i have questions okay
no questions from the appellants
advocate she's going to pick up any
relevant points with
her own witnesses
so he's going
points that you've raised she's going to
ask her witnesses to comment on and give
their view on without putting words in
her mouth yes so that's right and just
just to be clear that's because as i
indicated at the beginning in respect of
that i appreciate the israel six party
they have formal status in respect of
the proceedings but in respect of
residents whether they're all six
parties or otherwise my practice unless
i have points of clarification
is to adopt that practice which is
not i don't have any particular
questions and i'll raise them with my
um experts
okay could i ask which experts are going
to be presenting or questioning yeah so
my witnesses which are mr blair
who's dealing with highways matters and
mr pycroft who's dealing with planning
matters i do know so there is just one
point if i may raise it before you do
i do know that
points in respect of air quality have
been
made in the evidence
and we had understood from
correspondence prior to the inquiry
that we didn't need our air quality
expert here because those points weren't
going to be raised not not trying to
stop them being raised clearly the rule
6 party must make the points it wants to
make
um
i suppose that
we have produced a statement on the back
of mr pycroft's evidence
and it's just whether the rule six party
thinks now it's going to have additional
questions it wants to put
because mr pycroft's obviously not the
expert if they do and they've changed
their mind in terms of that then just a
bit of notice so that we can make
arrangements in terms of it
and i think it's probably going to have
to be a virtual arrangement as well
because he's not here i hadn't
anticipated that was going to be the
case i'm not sure that there are any
technical questions in respect of that
evidence
but it was just it was just a point of
clarification really this was raised
prior to the inquiry it wasn't i do
recall and the email was that they
weren't going to do at that point the
royal sixth party didn't talk because
you remember if if you remember sir i
raised at the case management conference
i said that we'd produce a statement the
rule six party would consider whether
they were raising evidence in respect of
rural air quality
and i think that they confirmed that
they weren't i don't think so they're
qualified i'm not sorry i'm not i'm not
taking any issue with them raising it
now to be clear but it's just in terms
of where we're up to and who we've got
here if there are any questions i think
the indication was that
they weren't and there wouldn't be
we've then had an addition to the
evidence which i'm not objecting to they
must raise the points they want to raise
it's just in terms of who i've got here
if they've got additional questions
mr pycroft isn't in a position to answer
technical questions on the statement
that's been served and so if they have
questions and i don't necessarily need
an answer to it this minute if they want
to but
i'm going to have to make arrangements
for that person to be available to
answer them
and it's going to have to be virtual
that they are brought into it at this
point because it was raised previously
and they're not here yeah no that i mean
that's a fair point i think that
summaries summarizes my response which
hopefully found its way to you i i asked
the
i was asked the question i think
um that let's think how i can best
phrase this um i'm aware that um at
an earlier stage in the proceedings when
it appeared although air quality may be
raised
the appellants responded by producing a
statement which is an appendix i can't
remember the number but it's an appendix
to either mr pogross or mr gasket mr
gascoigne's evidence
and then the rule six party said you
decided that you didn't want to submit
the aircraft no bear with us the air
quality
evidence that at one stage you were
going to i fully accept that air quality
is mentioned in your
uh statement and
as you said you you've you've covered
those points now but at one stage you
were going to submit additional air
quality evidence
and
i think it was possibly in response to
that that the appellants had produced a
further statement
my advice because i was asked whether or
not
your parents could reasonably stand down
their air quality witness
and i said no i don't think you can
because it may be that there
the air quality is raised by uh
interested persons at the inquiry and so
i advise that the um the witness still
ought to be made available if necessary
even though that may need to be through
a virtual appearance at the inquiry
so i think all that's being asked now by
miss reed is
were you intending to pursue
with
mr
pycroft is going to be any issues about
air quality because if you are he may
not be able to respond to them and miss
reed would need to ensure that
that witness was available virtually
let me just try and uh answer those
questions sir
um at the case management conference we
were asked whether we were pursuing
environment issues in relation to the
conservation area yes and we said we
were not yep we didn't say we weren't
going to pursue air quality no i think
you did later i'm not talking about the
the case management conference you you
stated at one stage that you want um you
you wanted
ms waite and an environmental
expert to provide additional evidence
and i through the case officer informed
you that we were well past the date for
the submission of what would at that
time be
additional late evidence and the
response i got back was that you had
come to the view that you didn't want to
submit that evidence and didn't want
that environmental expert i do agree sir
that
mrs wake was going to attend and for
various reasons she can't so we withdrew
that
as a she wasn't actually an expert
witness but shall we say
you know in the world of the blind the
one-eyed man is king she's
quite intelligent on these matters but
she couldn't
stay but nonetheless
uh we did raise the air quality around
the areas of the school and the big
junction yes i mean you'd included that
in your your initial statement so i mean
i would expect that we will be asking
questions
on the subject
in cross-examination well
i have no objection to that obviously
i've made that clear and i'm not trying
to curtail the points that are being
made
um
and as i say i don't necessarily need an
answer to that point this minute
and we're obviously going to go into
tomorrow and next week with the inquiry
um could i just request that some
thought overnight is given to whether
there are
questions
that the rule six party or residents
wish to ask
of our air quality expert the statement
is at appendix 3 of the emery proof of
evidence just i'm sure you know that
anyway but just to redirect to you in
respect of it
if there are questions
of him
if we could know tomorrow morning when
some thoughts being given to it and then
we can perhaps timetable in and make
arrangements for that so yeah if i may
suggest
can you do that because obviously we
need to if it's going to be a virtual
appearance then the witness will need to
know when
it's going to be
yes sir i will i expect to be asking
some questions about air quality
part of the reason is we were ignored on
the statement of common ground where we
did put some air quality items in
um they we the first version of the
statement common ground
came from the appellant on i think the
6th of december
we responded on the 8th of december
on the 9th of december mr gascoigne
responded that you don't you don't need
to go through you you did do this in in
your summary of your case so i mean yes
i accept there's a chronology and the
end result was that there isn't an
agreed statement of common ground
between the
uh supporters group and and the
appellants so yeah
can i just say one thing sir there isn't
an agreed statement we were ignored on
the matter from the third of january
onwards
well well
we don't obviously that's the view you
take i mean from my perspective
i haven't got a a statement of common
ground so i mean that's we've ended up
at the same point
i'm not saying that you're not right in
putting forward your your
perspective on that
so can i just clarify because it
again and it's just going back to having
a think about overnight if there are
questions of the air quality expert if
the questions are going to chronology in
terms of the statements of common ground
which frankly a we don't accept but b i
don't think it takes us anywhere anyway
because there isn't one and that's it
but if there's questions about
chronology and those kind of points then
they they can be directed to mr pycroft
if the questions are about air quality
substantive matters in respect of air
quality that need to be asked of the air
quality expert based on the statement
that he has provided that's attached to
the proof of evidence then that's where
we'll need to make arrangements and
that's why i'm just asking
for some cons i don't need to know what
questions are or anything like that but
consideration to be given to that point
overnight because what i don't want to
do is have him here and then the
questions go to things like chronologies
about statements of common ground which
i could quite easily which which mr um
which mr foster can raise with mr
pycroft so
yeah clearly i mean that's a reasonable
point i mean a distinction between
substantive air quality matters and
chronology in terms of abortive attempts
to do a
statement of common ground if it's the
latter it's the pie crust
the chronology is not a discussion point
now yeah we're ignored so fine we will
we will ask questions about air quality
okay okay well it's right
ponder it overnight but certainly i'm
taking at the minute that you're saying
yes you would like to
let
let's come back to that in the morning
okay right well thank you for that
um
so
wind back a bit you've got no
further points to raise with
mr foster
no thank you that's correct yeah okay
well let me i'll i'll go through some of
the points that i got then yeah with you
mr foster please
let me
now some of these may fall away um
as a result of other things that have
been said but obviously i noted these at
the time i first went through your
your statement so just let me
let me go through i think
one of the things
because you've referred to it many times
is this this table table 4.1 with the
congestion description
and you
you've gone i'm looking at your original
report which may well be set out very
similarly to the one that you worked on
here but basically you'd gone through
a number of bullet points prior to
putting that table in when you say
things like the report states high
levels of congestion reported for all
three approaches to the ashland road
hall road west street roundabout
sorry are you are you with me or yeah
yeah
yeah so those bullet points then you've
got medium to high levels of congestion
along washington road
recreates highly congested
what what i want to be clear on is what
time periods are these relating to
because when i looked through
this jacob's report
some of those that you've picked out of
there were specific to one peak period
or another i just want to know how
you've interpreted these um
these
descriptions of congestion and what
you're saying i should take away from
your
evidence when you tell me that
a particular road
congested in all directions i mean is
that in the a.m peak in the morning peak
well in um
in
parts of it
they talk about the
peaks
pm peak similar the am peak
others they don't actually define the
time of day
so it's variable depending
for example if i may just explain the
point it says on the um
it says in the rochford area we observe
medium to high levels of congestion
along the majority of ashland road
retrograde is highly congested it
appears blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah there is no suggestion there
of
what times of day
those comments are based upon sorry
that's from the report that you were
reading that was it ringway jake sorry
bring away jacob's report okay
but um as i say
when i looked through the report to try
and pick out where you'd taken some of
these
um
statements from
it did seem that some of them were
relating to specific periods so i think
it's from my perspective it seemed
reasonable to say well yes that that
that is a reasonable statement but it
has to be taken in the context of what
time period it relates to
okay
may i add so that i mean
big periods from my
relatively novice understanding of these
things they tend to have a pretty fixed
set
period of time
but in ashton road we've got schools
that start at 7 45 yeah
and finish at 2 10
and others that start quarters to 9 and
finish much later yeah i mean they're
fair points i i have picked that out as
as you know i've gone through the
evidence and as the inquiry has
progressed that yes you can't simply say
there's one morning peak and one evening
peak well you may be able to say that
those the actual peaks but there are
other periods in the day when certainly
there are local peaks or whatever
um okay
yes i mean i think
just looking at my own notes there the
the examples the second of those bullet
points the way it says medium to high
levels of congestion
along the majority of ashington road
very little free flow of traffic
the report only refers to that in the pm
peak
and then
no that was the only one there
[Applause]
nothing hinges on this but i'm going to
just say it on your page 3
when you were talking about the
jacobs report
in the context of ser 2
you you've
emboldened um
a quote saying the development is
projected to generate 482 two-way trips
in the am peak
and 3-5-7 in the pm peak i accept that
this isn't the the development before me
but then you want to say this adds up to
a total of 16 78 additional daily trips
and i just want didn't want there to be
any confusion here um
i'm not sure that you're right in saying
that i'm not quite sure how you've got
that
that figure or all the report says
is
482
two-way morning trips or rather two-way
trips in the morning peak and three five
seven in the pm peak so if they're
two-way trips what all that all you can
glean from that is that there are
839 two-way peak hour trips
it doesn't say anything about
additional daily trips it looks to me as
though you've you've
you've added those two together and then
you've doubled them correct
well if
with respect i don't think that's the
correct way to deal with that
information that's in the report
i say i
i'm not saying here that anything hinges
on this but all all it's saying is there
were 482 two-way trips in the morning
peak
and 357 two-way in the evening peak it
doesn't say anything about any other
times of the day
okay
i'm talking about additional trips in
those peaks
and it's two times if i go to the shop
no it's not it's no if i go to the shops
and come back
yeah that's included in when it says 482
two-way trips it doesn't mean
it doesn't mean twice 482 it means
there's 482 two-way trips
that's interpretation sir not sure it
does let's clear it
yeah i'm not going to labor the point so
i said
nothing's going to hinge on that
just on page five just so i'm
clear
what you're telling me here
um it's towards the end of the big uh
middle paragraph
you you say there's also a well-used
pelican crossing just south of the
rectory road actually the road junction
which also delays traffic in both
directions
i think it's actually the bit just
before that you say remind me you said
page yeah sorry page five
um you've got a big
middle paragraph on page five
towards the end of that it's actually
the bit that says in the evening rush
northbound traffic turning left into
rectory road is delayed by pedestrian
and cycle use of the pelican crossing
in rectory road close to the junction
and then you say delays spill into
washington road so have you followed the
bit that i'm at in your report yeah
i i just wanted to be clear what you're
what you're saying there i mean it's
it's clear that pedestrian and cycle use
of
crossings okay
let me explain sir
the
the pedestrian crossing the
pelican crossing is at the end of the
southern the cycle lane leading up to
regular road
and the cyclists and pedestrians use
pelican crossing
it causes a traffic delay there from
traffic turning left out of the ashland
road northbound
okay but that lane is very short yeah
and after two cars
sometimes only one car it starts backing
up down ashton road now i know the
applicant says they're going to pull
with left hand left turn lane there
okay to create a double lane yes but
that is a very short length
and when you when you see the experience
of cars being delayed there
they would still actually fill that up
and still cause delay on ashton road
yes i i i think i follow what you're
saying i'm just trying to to get the
balance here because obviously if
pedestrians and cyclists are wanting to
cross the road then that's an essential
movement i'm just trying to get the
your interpretation of the balance
between priority prioritizing traffic
movements and pedestrian and cycle
movements
it sounded as though you were you were
critical of of the fact that cyclists
and pedestrians wanted to cross the road
i just wanted to be the reverse uh if i
put that across in that way i apologize
okay
i'm i'm
simply saying the consequence of that
being a heavily used pelican crossing
causes delaying the ashton road
yep
okay thank you
now just so when i revisit your evidence
i can actually follow what you're saying
i was confused on your page six
you're talking about traffic leaving the
development via the secondary access on
percycottis road
you tell me there's essentially two
alternative routes
and i i thought i'd followed them in the
main but i i couldn't on the map find
green way is that uh
did you say page six
i did yeah
page six um
[Music]
almost halfway down
it's a paragraph saying the access for
the homes proposed in phase three
is via percycottis road
i'm going through your original one yes
all right the paper right this page
seven in the okay yeah and the other one
yes sorry
i did say that i wasn't going to cross
reference but yes okay um yes there's a
it's a convoluted series of quite small
residential yeah
and i picked up most of them i i wasn't
sure i could spot green way so if you're
telling me it's definitely there i'll
have another look
greenway okay
um
[Music]
yeah i was going to ask you about the
the points that you'd raised about the
road safety audit relating to the percy
cottage road
sorry sir i've just been corrected the
house is called greenway it's still
percy cottage road oh it's a house
called greenway sorry about that right
that perhaps explains why i couldn't
find it but yeah okay
um yes i say i was going to just ask you
or
ask you a point about the stage one road
safety audit
that you referred to for the percycottis
access because
you've emboldened the fact that it
actually identifies three risks but in
your oral presentation you did then go
on to say
that
um solutions were suggested for that uh
whether or not you agree with i i just
wanted to quiz you because you hadn't
you you left it hanging as it were in
your original proof to to simply say
that three risks were identified
um
my take on that when i looked at that
was well yes they are but there are
explanations as to how it's considered
they would be addressed my take would be
appearance with that so in the sense
that looking well no that's still
correct but whether they would be
effective i think is where your your
difference is is it yeah i mean
they're definitely
put forward as as
the those reviewing the road safety
audit have responded by saying this is
three out of three issues identified
this is this is our
uh suggestions to how they would be
addressed indeed and and i must may i
add actually i mean i picked those three
to highlight the point
that arden said no risks were identified
okay but they were and there were others
identified as well
um okay
i think
now i'm going to give you a page in your
original one so you'll have to
relate that again but this is
i've got page nine this is where you're
talking about the essex county council
corporate response
and uh
you talk about the segregated cycle lane
being a misnomer so i think you did
still refer to that in the
version that you've been working from
today
it was just it was just really the point
that
what you've said here
is um
from the rochford supporters group's
perspective
a white line painted up the middle is
dangerous dangerous in that you say
informally a footpath
now with a white line paint up the
middle and dangerous in that
with hundreds of school children and
parents walking the path
and i think really that
what
what i want to say in that context and
just ask you there
is that
in terms of your evidence as a whole
um
and the uh obviously the um assertion
that the
residual communi cumulative impact
on the road network would be severe i
think it's writing to say the evidence
that you've put forward it's not
included any
traffic counts traffic figures
queue
assessments
it's
predominantly based on
the photographs and you've submitted a
lot of photographs to demonstrate the
points that you want to put forward
but they're they're not backed up by any
junction capacity assessments or traffic
flow information
and
on this one here you're telling me
hundreds of school children and parents
but you've not put any figures in to
support that have you okay i understand
that
it's quite a simple discussion in the
sense that the school
has a capacity of
the whole farm schools have a capacity
of 500 i think
500 roughly
and if you look at ashton road
on school days
before the school opens
most of them
are walking
the catchment area is very close
yeah the um it's just been pointed out
to be the
all schools in ashington area account
for 2346
pupils so 2346.
okay and on the matter of the
junction or traffic assessments formal
assessments as i said at the start that
we are relying on pictorial evidence and
experiences
and we are not
traffic
experts in terms of using the software
and we are
we are not funded
we are you know residents that are
interested in our area
don't tell me it wasn't it wasn't put
forward as a criticism as such it was it
was me just making sure i'd followed
your evidence correctly and i hadn't
overlooked anything in there absolutely
okay thank you
i do just need to
pick you up on your page
again it was it was to do with this
essex county council response
um
a few a few things about this but one of
one of them which i've got on page 10
and i'm sure you've got on a slightly
different page where you
you you refer you say the essex report
goes on to quote the department of
transport's gear change policy
and i i looked through the
full essex
council response and yes i picked out
the reference to gear change policy
sorry i'll just wait while you
so it was it was page 10 on your
original submission
can't easily find it in this one you you
did
refer to it i do remember it very well
i'm just uh my brain is obviously a bit
scrambled at the moment sir yeah yeah
right if you'd like to ask a question
i'll try and answer oh here we are i
think i think our face so i think it's
actually page 11 in your um
the version your your revised version
that you submitted so on page 11
there's quite a lot of text and you're
you're going on
about about two inches down from the top
the essex report goes on to say quoting
the department for transports gear
change policy and then you start say a
few things there
but then a little bit further down you
actually say
it would be
contrary not compliant with the mppf
recommendation
that users should be and you put in
quotes physically separated on urban
streets
so when i saw that i thought you put in
quotes you've referred to the mppf so so
let me have a look in the mppf and see
where that is and i i couldn't find it
so i think what i'm trying to say is
although that you're
implying there that that's
something in which the proposal would be
in conflict with an mppf recommendation
i don't think that's strictly correct i
think the section that i put in quotes
was in the essex report yes i think that
you're right
the bits in quotes relate to
the essex report but but reading that
you you think i want to say it's not
compliant with the mppf recommendation
so
just highlighting that that wasn't how i
read that
and you know the point i made is um
white line isn't physical separation
okay there's a curb up the middle or
something no no yeah i i understand that
point yeah
just another point though on
you you you were at pains to say that
the
the non-statutory council t areas of
essex county council
were
not included in the report to the
development committee i'm not quite sure
if that's correct is it because when
when i looked through the
the nov the 26th of november committee
report
i i picked out most of those points in
the essex
comprehensive response
were reported in there
um
i i jotted down
4.54 to 4.61
these are paragraphs in the committee
report
4.73
4.11
with highways that
subsumed within that at 462 to 472. so
i'm not asking you to go and look at it
now but i'm just really
you you've highlighted the fact that as
far as the supporters group's concerned
those points weren't
put forward to members
i don't think that's correct but okay
what i can say is the members didn't
discuss them there was a it was a mitch
maybe well that may be a totally
different discussion but it's a very
very thick report yes and typically the
members
focus on things that get highlighted by
the officers for them often
and
my point is that by those items not
being discussed
they therefore weren't included in the
deferral and therefore weren't
uh actually
able to be discussed in the
uh june meeting when it came back
because the risk the discussion was
restricted to the reasons for deferral
yeah i mean
that that may well be the case and you
know i'm not
not suggesting anything other than that
but
in terms of whether or not that
information was available to councillors
council members
in the november report i i think as i
say when when i saw you you tell me it
wasn't i thought well i'd better check
that and it looked to me as though it
was but it may well be as you say that
it wasn't focused upon that in a
discussion i'm sure you'll realize i'll
go and read it myself again
yeah yeah say it's not it's it isn't a
criticism it's it's a clarification
really there
so i'm so sorry to interrupt um just
just a point as well it's just a
reference note as well from me if i may
um in court document 5.1 which is the
24th of june report
and it's the addendum report
at paragraph 2.34
there's reference there to an updated
additional consultation response has
been received dated the 12th of february
2021 from essex county council
and that's the one which is that that
response is the letter that's been
referred to okay
let me say that response is the letter
sorry sorry
that that in in cat you were calling
councillor shaw's councillor has got
them in her appendices
council sure i think it's also in the
court documents but i've been using
councillor shaw
appendix for
yeah letter
february 2021
right
which
yes so that's that's the that's the
second one and so so the
the earlier committee report had the
corporate response which is the appendix
ii
and then and then this later one is
referred to in that addendum report also
yes so so but in in effect
both of the essex county council
responses were before members one one
was in the
earlier committee report and one was an
as an
addendum or whatever to the second
report
is that correct correct okay yeah and
it's it's that it's that 2.34 to 2.35 in
that addendum report at core document
5.1
that's referring to that later document
of the 12th of february 2021 in addition
to the points that you've just raised
sir in terms of references so that was
in the june 2021
development committee sorry i couldn't
hear you very well i'm sure yeah i'm so
sorry yes and and if you if you if you
go to later if you want to find it's
core document 5.1
and it's page 6.9 okay and it's
paragraph 2.34 to 2.35
okay
i suspect i missed that because i was
thrown off the development committee in
june
okay well thank you thank you for that
um
i don't
i think we
just about the end of what
i wanted to check with you
mr foster i think the
the only one bit that
um
you didn't
well i better better just check on on
here but yeah on those uh bits that i
asked you if you were going to cover
um in your
presentation earlier
when you said be remiss not to mention
others
and i turned over the page and i saw
they were the bullet points that were in
the original
bit here your original statement the
only one i wanted to check with you is
your your third one um where you say
risk to rochford conservation area i
just wanted to be clear
what what what risk you're saying there
would be to the conservation that's the
the bit i withdrew originally in the
sense of the um
environmental okay the risk is about
traffic
so so should i score it out here then or
what or i need to see
well it's just the bullet point that
says
risk to rockford conservation area
that's about traffic sir
any risk that i've included in the in
the actual report
that i've just made
about rochford conservation areas about
traffic impact
okay so so just so i'm clear what what
what are you saying that there
that that would be unacceptable or i i i
refer that to the high court judgment
that i mentioned
which was that the coombs farm
development
was uh not including the local plan
because of traffic impact on the
conservation area and i was explaining
that the yeah okay so it's so it's a
it's a traffic impact that you would
have some concerns about
okay
okay thank you
so so that was all there just when you
went through
the
um
the second or other the revised version
i
put a few more flags on so i think some
of them were
the same points just let me
quickly check yes
uh
now i think
i think that's it
thank you mr foster so i haven't got any
more questions you've had no questions
put to you
by uh miss reed
had you have had an advocate taking you
through your evidence this would be the
point now where i'd ask if any
re-examination was required so i'll give
you the opportunity if if you've given
me an answer to a question earlier and
you've had time to reflect and you think
i didn't explain that very well let me
clarify it i'll let you do that now but
if you're content that everything you
said was fine we can just say that's the
end of your cross-examination i'm
content sir
okay thank you so we've got to 1705 so a
good time to
to break so thank you very much for uh
your contribution thanks to foster thank
you mrs austin and uh
you may re-take your seats and
start to remove your uh display boards
as it were thank you
you need us to move those now no no
sorry you can do that
so um
let's just reflect where we are
well
so i think
my my preference given that we're now
after five o'clock and even if we were
bashing on was we'd need a comfort break
anyway would be to break until i'm quite
happy to start again tomorrow morning
earlier but to start a fresh tomorrow
it's been quite a long day and oh yes
yes
had we have finished earlier then i
would have been toying with whether or
not we could start the appellant's
evidence but i think we've we've had a
long day we started at uh at nine
um
just let me tell you though i mean
clearly what we've
what i need to happen um we need i don't
know if it's come through but we need
that uh statement from mrs crosby ms
crosby
um the written reps it's not essential
that it's in before the appellant's
evidence but you know that would be
ideal in case of something that you
needed to take any of your
ah
thank you
thank you yeah thank you yeah
okay well we'll have a look at that
overnight and obviously we can
can see what that says
um
yeah so what i was going to say is based
on your
time estimates and my
run through how i thought it might pan
out
i thought that we might be talking um
you sorry it's mr blair first is it for
you yeah
i'd got um
i got a total there of 5 hours and 15
minutes
and that's taken on board
your
uppermost
estimate for
evidence in chief
mr parkinson's
upper estimate of two hours for
cross-examination
i've put in half an hour for
cross-examination from the rule six
party which may or may not be
close to it anyway cut a long story
short five hours fifteen so what i'm
getting around to
is if we have an early start tomorrow
again possibly nine o'clock if people
are happy with that nine o'clock
then
with the fair wind we ought to
definitely get through mr blair tomorrow
yeah on that basis that would leave mr
pinecroft to be dealt with next tuesday
um i understand mr parkinson what you
said yesterday we're not going to be
able to start till half past 10 next
tuesday is that right
yes
okay so that's
that's a bit of a bloke it means we
can't we can't get a a a racing start
but again
i'm trying to pin anyone down to these
times but i i've got three three three
and three quarter hours in total for mr
pycroft on a similar sort of
basis so certainly on the planning
evidence obviously we're gonna
i can't put points mr mycroft that's um
well having called a planning witness
i'm then constrained in some of the
points i take so we'll just need to
i can't remember what i put down well
you said an hour no i don't know i mean
yes i mean by all means reflect on this
yeah and come back to me and but what
what i'm really saying there is mr blair
tomorrow
mr pinecroft possibly
finished
tuesday morning early tuesday afternoon
so i think where i'm going with this is
that uh if if we then tried to do the
conditions and section 106 straight
after mr pycroft it would mean that we
wouldn't do the site visit on tuesday
afternoon but we would do that
on wednesday morning instead and then
have closings sometime wednesday
afternoon
okay
so that so that's plan a
plan b might be that well we still do
the site visit on tuesday afternoon but
that would mean leaving the
conditions and section 106 to
wednesday morning
and follow that by the site by the close
closings
i'm just floating options here to see if
there's any
preference from one side or the other as
to how that would work
you
um so from from my perspective mr
parkinson might have a different
perspective on his instructions and
we can be flexible because
my team doesn't necessarily need me here
for the 106 and the conditions session
on the basis it's around table
discussion and i think in terms of 106
um our solicitor is going to be dealing
with that who's been um
negotiating that in any event
so on that basis so whether from my
perspective i can use the conditions
section 106 and site visit time to do to
write my closing and therefore it
doesn't matter from our team's
perspective which way round you do it
yep understood
are you in a similar position i i know
that um
uh it's likely to be a
case officer for the conditions session
so you may or may not have wanted to be
there mr parkinson i don't know but um i
think we haven't decided yet i mean i
may be here but not speaking and typing
instead okay just in case anything comes
up
are you equally flexible then whether we
have site visit on tuesday afternoon
whatever time after we've finished with
mr pycroft of course there is your air
quality
um witness who we may need virtually
that may also need to be on tuesday
afternoon so i think i think my
preference is on this basis that we try
and deal with
all of the uh the evidence and the
conditions session etcetera on the
tuesday
that certainly works for us
and and then with a view to starting at
what time on wednesday well if we had
the site visit in the morning that you
could have a fairly lengthy uh site
there i'm not saying that
the minute the site is over we start
closing submissions i'd say time
two o'clock or whatever 1 30 or 2
o'clock on the wednesday for coming back
for
closing submissions but the only the
only reason i asked on that and it's
it's not to do with finishing closing
submissions because i
probably aim to have got them done on
tuesday evening it's just that
i have a hospital appointment
in the morning on wednesday well all
right um which i'd quite need to go to i
mean obviously this takes priority but
there was a way that i could do that and
then come down for the closings at two
o'clock then that would that would help
as far as i'm concerned it sounds like
it's it's going to work in a way because
we've done it i'm very happy i'm very
happy to fit around that mr foster from
the rule six parties group if i know we
we'd said you know a couple of days ago
that we were possibly looking at tuesday
afternoon for the site visit but if it
ends up being wednesday morning are you
still content with that
yeah okay and we can obviously
agree what time we would start i mean
and whether or not
it's all done in one bit or if we do a
bit and then come back at another of
your selected times as long as long as
we can finish it as a time that allows
us to start closing submissions at an
appropriate time i mean that would
either be two o'clock or i might have
gone from 1 30 depending on whether i
think a lot of interested persons want
to to
summarize their cases because that'll
take a little bit of time as well
but basically i've got an hour an hour i
think and 40 minutes or thereabouts as
estimates so if we start at two we
should finish by five or not much after
and so just in terms of the timetable
then um i suppose a couple of points one
one option in terms of the air quality
expert i mean i need to take
instructions on his availability he's
fine right okay
one option will be to
depending on how far we get with mr
blair tomorrow but just make him
available if we get to a point where we
can fit him in before closed to make
best use of time rather tomorrow
certainly rather than start mr pycroft
and it be split and that that would seem
to make sense if we if we get to a point
where we can do that we can then start
on tuesday mr pycroff's evidence all
and then proceed in the way that you've
suggested yeah well if if we start at
nine tomorrow um and we go through till
i said about half past three yeah
what's that nine half past three that's
six and a half hours isn't it take off
at least half an hour for lunch that's
six take out a mid-morning break so
we're it looks so we will get mr blair
done and possibly have a bit of time for
um air quality if if that works out well
for
parties involved i'm great but if it
doesn't work then he'd be available on
tuesday as well he would yeah yeah so
i'll work on the basis that i don't need
to go through matters with mr pycroft um
for tomorrow and that we're starting his
evidence on on tuesday then sir okay on
that basis yeah yeah all sounds good
right okay well i was going to ask for
the attendance list back but i see it's
here is there anyone who hasn't signed
you attended oh
can someone get the list to
that end please sorry sir just briefly
just so i'm clear so it's nine o'clock
start in the morning until 3 30. if
everyone's happy with that i think it's
good if we can and then we get a good
start so yeah
yeah
anything else from any other parties
before i adjourn
no okay
thank you then on that note i'll adjourn
now will resume tomorrow at nine o'clock
thank you
you